[Musique]
François Xavier Bélanie, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinement ? Je suis
François Xavier Benami. Je suis euh prof
de philo, c'est mon métier. J'ai eu la
joie d'exercer ce métier pendant plus de
10 ans. Et euh en parallèle de ça, je me
suis engagé en politique euh dans ma
ville, d'abord sur le terrain local et
puis ensuite euh dans le débat public
pour parler en part de la crise de
l'école. J'espère qu'on en parlera ce
soir parce que c'est le sujet, je crois,
le plus déterminant pour l'avenir du
pays. Et certainement et euh et puis et
puis en 2018, euh les Républicains dont
je n'étais pas membre à l'époque m'ont
proposé d'être leur tête de liste pour
l'élection européenne.
C'était
évidemment une mission difficile mais
une mission passionnante. Et je me suis
engagé parce que comme des millions de
Français, je je me résigne pas à ce que
mon pays s'effondre. Et euh et depuis
2019, je suis au Parlement européen,
j'ai été euh élu puis réélu en 2024 et
je me bats tous les jours avec euh les
collègues de la délégation que j'ai le
le l'honneur de de diriger. Euh je me
bats tous les jours pour essayer de de
faire entendre la voix de la France et
les Français dans les institutions
européennes et les combats sont souvent
difficiles. On en reparlera
certainement.
On va parler ce soir d'Union européenne,
de monnaie, de stabilité, de guerre, de
guerre économique, de renseignement
peut-être et tout un tas de vérol
d'ingérence extérieure ou étrangère. On
commence par quoi ? On commence sur le
fait pourquoi vous dites que la France
va s'effondrer ?
Il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux. Je dis pas
qu'elle va s'effondrer, mais on la voit
s'effondrer aujourd'hui. On la voit
s'effondrer sur elle-même. C'est pas
seulement la vie politique du pays, mais
c'est euh la réalité que vivent tous les
jours les Français. Euh la réalité
d'abord d'un appauvrissement collectif
qui est indénégéniable aujourd'hui. Euh
la réalité d'une situation que plus rien
ne maîtrise sur le plan euh de la
sécurité, de l'immigration d'un état qui
est défaillant dans ses missions
fondamentales alors qu'il a jamais
prélevé autant d'impôts et qu'il a
jamais autant endetté la société. Euh je
crois que tous les Français le savent et
il faudrait vraiment céder à un déniis
de réalité absolument stupéfiant pour ne
pas voir qu'aujourd'hui la France est
sans doute euh menacé de de disparaître.
Je je dis pas qu'elle va disparaître.
Encore une fois, je crois que l'histoire
est d'abord ce que nous en ferons. Mais
si je me suis engagé en politique, c'est
parce que je me résigne pas à voir se
perdre tout ce à quoi je tiens et tout
ce qui me tient et tout ce qui m'a fait.
Euh et je parlais de la crise de
l'éducation parce que je crois qu'elle
est vitale parce que je crois qu'à
travers elle, c'est toute la crise du
pays qui se vit.
Euh pourquoi vous avez soutenu euh
Ursula Van Derleyen ?
J'ai pas soutenu Ursula Van Derleen.
Je me suis engagé euh en 2024. En 2019,
Ursula Vlon a été choisi par Emmanuel
Macron. C'était pas la candidate de la
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartenais au Parlement européen. Le
PPE.
Le candidat du PPE c'était Mfred Weber.
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé, il a dit "Je
veux pas de Manfred Weber. Bien que le
PPE avait gagné les élections
européennes." Donc en théorie, c'est lui
qui devait présider la Commission
européenne. C'est Emmanuel Macron qui
s'est associé avec Victor Urban à
l'époque pour disqualifier Manfred
Weber. Il voulait nommer quelqu'un qui
lui devrait sa légitimité. C'est une
habitude chez lui. Il veut que les gens
lui doivent tout. Et donc il a il a
refusé la nomination de Manfred Weber
qui aurait eu la légitimité d'avoir été
portée par la formation politique qui
avait gagné cette élection en Europe. Et
et à ce moment-là
a été trouvé le nom entre Emmanuel
Macron et Angela Merkel, ils ont trouvé
Ursula Vanerle qui avait jamais eu une
seule responsabilité sur la scène
européenne, qui était ministre de la
défense en Allemagne à l'époque et et
donc elle a été nommée présidente de la
Commission européenne et elle a présidé
la Commission pendant le premier mandat
où j'étais pour ma part au Parlement
européen. Et on voit le le le bilan de
ce premier mandat, j'ai été pendant
comme comme d'ailleurs la plupart de de
de mon groupe, on a été sur la plupart
des textes dans l'opposition sur
beaucoup des textes qui ont constitué
notamment ce qui s'est appelé le Green
Deal, le 100 % véhicule électrique, la
politique antinucléaire, euh la
stratégie de décroissance qui était
imposée à notre industrie, à notre
agriculture, à la filière de la pêche.
Sur tous ces sujets là, on s'est on
s'est battu, on a résisté et en 2024,
j'ai fait campagne en disant si on est
assez nombreux au Parlement européen,
demain on s'opposera à la reconduction
d'Ursula Funderlon. C'était le principe
de de de l'engagement qu'on prenait. Et
donc, j'ai voté contre sa reconduction.
Elle a trouvé une majorité, elle a été
reconduite, elle a été renommée par les
chefs d'état d'abord parce que c'est eux
qui prennent la responsabilité et au
Parlement, elle a trouvé une majorité.
Euh la Commission, elle a complètement
changé parce que les équilibres
politiques entre-temps ont complètement
changé en Europe. Mais je n'ai je n'ai
pas soutenu Ursula Funderlion pour la
raison que j'évoquais. Il y a rien de de
personnel là-dedans. C'est d'abord de la
politique et c'est des lignes
politiques. Et ma conviction profonde en
2024, c'est que l'Europe avait pas
besoin de continuité mais qu'elle avait
besoin de changement. Et ça reste ma
conviction aujourd'hui.
Avant de commencer l'interview, on a été
boire un café dans un Kawa
français d'ailleurs qui doit encore
faire ses baguettes maintenant. Euh
sur les vaccins, l'Europe, la
déclassification des contrats, vous êtes
positionné comment ? Moi, j'ai toujours
voté pour la transparence des contrats.
Je pense qu'on peut pas faire des
contrats d'une telle importance sans
être transparent. Je pense que le vaccin
est une belle conquête scientifique et
que il a permis d'éradiquer beaucoup de
maladies. Je pense que la manière dont
on a utilisé le vaccin face à l'épidémie
du Covid, je le dis très simplement
parce que je suis pas moi-même médecin
ou épidémiologiste, mais on n pas besoin
d'être médecin ou épidémiologiste pour
savoir que ça n'avait aucun sens de
vacciner des enfants de 5 ans euh pour
savoir que le le vaccin pouvait
peut-être être utile pour protéger les
personnes vulnérables qui risquaient de
faire des formes graves, mais que cette
utilisation généralisée était totalement
disproportionnée. et j'ai été l'un de
ceux qui a qui a alerté les premiers
parce que c'était au Parlement européen
que ça a été créé contre la création du
pass sanitaire qui était pour moi un
recul absolument terrifiant dans le
principe même de notre vie démocratique.
À votre avis, si on prend un peu de
recul maintenant, nous sommes en 2025,
pourquoi ils ont réagi comme ça ?
Pourquoi il y a eu tant de panique ?
Pourquoi Emmanuel Macron nous disait
d'aller au théâtre avec sa femme et que
5 jours plus tard, on était tous
confinés ?
Il y a eu une absence délirante
d'anticipation. Euh le le le on a vu le
vaccin se se on a vu le le virus se
développer en Chine
et à l'époque vous étiez parmi les
premiers à alerter sur la situation.
Puis ensuite il est arrivé en Europe.
Moi il se trouve que j'étais en Italie
pour faire une série de je venais de
publier un bouquin qui était traduit en
italien. Donc j'étais en
comment il s'appelle le bouquin ? Je le
but est pas de faire la publicité du
bouquin. Il s'appelle Demeur et donc il
venait d'être traduit ce livre en
italien et j'aiétais invité en Italie
pour présenter le le livre au moment où
l'épidémie était en train de frapper
l'Italie. Et je me souviens de ce que
j'ai vécu, une sorte de dissonance
cognitive hallucinant. Je je voyais les
Italiens en train de vivre le choc de
cette première vague de l'épidémie qui
était objectivement la plus la plus la
plus rude comme toutes les premières
vagues d'épidémie. Euh et puis j'arrive
en France, je reprends mon avion, je
rentre en France et là je vois une
insouciance absolue et toute la France
qui se moquait des Italiens et tous nos
dirigeants en particulier qui
entretenaient l'idée que les Italiens
sont des branquignoles, qui savent pas
gérer un système de santé mais que nous
avons bien sûr le meilleur système de
santé du monde et que on va voir ce
qu'on va voir. De mois plus tard, on
envoyait nos infirmières avec des des
des blouses faites dans des sacs
poubelles pour aller à l'hôpital quand
plus personne ne voulait y aller. que on
on a vécu un défaut d'anticipation
absolument stupéfiant et ensuite ce qui
était un manque de prévision est devenu
une sorte d'excès de de de
d'action. Enfin, je je je crois vraiment
que la manière dont on a abordé cette
situation était totalement hors de toute
proportion. Et je pense que d'ailleurs
je je le dis avec vous, c'est bien qu'on
en parle parce qu'en fait
tutoyer si vous voulez hein,
tutoyons-nous. C'est bien qu'on en
parle. parce qu'en fait on n jamais
reparlé de cette période là et je pense
qu'elle a laissé une blessure très grave
dans la société française pour plusieurs
raisons. D'abord parce que il y a eu
objectivement un usage de la parole
publique qui était totalement
non maîtrisé pour le dire d'une manière
très euphémistique. Quand le premier
ministre de la France Jean Castex à
l'époque va sur un plateau de télévision
et dit si vous êtes vacciné vous pourrez
ni contaminé ni contagieux c'est faux.
Et donc on a vu dans des circonstances
très solennelles les plus hautes
autorités de l'État produire des
messages qui se sont avérés être faux.
Et personne n'est revenu là-dessus. Et
la crise de confiance dans la parole
publique, elle vient pas seulement mais
elle vient aussi en partie de ce
moment-là. La deuxième chose, c'est que
on a vécu des situations qui étaient
proprement inhumaines. Il y a des gens
qui dans nos hôpitaux sont morts, pas
seulement du Covid mais de plein
d'autres maladies tout simplement de
vieillesse, sont morts seuls que leurs
familles ont pas pu aller voir, que
leurs familles ont pas pu accompagner.
Il y a des gens qui ont pas été enterrés
comme il l'aurait fallu. Et ça c'est une
rupture très profonde. Je le dis pardon.
C'est c'est du point de vue de
l'anthropologie.
Quand on étudie l'anthropologie, on voit
que ce qui distingue l'humanité, ce qui
distingue l'homme, c'est deux choses.
C'est les outils, la technique et c'est
le fait d'enterrer les morts. On trouve
la trace de l'homme quand on trouve des
traces d'outils et des traces de tombes.
Le fait qu'on nit pas enterré nos morts,
c'était quelque chose comme une rupture
extrêmement grave, extrêmement profonde.
Et on n'est jamais revenu sur ça. On on
n jamais même fait mémoire de ce qui
avait été vécu à ce moment-là. Et puis
la 3è chose et moi c'est un sujet qui
pour moi est toujours d'actualité, c'est
qu'on a vu à quel point la peur la peur
des dirigeants, la peur de la société
euh la peur pouvait conduire à faire des
choix qui sont extrêmement inquiétants
du point de vue des principes
fondamentaux. Le fait qu'on demande un
document de santé à des gens pour
rentrer dans un café, pour aller dans un
bistro, pour rentrer dans un espace
public, dans un service public, le fait
qu'on ait un président de la République
qui est assumé de vouloir mener une
politique de discrimination alors que le
vaccin n'était pas obligatoire. Vous
vous souvenez de cette formule
incroyable d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait
dit "Je rêve d'emmerder les non
vaccinés". Mais mais on a vécu là des
des expériences de ségrégation dans la
société qui sont d'une brutalité inouie.
Et et moi je le redis encore une fois,
je je
alors que l'élite faisait bamboche euh
tranquille sans masque, il mettait les
masques au dernier moment, tout allait
bien.
En tous les cas, il y avait une grande
hypocrisie sur sur le sujet. Moi, je me
souviens encore une fois, je je
j'assumais une rupture qui était pas
évidente à l'époque parce qu'on a on a
on a un peu oublié, mais j'avais publié
un texte euh sur la question du pass
sanitaire. À l'époque, c'était tellement
l'ambiance était tellement délirante que
le seul fait de parler de ça vous valait
d'être immédiatement traité d'antivax
complètement obscur.
C'est c'est absurde. C'est c'est cette
politique là qui était de
l'obscurantisme du point de vue de la
science, de l'épidémiologie et de la
connaissance que nous avons de ce que
produit un vaccin comme effet.
le le le fait est que euh dans dans ce
moment-là, j'ai vu plusieurs personnes,
plusieurs responsables politique par
exemple venir me dire "Non mais OK, je
je comprends que tu es un problème mais
tu sais les mêmes qui à la télévision
disaient il faut vacciner tout le monde
et moi je je sais comment faire des des
faux des faux passes sanitaires ou si tu
veux je peux te moi j'ai jamais fait un
faux jamais parce que je crois que il
faut s'appliquer
la la règle qu'on défend en public je je
je je je je je je je je vois qu'il y a
eu dans ce moment-là effectivement une
forme d'hypocrisie et là encore tout ça
pèse sur le débat public aujourd'hui.
Bon par
et c'est important qu'on qu'on revienne
là-dessus parce que parce que
pourquoi il faut des têtes tomb qui
tombent des gens en prison ? Il faut
quoi ? Il faut que ce soit traité au
pénal. Comment ça se passe ?
Bah d'abord il faut que la transparence
soit faite. Typiquement vous parliez des
contrats de vaccin. C'est un sujet qui
reste d'actualité.
La la médiatrice de l'Union européenne
qui est l'institution qui doit garantir
les droits des citoyens. Je je pense
c'est la même chose que vous de
l'efficacité de la chose, mais le fait
est que
elle a quand même publié un rapport très
très ferme et on peut pas l'accuser
d'être une officine obscure de
propagande
antie-européenne. Elle est au cœur des
institutions. Elle a publié un un
rapport pour dire qu'il y avait un vrai
sujet de de transparence sur ces
contrats. Il faut faut il faut aller au
bout.
Et puis surtout, il aurait fallu enfin
je pense voilà comme toute société quand
elle traverse un choc comme celui-là, il
faut il faut simplement qu'on en parle
et et aujourd'hui c'est comme si
vous êtes un peu bisouours non
non pourquoi dire la conduite
introspective du pouvoir politique du
pouvoir journalistique ils sont plantés
lamentablement vous croyez qu'ils vont
aller mettre le sujet sur la table il
faut qu'on en parle c'est encore il y a
qu'à faux compte politique ça non
non parce que
je me fais l'avoquer du diable parce que
personne ne dit ça justement. Personne
ne dit ça et il y a qui a qui a quiici
qu'on peut qu'on peut en parler d'une
certaine manière. En tous les cas, ça
m'est jamais arrivé depuis que cette
période est derrière nous. Ça m'est
jamais arrivé de de de reparler de ce
moment et je pense qu'il faut et je dis
pas ça il faut au sens où il faut
attendre que les politiques le fassent
mais il faut que la société rouvre la
discussion sur ce sujet-là. C'est clair.
Sous peine de quoi ?
En fait, moi ce qui me frappe, c'est que
d'une manière générale, un des symptômes
et on en parlait avec le le patron du
bistro chez qui on était tout à l'heure,
euh
honorable établissement,
très honorable établissement. Euh
mais ce qui ce qui est frappant dans la
crise qu'on traverse aujourd'hui, c'est
qu'effectivement c'est une crise et
notamment la crise politique, c'est une
crise de l'irresponsabilité politique.
Plus personne n'est responsable de rien.
En tous les cas, en haut, plus personne
n'est responsable de rien. En bas, tout
le monde est responsable de tout. Euh si
le patron de ce bistro chez qui on était
euh se plante dans dans sa déclaration
de revenu, il y a peu de doutes que il
va prendre. En revanche,
euh regardez ce qui vient de se passer
euh avec cette
incroyable cambriolage au Louvre.
Objectivement, tout est défaillant sur
toute la ligne.
Non, je peux pas vous laisser dire ça.
Rashidanati a dit que
que tout avait bien fonctionné
et que et que voilà,
tout va pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes. On
rentre dans du beurre en moins de 4
minutes clé en mainant.
Mais c'est pas seulement le Louvre,
c'est l'incendie de Notre-Dame.
Que ce soit difficile de trouver
l'origine de l'incendie, j'imagine que
tous les enquêteurs qui se sont mis sur
le dossier qui a été amené par une
mouette,
que ce soit difficile de trouver, je
suis pas spécialiste peut-être, mais le
fait est que il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements sur toute la ligne.
Pas un coup de disqueuse qui a mis le
feu à la à la poussière sur les poutres.
En tous les cas, c'est un fait et ça
pour le coup personne peut le contester.
On a même pas besoin d'être enquêteur
pour le savoir. C'est un fait que les
systèmes d'alarme ont pas fonctionné,
que le type qui était dans son poste de
sécurité, il était pas formé pour ça,
que c'était son premier jour qu'il était
censé être deux et qu'en fait il était
tout seul. C'est un fait qu'il a
désamorcé l'alarme alors que le feu
brûlait sans se rendre compte de ce qui
se passait. Et en fait, c'est même pas
tellement son sujet. C'est le sujet de
ceux qui ont laissé cette situation de
vulnérabilité globale s'installer
pendant si longtemps. Quand un feu de
cette ampleur prend dans les combles de
Notre Dame, c'est qu'il y a une
succession de problèmes de grande
ampleur qui pendant longtemps ont duré.
Moi, je je je suis pas spécialiste
d'incendie, mais quand j'ai le temps,
c'est-à-dire pas assez souvent, je fais
de la voile, je navigue, je je pense que
la la mer, c'est une école de la vie. Et
en mer, on apprend un truc, il y a il y
a jamais d'accidents qui surviennent à
partir de rien. Quand vous avez un
accident, c'est toujours même partant
calme et même quand tout allait avait
l'air d'aller d'aller bien, c'est
toujours parce qu'il y a eu une série de
négligences d'abord qui conduisent à ce
qu'à la fin la pire catastrophe arrive.
Euh et et en fait euh euh on a perdu
dans dans dans la société on a perdu
dans la politique, dans la vie politique
du pays ce sens de la responsabilité et
je dirais même, pardon, vous allez dire
que je suis bisouns, mais je vais
employer un mot qui je pense mériterait
d'être remis au goût du jour. On a perdu
le sens de l'honneur. À la fin, quand
vous dirigez un établissement, quand cet
établissement est sous votre
responsabilité, quand vous avez
l'honneur de diriger le plus grand musée
du monde, bah vous faites pas semblant
que votre lettre de démission a été
refusée. Si si vous aviez sous votre
garde les joyaux de la couronne de
France et qu'ils ont été volés, OK,
c'est pas vous qui les avez volés, OK,
c'est pas vous qui faisiez marcher
l'alarme, mais c'est pas grave, vous
êtes le chef et le chef, il est là pour
assumer. et et on s'est tellement
habitué à ce que les chefs n'assument
plus et à la fin quand plus personne en
haut n'assume, c'est ceux qui sont en
bas qui payent. Et c'est ça la réalité
de la situation de la France
aujourd'hui. Vous avez des gens qui
risquent rien en haut et qui font payer
en permanence à ceux qui risquent tout
en bas. C'est
Sarkozi Sarkozy est en zonzon là quand
même, non ?
Ouais. Oui, ben alors là ça sert encore
un autre problème. Je suis pas sûr que
Sarkozi
en l'occurrence je pense que Sarkozi
certains lui font payer la la ligne
qu'il a tenue pendant longtemps et qui a
manifestement déplu au même syndicat qui
faisait le mur des cons. Parce que là
aussi le mur des cons, arrêtons-nous
là-dessus. le mur des cons. Vous avez un
syndicat de magistrat, l'un des plus
importants, un syndicat de magistrat qui
affiche dans un local syndical un
panneau avec tous les gens qu'il
considèrent comme étant ses cibles.
Parce que qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
panneau comme ça ? Le mur des cons. Sur
cette cible, vous avez des politiques.
C'est votre interprétation, hein.
Bah, ça s'appelle le mur des cons,
pardon. Je sais pas comment il faut
l'appeler. Euh, je sais qu'il faut être
factuel. un trombinoscope.
Un trombinoscope. Bombinoscope s'appelle
quand même le mur des cons. Donc si vous
vous retrouvez sur un trombinoscope qui
s'appelle un mur de con, c'est qu'à
priori on vous tient pas en haute
estime.
Vous savez, vous savez ici on a un vieil
adage qui nous vient de notre
grand-mère, c'est "Méfie-toi de ceux qui
font des listes."
Euh oui, c'est vrai, vous avez raison.
les histoires de liste, ça a jamais
tellement réussi à notre pays. Mais bon
euh
mais bon, en l'occurrence, c'est pas une
liste innocente. Euh on on identifie ce
ce
mur des cons parce que des photos sont
prises, l'affaire est révélée. Est-ce
que ces magistrats ont été sanctionnés ?
Le manquement à leur devoir de
neutralité est absolument évident,
manifeste, il est absolument choquant et
il est tellement choquant qu'il est de
nature à discréditer l'institution
judiciaire dans son ensemble. Est-ce
qu'il y a eu la moindre sanction ? Je
pense qu'il y a eu une sanction mais
vraiment pour la forme qu'elle était
tellement anecdotique que tout le monde
l'a oublié. Moi le premier d'ailleurs
sont fait taper un peu sur les doigts.
Je je sais même le carem.
Ouais.
C'est quand le carême ?
Bah ça dépend des années. Je peux pas
dire la date du début du carême cette
année parce que je la connais pas par
cœur. Mais
c'est pour ça que vous az appelé
François Xavier ?
Euh parce que je suis cat. Bah en
l'occurrence Saint-Fançois Xavier un
immense personnage, immense qui
d'ailleurs a aussi enseigné la
philosophie à Paris.
Et mais non mais en même temps c'est
très beau que Cat ou non, pratiquant ou
non, on a pour beaucoup d'entre nous des
prénoms qui nous viennent de cette
histoire qui a fait notre pays et notre
civilisation. C'est c'est ce qui nous
réunit tous en tous les cas. C'est ce
qui réunit beaucoup d'entre nous et
c'est ce qui fait que on a et là encore
quelle que soit notre histoire, queles
que soient nos convictions, on a on a en
commun d'être sui de regarder les
communes de France et le nom qu'elle
porte aujourd'hui. On a en commun d'être
pétri par cet héritage.
Si je vous dis ce que vous croyez dans
un ami imaginaire, ça vous choque ?
C'est un blasphème ? C'est quoi ? Non,
j'ai fait trop de philos pour être
choqué par quoi que ce soit. On peut
parler de de Nietzs de Ferbar, de Marx
autant que vous voudrez. Qui qui est-ce
qui aé qui a tué Dieu ?
Nietzsche Nietzsche il a il dit pas
qu'il a tué Dieu, il dit que nous avons
tué Dieu. Dieu a tué Nietzsche, hein.
Ça c'était la fameuse plaisanterie. Je
crois que c'est le cardinal de Lubac qui
qui
plaisantait en disant pendant le pendant
le le mai 68, il y avait ces ces ce
fameux graffiti Dieu est mort signé
Nietzsche et et je crois que c'est Lubac
qui avait plaisanté en disant Nietzsche
est mort signé Dieu.
Et c'est très beau le c'est c'est un
thème qui revient dans toute la pensée
de de Nietzsche et Nietzsche ne dit pas
du tout ça
pour s'en réjouir ou pour expliquer que
maintenant Dieu est mort, tout est
permis et que ce serait le début d'un
hédonisme tranquille. Quand N dit que
Dieu est mort, il dit que nous avons tué
Dieu, c'està-dire la civilisation
occidentale a tué Dieu et que la mort de
Dieu annonce un renversement qui va être
l'occasion d'un d'un bouleversement sans
précédent. dans l'histoire de de de la
civilisation.
C'est dans le gay savoir qu'il y a ce
texte extraordinaire sur le le fou qui
qui se promène en pleine rue avec une
une lanterne allumée en plein jour et
qui dit "Je cherche Dieu, je cherche
Dieu." Et tout le monde se moque de lui
et le prend pour un fou. Et le fou casse
sa lanterne et dit "Mais vous ne savez
pas où est Dieu. Nous l'avons tué. Nous
l'avons tué et nous sommes responsables
de de cette mort."
Euh et et ensuite l'insensé annonce euh
le fait que tout va perdre son sens, que
tout va se renverser. Euh mais c'est pas
du tout chez Niet une prédiction
euphorique ou tranquillisante. C'est
c'est et de fait aujourd'hui peut-être
je dis ça sans sans là pour le coup
vraiment sans sans sans me référer à une
perspective de foi. Mais aujourd'hui
peut-être dans la société on cherche la
la trace de de de ce manque que que qui
qui habite encore finalement même nos
nos débats les plus les plus concrets.
C'est
c'est un manque. C'est un manque de quoi
? espoir
déguisé
sous de la dopamine de la croyance.
C'est quoi ? Non, mais on on fait partie
à l'échelle de l'histoire des
civilisations de de rares civilisations
qui se qui se construisent de sociétés
qui se construisent sans euh l'idée la
référence commune à un absolu. Et c'est
pas facile en fait de vivre sans ça.
C'est pas simple
pour le commun des mortels.
Euh c'est pas simple pour une société
tout court. Moi, je je crois
profondément à la laïcité. Je crois
profondément à la laïcité. Je pense
vraiment qu'on a on a besoin de de euh
parce que après tout la laïcité c'est la
c'est la c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on
vit aussi en philosophie quand vous
quand vous quand vous vous confrontez à
une question de philosophie vous vous
vous n'y répondez pas avec les arguments
d'une vérité révélée. Vous faites
l'effort de votre de votre simple
raison.
C'est combien le PIB français ?
Mais mais je mais je pense que je pense
que la laïcité elle trouve en fait son
origine dans cet héritage dans cet
héritage.
Combien de milliards le PIB français ?
Je saais pas vous répondre. Comment ?
Je saurais pas vous répondre.
Combien de milliards ? 3000 milliards.
Non, je saurais pas vous répondre.
La France La France consomme combien de
millions de barils de pétrole par jour ?
Je saurais pas vous répondre non plus.
D'hydrocarburant.
De toute façon, ce qui compte le plus
dans le PIB, c'est pas tant la valeur
absolue que son évolution à la dynamique
dans sens ou dans un autre. C'est ça la
chose la plus déterminante.
Si je vous parle d'énergie, d'Europe,
par d'énergie. Ça c'est un sujet
fascinant.
Quand je suis rentré au Parlement
européen en 2019, je me suis engagé en
commission
la commission qui s'appelle ITR qui
s'occupe de l'industrie et l'énergie.
Ouais.
J'ai un député européen en face de moi
qui connaît pas le PIB français. Donc
là, je vais passer de hard à
destruction.
Allez-y, il y a pas de problème.
Je je je suis pas sûr que le fait de de
vous rappeler, c'est Jean-Jacques
Bourdin qui faisait toujours ce genre de
question. Je je je sais pas si c'est en
éisant des encyclopédies que vous aurez
la meilleure manière d'avoir des
réponses politiques adaptées au défi du
moment.
Le prix de la baguette.
Bah le prix de la baguette, ça dépend où
vous êtes mais aujourd'hui chez moi 1,20
€
le prix du ticket de métro il a il a
augmenté mais parce que maintenant ça
c'est ça s'est fusionné maintenant c'est
2,50 € en Île-de-France.
Le prix du MAW
Ouais OK. Ça ça devient honnêtement ça
devient ça devient absurde. Je vais pas
répondre à ces questions. Je suis rentré
en commission de l'industrie et de
l'énergie parce que je pensais que la la
reconstruction du pays passerait d'abord
par la reconstruction de sa base
industrielle. La part de l'industrie
dans le pip français a jamais été aussi
faible. Ça pour le coup c'est 11 %.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on s'est complètement
désindustrialisé. Parce qu'on a rêvé
qu'on allait devenir une société de
service. Parce qu'on a pensé que
l'industrie c'était sale, que produire
c'était coupable.
C'est qui on pensait ? Bah, c'est toute
la génération des dirigeants, pas
seulement politiques, mais aussi
économique. C'était euh
localisation heureuse.
Ouais. euh la la société sans industrie
et les les les usines sans ouvriers et
l'industrie sans usine.
Et puis aussi parce que on a aussi, il
faut le reconnaître, on a construit un
et ça c'est l'impasse politique à
laquelle on est toujours confronté
aujourd'hui. On a construit un modèle de
société,
un modèle économique, un modèle de
société de consommation,
un modèle de société d'assurance sociale
euh pyramide
qui crée qui crée des des des coûts
salariaux qui sont incompatibles avec le
maintien d'une activité industrielle
durable.
Est-ce que le système de retraite
français c'est une pyramide de Ponzi ?
Bien sûr, totalement. C'est pas
seulement une pyramide de Ponzi parce
qu'une pyramide de Ponzi, c'est un
système qui fonctionne fictivement
aujourd'hui et qui va s'effondrer
demain. Le système de retraite français,
il fonctionne pas aujourd'hui. Il est
déjà en train d'absorber la la vitalité
de la société. Le système de retraite
français, il est déjà aujourd'hui en
train de peser sur tout ce qui vit dans
ce pays, tout ce qui travaille, tout ce
qui crée, tout ce qui recrute, tout ce
qui innove. C'est c'est déjà en train de
se produire une pyramide de Pond et
c'est la catastrophe. Elle est pas
visible encore. Elle arrivera demain
quand tout va s'écrouler. Moi, je pense
que si on continue comme ça et en
particulier avec ce qu'on vient de
vivre, la suspension de la réforme des
retraites, si on continue dans cette
irréalité, ça va s'effondrer demain.
Euh, peut-être plutôt qu'on ne le croit
d'ailleurs. Mais la vérité, c'est que
c'est déjà en train de faire s'effondrer
le pays. La France, tiens, vous parliez
du PIB, ça c'est une statistique bien
plus importante sans doute que de
connaître la valeur absolue du PIB. Le
fait est que aujourd'hui la France,
c'est 33 % de PIB en dépenses sociale.
C'est unique. Il y a pas un pays qui
fait comme nous. 33 %. Et là-dedans, une
partie très substantielle, c'est les
retraites. 1 € euh sur sur 4 dépensé par
l'État, c'est les retraites. 33 % du PIB
dans la dépense sociale. Le l'OCDE, la
moyenne de l'OCDE, c'est 20 %. De
l'OCDE, hein, donc des pays développés
qui ont des systèmes sociaux et des
systèmes de solidarité. 33 % de de du
PIB part dans la dépense sociale. C'est
c'est juste intenable. Et et en fait
concrètement cette statistique qui
paraît abstraite, elle veut dire pour le
patron du bistro derrière que quand il
veut recruter quelqu'un
du restaurant.
Ouais, le patron du restaurant quand il
veut recruter quelqu'un, c'était pas
péjoratif hein. Péjoratif dans
J'aime j'aime les bistro bien sûr. Quand
il veut recruter quelqu'un,
vous savez d'où ça vient le mot bistro ?
Le mot bistro. Non,
ça doit venir de Russe. De Russie à mon
avis.
Bah prenez-le moi du coup. Non,
ça veut dire vite vite. Non,
bistro. Ah, je vois que je je vois qu'il
y en a qui ont la ref.
Euh bon, on reviendra sur le sujet plus
tard. On ira prendre une bière au
bistro. Je je disais que pour le patron
du restaurant, mais pour n'importe quel
patron en France, quand vous voulez
recruter quelqu'un, que vous voulez lui
payer un salaire, vous allez payer deux
fois.
Et tous les patrons de ce pays savent
ça. Et et ça c'est en particulier parce
qu'on a un système de solidarité
sociale, parce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
un modèle social qui est devenu en fait
un modèle antisocial. Un modèle
antisocial parce qu'il punit le travail
et que finalement en punissant le
travail, il finit par détruire la base
même sur laquelle il est construit. Et
ça fait partie des raisons de la
désindustrialisation. C'est pas la
seule.
Est-ce que vous pensez que l'Europe
l'Union européenne va se disloquer ?
Je pense qu'elle peut se disloquer.
Pourquoi ? que tout va bien, qu'on a
jamais été autant à se serrer les coudes
face à un ennemi, qu'on est là à
défendre la veuve, l'orphelin, la
démocratie, les Ukrainiens et nos
valeurs,
les bébés f, le réchauffement
climatique.
Je pense que l'Union européenne peut se
disloquer parce qu'elle a été conçue
pour un monde qui n'existe pas, en tout
cas qui n'existe plus et qu'elle a du
mal à sortir de la naïveté qui a été le
le le point de départ de de euh de de sa
conception.
C'était quoi à la base ? C'était un
déboucher pour les marchés américains ?
C'était une union du charbon ? C'était
quoi ? C'était un c'était le c'était euh
le le Moi, je suis frappé de voir à quel
point l'Europe, l'Union européenne vit
l'histoire. C'est euh c'est
Fuyama, c'est ça,
c'est Fukuyama. Bah, je vous apprends
rien, hein. Euh la fin de l'histoire,
c'était le rêve euh après la chute d'une
humeur de Berlin euh de la victoire
définitive du modèle. Attention, ils
vous ont mis un bout de chatton.
Oh là là, catastrophe.
Heureusement que vous me prévenez.
Ça va, c'est bon comme ça ?
Euh le rêve de la fin de l'histoire,
c'était le rêve qu'après l'effondrement
du mur de Berlin, on allait connaître
avec la victoire définitive du modèle
libéral et démocratique, celui de
l'économie de marché et de de la règle
de droit, on allait connaître une
extension universelle de ce principe et
que ce serait la fin de toute forme de
conflictualité, la fin des logiques de
puissance qui seraiit remplacé par les
règles acceptées par tous et mis en
application par des institutions
multilatérales. C'est c'est
ça c'est le petit terre de flû.
Non mais c'est
quand on voit le les États-Unis
s'essuyer bien gentiment avec le droit
international depuis un su un certain
nombre de décennies
que le droit international ça s'applique
que au guu du tiers monde ou au guu de
dictateur à gauche à droite bon les
méchants. Bon ceux qui menacent nos
intérêts et qui
et à l'Union européenne quand même
de nous ça nous a ça s'applique à nous.
Bah l'Europe s'applique des règles du
jeu que plus personne ne respecte
aujourd'hui.
SarkoZi s'est appliqué des règles du je
la France elle s'est appliqué des règles
du jeu.
Mais prenez par exemple les règles du
commerce. Regardez l'OMC par ex.
Question question. La Libye, on avait
quel mandat déjà
quand on a dégagé Kaddafi ? Du moins
avant c'était sécuriser l'espace aérien.
C'est ça
la Libye ? C'était c'était Mais je je
dis pas que ces règles étaient
respectées. Je dis que c'était le rêve.
Je je dis pas qu'elles étaient
respectées ni qu'elles le sont. elles le
sont surtout pas maintenant. Je dis que
c'était le rêve qui qui présidait à la à
la à la conception du monde pour
laquelle l'Union européenne s'est
construite. C'est c'est la c'est la
factuellement aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne est un continent qui croit
encore au multilatéralisme dans un monde
où le multilatéralisme n'existe plus. Et
c'est ça qui qui rend les Européens
totalement désarsonnés par la situation
à laquelle ils sont confrontés. L'Europe
s'est construite, prenez prenez prenez
ce ce paris-là fondamental. L'Europe
s'est construite sur le paris de la
dépendance, de l'interdépendance.
C'était le c'était le rêve européen mais
c'est la réalité. Le lapsus qui va vite.
La dépendance et l'interdépendance, les
deux. Euh ben vous parliez de d'énergie,
c'était la communauté du charbon et de
l'acier, premier premier premier concept
européen. Et il faut reconnaître
objectivement euh il faut reconnaître le
le le courage que représentait le fait
de construire la Communauté européenne
du charbon et de l'acier après des
siècles de conflits entre les pays qui
se rassemblaient dans cette dans cet
effort. L'idée c'était que si on met en
commun ces ressources fondamentales, on
aura plus les moyens de se faire la
guerre demain et donc ce sera la fin de
de toute conflictualité. Ce sera c'était
déjà le rêve de la fin de l'histoire.
Euh et en fait le modèle européen
aujourd'hui, il est conçu sur le Paris
d'exporter ce modèle de la dépendance et
de l'interdépendance. Et
fondamentalement, tous les grands Paris
européens viennent de s'effondrer en
quelques années seulement. C'était le
rêve que on allait trouver notre
prospérité et notre sécurité dans la
dépendance à la garantie euh militaire
américaine, la dépendance à l'énergie
peu coûteuse du gaz importé de Russie et
la dépendance au déboucher facile du
marché chinois.
C'est ces trois paris s'effondrent en
même temps et c'est pour ça que l'Europe
peut se disloquer. En effet, je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous.
Ça va à votre avis se modéliser ou se
matérialiser comment ?
Bah ça se matérialise déjà quand vous
voyez le deal qui a été signé entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe en juillet
dernier. C'est pas
quel deal le deal pour protéger
l'industrie automobile allemande ?
C'est pas un c'est pas un accord en
fait. C'est c'est juste c'est c'est
juste une extorsion
devant devant les caméras du monde
entier. C'estàd que
c'est dur. Pourquoi vous dites extorsion
? On a on est fâché avec les Russes donc
il nous faut il nous faut de l'énergie
donc on va le chercher bon un peu plus
cher aux États-Unis puis c'est de
l'énergie un peu plus cher un peu moins
écologique
ou peut-être beaucoup moins écologique
et beaucoup plus cher. vraiment pas du
tout écologique parce que le GNL qu'on
qu'on liqu fait encore la B du diable
euh mais non c'est c'est une extorsion
et tout le monde le voit, tout le monde
le sait en réalité. Si les Européens
étaient pas dépendants pour leur
protection de
la défense américaine, ils accepteraient
jamais une situation comme celle-là.
Votre lecture du conflit euh de la
guerre avec les Russes, c'est quoi ?
Comment c'est arrivé ? Est-ce qu'il y
avait des des des braises ? Pas des
braises. Comment ça se passe ?
Comment la diplomatie
a à ce point échoué ?
Je pense que la diplomatie a échoué
quand le le monde occidental a refusé de
considérer ce qui se ce qui se passait
en Russie
en Ukraine,
en en Russie. en Russie
euh dans la décennie 90 et 2000 euh et
que au moment où on aurait dû avoir une
vision prospective et travailler sur sur
l'avenir, euh le le l'Ouest a vécu sur
l'ivresse de sa victoire écrasante sans
trop se préoccuper de la suite. Et il y
a eu une immense naïveté aussi vis-à-vis
de de la Russie. En tous les cas dans
dans ce mépris, une forme de
condescendance qui faisait que bah
voilà, on se disait fondamentalement,
c'était le grand Paris et le grand Paris
notamment de l'Allemagne. On importe du
gaz pas cher, on vend des belles
voitures, on importe ce qui fait peu de
valeur ajoutée, l'énergie avec la
naïveté qu'on sait sur le secteur de
l'énergie et on exporte ce qui fait de
la valeur ajoutée, c'est-à-dire
l'industrie manufacturière. on importe
des des des voitures, on exporte des
voitures et et du coup toujours cette
idée que voilà, si on a des relations
d'interdépendance commerciale, on
s'évitera les conflits. C'était ça le le
la naïveté fondamentale.
Là, on est en train de faire quel Paris
là ? Parce que on sacrifie notre
industrie, on sacrifie l'industrie
allemande.
Donc forcément, ils font un retour sur
investissement.
Il faut il faut il faut surtout sortir
de là. Il faut sortir de de cette
logique pour la paix
sur sur le sur le sujet du conflit.
Bah là, de toute façon, le conflit tout
le monde sait bien, c'est comme au
Moyen-Orient, tout le monde sait bien
que que aujourd'hui ce conflit va se
résoudre au-dessus de la tête des
Européens. C'est c'est fondamentalement
aujourd'hui entre Washington et Moscou
que que les choses se se journent.
Est-ce que c'est peut-être en réalité
les deux seuls vrais protagonistes ?
Il est il est il est il est clair, mais
encore une fois, je le redis, c'est la
c'est la c'est la conséquence logique de
ces paris que l'Europe a fait.
Aujourd'hui, les les pays européens euh
la France fait un peu exception au
milieu encore que malheureusement malgré
les efforts que la nation a consenti, la
France a pas une armée qui soit
suffisamment puissante pour affronter le
retour de la haute intensité mais le
fait que la France est l'un des rares
pays européens à avoir gardé une armée
d'intervention capable de se projeter
sur sur des terrains de d'action un peu
partout dans le monde et qu'on soit le
dernier pays de l'Union européenne à
avoir la dissuation nucléaire fait qu'on
est un peu singulier dans le débat
européen sur les questions de de
défense, mais y compris la France et
tous les pays européens sont aujourd'hui
sans la garantie américaine extrêmement
vulnérable. Je le vois tous les jours au
Parlement européen. Je je viens de
terminer la négociation d'un texte sur
l'industrie de défense en Europe. Euh
l'angoisse majeure de nos alliés
européens, c'est de perdre le bouclier
américain et et leur inquiétude fait que
il est très difficile de réussir à
sortir même de manière
embryonnaire. Pour commencer, il est
très difficile. C'est un combat très
rude à mener de réussir à sortir de
cette logique de dépendance qui s'est
imposée depuis longtemps. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
? Qu'est-ce que vous feriez si demain je
vous donne la baguette magique de la
France ? On va dire François Xavier
président. François Xavier président, il
fait quoi pour calmer les choses là ?
Mais enfin, je pense qu'il faut pas
partir du virtuel. La question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Vous seriez en
droit de me demander qu'est-ce que je
fais maintenant ? Est-ce que je je suis
élu maintenant ? et et ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a porté justement c'est un projet
qui est encore relativement modeste mais
qui est quand même un renversement de
logique. Misérabilisme dans
l'impuissance.
Non non, je tombe pas du tout dans dans
le misérabilisme. C'est vraiment un
renversement de logique qui est qui est
inédit et qui j'espère euh sera sera
sera important par la portée qu'il est
qu'il aura. L'année dernière, les pays
européens ont importé pour leur armement
79 % de ce qu'ils ont acheter dans
dehors d'Europe dont 63 % des
États-Unis. C'est pas parce que ils
savent pas produire parce que la vérité
c'est que la France est malheureusement
très difficilitaire sur sa balance
commerciale mais les autres combien de
déficit
elle est très elle fait à chaque année
un nouveau record en terme de déficit de
la balance commerciale. Je saurais pas
vous dire cette année mais même la
balance commerciale agricole est devenue
déficitaire cette année pour la pour la
première fois. Elle était déficitaire si
on enlevait les vins spiritueux depuis
2019. Elle est devenue déficitaire au
global pour la première fois cette
année. Ce qui est ce qui est inédit. on
pourrait y revenir parce que ça a un
lien avec la question de la défense, la
question de l'agriculture,
mais
ça a un lien avec la souveraineté.
Peut-être
avec la question de la souveraineté,
mais aussi avec la question de la
sécurité. Euh je je disais donc que
c'est pas parce que les Européens savent
pas produire parce que les autres pays
européens sont pour beaucoup d'entre eux
excédentaires sur leur balance
commerciale. L'Europe est excédentaire
en moyenne commercialement. Mais si on
importe autant, c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est le tribut que le vassal paye au
suzer. C'estàd que les Européens
importent leur armement. Parce que le le
deal implicite c'est nous ne payons pas
pour notre propre défense, nous laissons
les Américain payé pour défendre
l'Europe. En échange de quoi ? Nous leur
faisons la politesse d'au moins leur
acheter le peu que nous dépensons pour
nos nos forces armées échantillonnaires
qui sont en réalité des simples
contributions à l'OTAN.
et et donc le but c'était de renverser
cette logique et avec le programme EDIP
donc pour le programme pour l'industrie
européenne de défense et ça a été un
combat très rude et jusqu'à la dernière
minute parce que la pression était très
forte
un combat avec certains de nos
partenaires européens mais en fait
quel
ben beaucoup de pays européens qui sont
ceux qui sont les plus dépendants en
réalité de de l'industrie américaine.
Quel
nos amis les Allemands ? Non, même
nos amis les Polonais,
mais les la Pologne, bien sûr, par
exemple. Mais mais je je comprends,
enfin je veux pas je veux pas euh faire
de jugement.
Je veux dire qu'il faut les comprendre
aussi. Les Polonais, ils sont en face
des Russes, les Russes sont énervés. Les
Polonais, ils ont déjà subi un peu, ils
connaissent le truc
bien sûr euh
compliqué. J'ai un collègue polonais qui
m'a dit cette chose toute simple. Il m'a
dit "Moi, tu sais, nous on a retenu une
chose du 20e siècle, c'est que quand on
n'est pas avec les Américains, on se
fait envahir. Et vous nous avez déjà
souvent depuis l'Europe de l'Ouest
promis votre solidarité. Vous avez
souvent signé des traités avec nous.
Mais à la fin, au moment où on se fait
envahia, qui veut mourir pour Danzig ?
Bah comment lui donner tort ? Voyez donc
je comprends les Polonais, je je et et
de fait l'histoire, elle est pas
ancienne et je pense que c'est important
qu'on la comprenne nous d'Europe de
l'Ouest. Moi j'ai des collègues dans mon
groupe au Parlement européen qui sont
nés enfin beaucoup de mes collègues qui
viennent d'Europe centrale orientale
sont nés dans l'URSS.
Vous avez quel âge ?
J'ai une collègue lituanienne qui est
née dans un goulag. Elle est née dans un
goulag. Et donc si vous voulez, elle dit
Andrius Cubilus qui s'occupe de la
défense dans la Commission européenne
quand il a fait sa son audition de
confirmation devant le Parlement
européen, il a dit "Moi, j'ai un seul
but dans l'existence, je suis né en
URSS, je veux pas y retourner, je peux
pas lui donner tort." Voyez,
vous connaissez la blague avec Gagarine
?
Quand est-ce que quand est-ce que que
ton papa revient de l'espace ?
Non
non, moi j'en connais une autre. Alors,
allez-y, racontez-moi.
Alors, la blague avec Gagarine, c'est il
décolle du RSS,
il atterrit en URSS.
Il y en a plein des blagues avec
Gagarine, il y en a plein des blagues
soviétiques, c'est fabuleux. Moi je
connais la la blague avec Gagarine,
c'est la petite fille de la la fille de
Gagarine qui a à la télévision et on lui
dit "Il rentre quand de l'espace ton
papa ? Il rentre demain à 17h et et ta
maman elle sera là." "Ah ben non, c'est
pas possible. chez le boucher, elle
revient dans 3 jours parce qu'il y avait
des queu tellement énormes devant les
magasins que pour avoir un peu de
viande, il fallait rester longtemps. On
est dans un phénomène de guerre froide à
l'heure actuelle où le but c'est de
plomber l'économie de l'autre, de faire
payer au peuple infin, que ce soit le
peuple européen, le peuple russe, le
peuple ukrainien, parce qu'on n'est pas
foutu d'avoir des politiques se mettent
qui se mettent autour de la tête pour
éviter qu'on se mette sur la figure
parce qu'on est encore des nations
barbares, archaïques avec des
politiciens ou à l'échelle européenne,
soit qui poussent d'un côté, soit qui
poussent de l'autre et que on est en fin
de compte une société de primitif
et que ça va mal se terminer là.
Mais on est dans une guerre froide au
sens en tous les cas dans une dans un
retour des logiques de la guerre froide
au sens où aujourd'hui et pour le coup
c'est parfaitement clair parce qu'il le
dit dans ces termes-là, Vladimir Poutine
veut réparer la chute du mur de Berlin.
En fait, il veut réparer l'effondrement
de l'URSS.
Il a dit ça quand ? il a dit euh que il
il a il a dit explicitement que euh
l'effondrement de l'URSS avait été une
catastrophe sans précédent et et en fait
est-ce qu'il a dit qu'il voulait revenir
? Quand est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Il a dit que c'était une catastrophe
sans précédent. Donc ce qui ce qu'il est
en train de de faire euh manifestement
c'est de tenter de réparer cette
catastrophe. Euh
et moi je l'ai vu euh
je je je l'ai vu sur d'autres terrains,
mais je je vois par exemple un pays que
je que je connais bien et pour lequel je
me suis beaucoup battu, l'Arménie.
Euh Poutine
a fait payer à l'Arménie d'avoir voulu
prendre son indépendance, d'avoir voulu
sortir du du Giron, d'avoir voulu être
autre chose qu'un satellite
post-soviétique piloté par un régime
intégralement corrompu et qui était
relié à Moscou par la corruption. Et
quand les Arméniens en 2018, quand le
peuple arménien, la jeunesse arménienne
euh a dit "Bah nous en fait, on n veut
plus, on veut on veut faire tomber ce
système et on a envie de vivre une vie
normale, une vie libre, une démocratie
normale, de sortir de la de la
corruption."
Euh ben en fait la Russie qui était
historiquement et qui était euh
juridiquement par les liens d'alliance
dans le cadre de de l'OTSC qui qu'il l'a
lié à l'Arménie, la Russie a lâché lâché
l'Arménie face à l'Azerbaïdjan et et ce
qui s'est passé en 2020, ce qui s'est
passé en 2022, c'était aussi ça qui se
jouait.
On va pas se signer nous l'Europe des
contrats avec l'Azerbaïdjan.
Si alors pendant ce temps-là, le truc
qui est d'une violence hallucinante,
c'est que l'Arménie dit "Bah nous, on
veut se tourner vers l'ouest parce qu'on
veut avoir une démocratie qui ressemble
à celle des pays occidentaux. Et puis en
réalité, au moment où ils ont payé cher
pour cet espoir qu'il qui qui traversait
la société arménienne, bah l'Ouest les a
les a les a trahi." Et moi, j'ai j'ai me
suis battu pour l'Arménie parce que je
dénonçais cette plaision.
Il y a pas eu un déplacement de
population ?
Euh, je j'appellerai pas ça un
déplacement de population
récemment. récemment,
j'appelle ça un nettoyage ethnique, un
nettoyage ethnique aux portes de
l'Europe et et c'est d'ailleurs quelque
chose qui me qui me qui me qui me fera
l'avocat du diable, même si c'est très
difficile sur ce type de sujet,
mais le contrat du gaz
Non, mais alors là pour le coup, je
serai procureur avec vous. C'est ce
contrat gazier est indécent. Il est
indécent et il dit tout d'une forme de
double standard parce que en plus c'est
quoi le gaz qui vient de Baku et qu'on
achète en Azerbaïdjan ? C'est du gaz qui
vient de Moscou et qui est juste passé
par là pour pouvoir être blanchi. Et on
le sait, on le sait parce que
l'Aerbaïdjan
a augmenté ses exportations mais a
diminué sa production de gaz. Quel pays
peut faire ça ? Donc la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui les Européens savent et je
l'ai demandé à la Commission à de
nombreuses reprises, on a exiger d'avoir
accès au contrat gazier qui est en fait
pas un contrat qui est un mémorandum
d'accord avec Bakou.
C'est stupéfiant. C'est vous dites "Oh
là là, c'est horrible, il y a une
dictature sanguinaire qui attaque ses
voisins et par conséquent on refuse de
lui acheter du gaz." Et donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? on se tourne versre
dictateur sanguinaire qui attaque aussi
ses voisins et on lui achète en fait le
gaz de la première dictature qu'on paye
d'ailleurs deux fois le prix au passage
du coup donc c'est c'est c'est
évidemment d'une hypocrisie absolument
indécente. C'est c'est est-ce qu'on peut
résumer l'Union européenne à euh une
comment comment formuler ça
à une bande d'hyprocrite drapée dans
l'étendard de la vertu pour pouvoir
aller sur les plateaux télé la main sur
le cœur pour dire que on se bat pour la
veuve l'orphelin et que derrière bah
business quoi. Business business.
Vous pouvez pas comment dire ? Non mais
moi moi si je devais résumer l'Union
européenne, je dirais que c'est un
combat. L'Union européenne, c'est des
institutions, il faut y être pour se
battre, c'est tout. Il faut se battre
matin, midi et soir.
C'est c'est la seule chose qui compte.
Se battre, c'est il y a il y a pas de
votre marge de manœuvre, c'est quoi ?
Ben notre marge de manœuvre, c'est ça.
En l'occurrence, typiquement sur le sur
le sur le sujet de de de l'Arménie, je
pense qu'on a réussi à sortir ce ce
crime hallucinant du silence. En 2020,
en 2020, le Parlement européen comme les
institutions européennes étaient
malheureusement totalement traversé par
totalement pris en otage par le lobbying
de l'Azerbaïdjan. Vous vous souvenez que
le le
tapis
la première affaire de corruption dans
les institutions européennes, c'était
pas le catargate, c'était ce qu'on a
appelé la cavière diplomatie. C'était
l'Azerbaïdjan qui payait en l'occurrence
au Conseil de l'Europe qui payait des
parlementaires pour faire avancer sa
cause et défendre ses intérêts. Il y a
qui d'autres comme
ils ont été arrêtés, ils ont été
condamnés. Tout ça est factuel hein.
C'est
il y a il y a d'autres puissances qui
s'amusent à sucrer les fraises de nos
parlementaires ou comment ça se passe ?
Bah on a on a connu le catargate qui
était quand même un très grand moment.
C'était rien du tout. C'est
petit sac à main un peu de cachord
le catarget. Je suis d'accord avec vous,
c'était de la corruption cache
d'ailleurs qu'on a trouvé chez la SPIN
qui était d'ailleurs vice-présidente va
c mais d'ailleurs l'enquête judiciaire
est toujours arrêté à ce jour.
Elle a pas été blanchie ?
Non, elle a pas été blanchie mais elle a
pas été condamnée non plus. Je je mais
je crois que le catargate c'était
vraiment une histoire de corruption pour
les pied niyclés. C'était vraiment de la
corruption à l'ancienne. C'est-à-dire
effectivement le le papa d'une députée
qui se barre à l'aéroport avec des
valises de billets au moment où la
police débarque. Enfin, tout ça
ressemble à rien. Je pense que les
puissances étrangères qui veulent peser
sur l'Europe utilisent des canaux
infiniment plus sophistiqués aujourd'hui
que ceuxl.
Il y a qui comme puissance ?
Bah, il y en a beaucoup.
C'estàd que l'Union européenne c'est
ouvert aux 80 de n'importe quel type de
propagande.
Est-ce que vous êtes fait tamponner vous
?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par
tamponner ? Parce qu'il y a une
puissance étrangère qui a essayé de vous
graisser la pâte, vous mettre des filles
dans le ch
jamais. Je suis super vexé, on m'a
jamais proposé. Non, j'ai déjà eu droit
à des
un câ avec une tête de Mickey aussi
belle, c'est compliqué de le de le
corrompre, c'est ça.
J'ai plus trop eu droit à l'inverse.
J'ai plutôt eu droit à des des
gens qui viennent vous voir en vous
disant bah typiquement sur le cas de
l'Azerbaïdjan, tu sais euh c'est pas
idéal de s'intéresser à un sujet comme
ça. Euh
tu risques d'avoir un accident,
vous savez, moi je je
Tu tu sais
Ouais, on on passe notre temps à
changer.
J'ai rencontré parce que je me suis
occupé de l'Azerbaïdjan parce que j'ai
dénoncé ce qui se passait aussi dans les
institutions européennes. J'ai été
contacté un jour par quelqu'un qui m'a
écrit en disant "Vous devriez vraiment
rencontrer Maha Mirzali." Vous
connaissez Maha Mirzali ? Je le
connaissais pas non plus. C'était en
2020. Euh ce monsieur qui m'écrit que je
connaissais pas me dit Mohammad Mirzali,
c'est un jeune
Azeri qui est réfugié politique en
France parce qu'il s'est opposé au
régime d'Alif et il a été victime de
plusieurs tentatives d'assassinat sur le
sol français.
Honnêtement, heureusement qu'il y avait
eu un papier qui avait pas fait beaucoup
de bruit dans un journal parce que
sinon, j'aurais eu du mal à croire
l'histoire. Mais bon, j'ai été le voir.
Quelle histoire ? Que la France n'est
pas capable d'assurer les sécurités des
réfugiés. Comment
il y avait un réfugié politique Azéri
sur le sol français victime de plusieurs
tentatives d'assassinat et que personne
n'en savait rien. Ça paraissait un peu
énorme. J'ai été le rencontrer. Il était
tout seul à l'époque dans un petit
appartement à Nant. Il vivait dans une
situation de d'erreur très
compréhensible parce que ce jeune avait
simplement eu euh le courage de dénoncer
la corruption du régime d'Alif et il
était parti en France en espérant être
tranquille. Et effectivement, en France,
il a été victime de plusieurs tentatives
d'assassinat euh qui ont conduit à des
arrestations. Un procès va avoir lieu.
Euh et il est aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
alerté sur cette situation. euh j'ai
obtenu qu'il soit qu'il soit protégé
mais il l'était pas du tout à l'époque.
Euh et donc oui, il y a des gens qui
vous disent quand vous vous intéressez à
ce genre de sujet euh il vaut mieux être
prudent, il vaut mieux faire attention.
Ils vous le disent gentiment ou ils vous
le disent du genre euh tu risques
d'attraper froid ?
Bah ils vous le disent pour votre bien
évidemment
mais encore une fois
par quel canau ?
La corruption la la corruption
les gens qui vous préviennent de façon
très amicale. C'est juste un petit mail.
Il vous rencontre dans un bar en face du
Parlement européen, il vous envoie un
petit petit un petit bouquet de fleurs.
Non, mais en l'occurrence, c'était euh
quelqu'un qui travaillait que je je je
j'identifie et qui travaillait
euh euh autour de la délégation
interparlementaire avec ce pays
mais qui c'était pas du tout c'était pas
du tout sous la forme d'une menace.
C'était
ça, je conseille. Vous
avez prévenu des services de sécurité
pour
Non, je honnêtement je je j'ai jamais eu
peur de ma vie. Je prétends pas être un
héros. Je suis pas Il y a des gens qui
sont courageux et Mahamad est un pour le
coup un vrai héros. J'en ai rencontré
peu parce que parce qu'il veut pas
mourir et je le comprends euh mais qui
veut pas se terre non plus. Et c'est pas
une tête brûlée, c'est pas un type qui
qui joue les les les gros durs, mais
mais juste il refuse de mentir. Et lui,
pour le coup, on lui a proposé, on l'a
menacé très très très souvent et il sait
ce que ça veut dire d'être confronté à
un commando qui vient pour vous
exécuter. Il s'est vu mourir et la
dernière fois que ça s'est produit, il a
eu beaucoup de chance parce qu'il y a eu
un un contrôle de gendarmerie qui lui a
sauvé la vie. Il se trouve qu'on a chopé
des types à un péage de de d'autoroute
et que leur voiture a été contrôlée
parce qu'ils avaient sans doute l'air un
peu un peu un peu particulier et qu'on a
retrouvé des armes de guerre dans leur
coffre et l'adresse de Mahamad dans leur
GPS quoi. Donc voilà, c'est c'est donc
il sait ce que ça veut dire mais lui
pour le coup j'ai une admiration infinie
pour lui parce que en mesurant la
réalité du risque et en jouant pas du
tout à ça pour le plaisir alors qu'il
pourrait s'il se taisait sans doute y
trouver non seulement la sécurité mais
bien des avantages matériels et qu'on le
lui a promis et ben il refuse de le
faire. Ça c'est quelqu'un de courageux.
Moi je prétends pas du tout euh
Revenons. Revenons à un autre sujet.
inérences étrangères parce que c'est ça
qui est important.
Quand il s'est passé le catargate ?
Alors le catargate résumé très
trivialement, je vous laisse
donc le catargate c'est des des
collègues parlementaires a priori c'est
tout tous sont
des carrières messes ou pas ? Tous sont
présumés innocents parce que il y a pas
de il y a pas de condamnation encore.
Mais en tous les cas, apparemment,
recevait euh beaucoup de de de d'argent,
des quantités sans doute confortables.
Euh aurait reçu euh ces sommes-là pour
euh dire du bien du Qatar. C'était euh
la première partie du contrat. Donc il y
avait des députés qui expliquaient en
plein milieu de la préparation de la
coupe du monde de foot au Qatar que ce
pays était le le paradis des droits
sociaux et que que les travailleurs du
monde entier rêvaient de de d'être
salarié au Qatar. Euh et puis euh aussi
pour faire avancer des intérêts très
concrets. L'Union européenne par exemple
a signé euh ce dont les compagnies
aériennes européennes se plaignent
aujourd'hui amèrement à signer un accord
euh sur l'aviation avec le Qatar en
offrant des conditions d'accès
exceptionnelles au marché européen à
Qatar Airways. Et j'ai là encore eu
l'occasion de poser beaucoup de
questions à la Commission européenne sur
le sujet pour réussir à faire la lumière
sur ce qui ce qui s'était joué dans
cette affaire.
Vous avez suivi le fait vous avez suivi
le fait que le Qatar et les États-Unis
nous impose du moins impose à l'Union
européenne d'arranger un petit peu notre
vision sur les droits de l'homme sur
tout ça parce que ils nous vendent du
gaz donc vous comprenez tu comprends
faut arranger les choses il faut
arrondir les angles.
Ouais mais ben revenons là-dessus.
L'influence du Qatar, elle s'est faite
pour les États-Unis,
les relations publiques de de de ce de
ce pays. Elle s'est faite aussi pour les
avantages matériels de de son business,
mais elle s'est faite aussi certainement
pour la vision de la société que le
Qatar a essayé d'exporter. Et quand la
Commission européenne finançait des
publicités qui disent "La joie est dans
le hijab ou la liberté est dans le hijab
quand vous avez autour de la
commission".
J'ai pas vu passer ça. C'est vrai ça ?
Ouais.
Non. Si sans déconner.
Si ben c'est moi qui ai qui ai qui est
c'est moi qui ai déposé un amendement
j'ai dû le déposer à plusieurs reprises
jusqu'à ce que ça passe pour interdire à
la Commission européenne de financer ses
publicités en pleine révolte des femmes
iraniennes après la mort de Marsa Amini
alors qu'il y avait des femmes en Iran
qui mouraient parce qu'elle disait
qu'elle refusaient de porter le hijab.
La réponse de la Commission européenne,
c'était de financer des publicités qui
disaient littéralement apporter de la
joie, accepter le hijab.
La liberté est dans le hijab.
Et tout ça passe par quoi ? Et et c'est
là le point où je voulais en venir.
C'est super important que les gens
comprennent ça. À Bruxelles, à
Strasbourg, il y a plein d'acteurs qui
entourent la décision publique. Il y a
il y a bien sûr les parlementaires, les
chefs d'état de gouvernement, il y a les
commissaires et cetera, mais derrière il
y a on parle beaucoup du lobbing, il y a
des entreprises qui viennent faire
valoir leurs intérêts, essayer de de
défendre leur vision. Il y a des des des
organisations diverses et variées et il
y a beaucoup d'ONG. On parle beaucoup du
lobbying, mais le lobbying le plus
déterminé, le plus organisé, le mieux
financé, c'est clairement le lobbying
des ONG euh de très loin. Et quand on
regarde les résultats politiques des
dernières années, c'est clairement pas
l'industrie qui a gagné la partie ces
dernières années en Europe, hein. Euh,
c'est clairement pas l'agriculture,
c'est clairement pas la pêche.
C'est clairement pas le nucléaire.
C'est clairement pas le nucléaire. Le
nucléaire, mais parlons de ça. Quand le
catargate a eu lieu, on nous a dit "Oh
là là, horrible scandale de corruption."
C'est vrai, il faut être plus
transparent pour répondre euh à la crise
de confiance que les citoyens ont envers
les institutions. Donc, on exige que les
entreprises déclarent toutes leurs
activités de lobbying dans les
institutions européennes. Évidemment, on
exige que les parlementaires soient
parfaitement transparents. Maintenant,
par exemple, je vais je devais déjà
déclarer comme tous les parlementaires
tout ce que j'avais gagné sur les 10
dernières années.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Combien je gagne aujourd'hui ? Bah,
c'est c'est public, c'est parfaitement
accessible. Je gagne l'indemnité au
Parlement européen, c'est 8500 € par
mois impôt.
Quand vous pointez là-bas, vous avez une
petite sucette en plus ou pas ?
Non, il y a des il y a il y a un un
financement pour le le qui couvre les
coûts que vous avez quand vous devez
vous loger à Bruxelles, à Strasbourg.
Honnêtement, c'est c'est c'est une
situation de vie évidemment très très
confortable. Ce qui compte pour moi,
c'est de d'en faire l'occasion d'un
travail utile au pays et c'est la seule
chose importante. Mais mais
on a on a commencé, excusez-moi,
mais pardon, est-ce que je peux juste
terminer là-dessus ? Parce que sur les
c'est pas que je veille pas parler de
mon salaire, j'ai aucun problème avec
ça. J'ai pas fait des choix de carrière
pour gagner beaucoup d'argent parce que
j'étais prof dans l'éducation nationale,
vous voyez. Donc c'était pas vous
impôts, ils sont déclarés en France.
Oui, je paye mes impôts en France.
Ouais. Enfin, en fait, je paye deux fois
mes impôts parce qu'on paye des impôts
dans dans pour l'Union européenne, il y
a des ce qu'on appelle les impôts
européens et ensuite je paye mon impôt
sur le revenu en France et c'est tout à
fait normal. Bien sûr, j'ai pas déménagé
à Bruxelles, j'habite toujours en
France.
Sympa à Bruxelles,
je suis pas très fan.
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas.
Super. Super boîte de nuit. Les
Bruxellois, les Belges sont absolument
adorables.
Très sympa. Vraiment très sympa. Il y a
toujours autant de barres autour
mais bon, il faut dire que je connais
pas enfin il a toujours autant de barres
autour du Parlement européen.
Il y a pas tant de barre que ça autour
du Parlement européen.
Celui qui est quand vous sortez, il y a
une espèce de grande place en face.
La place du Luxembourg. Ouais. Là, il y
a quelques bars autour. Ouais.
Mais bon, ça ferme tôt et tout. La
Belgique sont pas c'est des couches tôt,
hein. Quand on travaille tard, en fait,
c'est intéressant de laisser traîner les
oreilles dans ce type de bar. Non, vous
avez déjà fait ça.
Euh, il paraît ben pareil aussi dans le
le Talis, enfin le train qui roule entre
Paris et Bruxelles, c'est un
pour le réseau Wii, ça
Oui, il y a il y a des il y a des gens
qui ont la fâcheuse tendance prendre en
photo les les écrans des ordinateurs des
gens qui bossent autour. Mais bon.
Ouais. Non, mais sur les barres là, la
boutade
quand vous avez
Après, on revient on revient au sujet
d'avant parce que
quand vous écoutez les assistants
parlementaires quand ils ont 3 4 L de
bière dans le nez,
c'est intéressant ce qu'il raconte. Non,
je sais pas. Vous savez, le Parlement
européen, on traite quand même peu de
secrets d'état. La plupart des choses
qu'on fait sont publiques. Donc je suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait forcément beaucoup à
tirer de de
les ingérences étrangères. Est-ce que
vous êtes mais regardez regardez
regardez.
Est-ce qu'il y a un service autour de
vous qui vous brief ? Votre téléphone
portable, il a un Pegasus, il a pas de
Pegasus, il a été audité, pas audité,
c'est quoi un Pegasus ? Est-ce qu'il y a
des gens qui viennent vous briefer en
France pour vous dire méfiez-vous ? Bah
les
les Qataris, les Russes, les
Azerbaïdjanis,
les Allemands, peut-être que c'était
peut-être pas cool. Il faut apprendre à
sécuriser vos communications. Vous
laisser mon téléphone portable ?
Comment
je vais vous laisser mon portable ?
Ça va vous coûter une blinde, hein.
Est-ce que vous avez quoi comme
téléphone portable ?
On n pas du tout euh on est on est on n
pas vraiment briefé sur le sujet. C'est
quoi pas très honnête ?
Je peux vous donner un exemple très
concret. En 2024, j'ai appris par les
services américains que j'avais fait
l'objet de tentative de piratage par la
Chine.
Parce que vous vous occupiez de quel
dossier ?
Parce que j'ai pas mal travaillé aussi
sur la Chine. Mais justement,
les Américains vous ont contacté comment
? Avec un petit mail sur Gmail ?
Ils nous ont contacté via le Parlement
européen en nous donnant une liste de
parlementaires qui avaient fait l'objet
d'une d'un ciblage par les Chinois.
Mais c'est pas des services européens ou
nationaux qui qui nous ont alerté sur
ça.
Et on a même eu droit du coup à un brief
par les services américains avec les
quelques parlementaires qui avaient été
ciblés pour nous nous dire le le le le
la réalité du risque et comment puis
vous êtes vous êtes un petit peu
endurci.
Oui, mais en même temps, encore une
fois, je le redis, moi je je on est je
suis pas dans une fonction exécutive, je
suis pas ministre des armées, je suis
pas et donc la plupart des choses que je
fais et que je traite sont publiqu et
j'ai pas de problème avec ça. Si j'étais
demain dans une fonction qui m'exposait
à à accéder à des secrets
particulièrement sensibles,
je peux vous faire votre dépucelage tout
de suite. Votre téléphone portable, il
est poutré. Je peux activer votre micro
à distance.
Comme vous êtes sympa, vous êtes beau
gosse, vous retrouvez dans des dîners
d'affaires de bourgeois ou des des votre
téléphone, il est dans les parages. Moi,
je suis chinois, russe, atari,
sud-africain, chilien. J'ai le contrôle
de votre téléphone, je peux sonoriser la
pièce.
Je salue les gens qui nous écoutent.
Alors peut-être, mais
les moustaches ou les grandes oreilles
ou les deux ? Vous comprenez ? Comprend
très bien. Non non mais je comprends
très bien ce que je veux dire. Ce que je
veux dire c'est que je pense que là
encore je veux pas me faire passer pour
quelqu'un qui traiteraiit tous les jours
avec des secrets d'état et je suis pas
sûr qu'il y ait une très forte valeur
ajoutée pour des services étrangers à
écouter et moi je me sentirai pas
particulièrement vulnérable. Euh encore
une fois si j'étais dans une autre
fonction demain, ce serait peut-être
différent. Mais aujourd'hui, ce que je
fais euh l'essentiel de ce que je fais,
de ce que je défends, de ce que je
discute euh est en fait des engagements
que j'assume dans l'espace public. Et
donc euh je je suis pas sûr d'être le
plus le plus le plus en danger, même si
je suis pas naïf du tout sur la réalité
de de ces ingérences. Mais je reviens
sur le point parce que c'est vraiment le
plus le plus important. Qu'est-ce qui
pèse sur la décision publique européenne
? Après le catargate, donc on nous a dit
vous les députés européens, vous devez
être de plus en plus transparents. Donc
maintenant, je dois déclarer tous les
rendez-vous que j'ai. Après tout,
pourquoi pas ? Enfin, je moi je pense
c'est c'est un peu absurde parce que
je dirais encore heureux.
Comment
encore heureux ?
Ouais, c'est un peu absurde parce que de
toute façon les tricheurs trichent.
Enfin, je veux dire si madame Ky a
touché beaucoup d'argent du Qatar, si
c'est le cas, je doute bien
je doute fort qu'elle qu'elle aurait
déclaré sur internet qu'elle avait
rendez-vous avec des gens qui venaient
lui livrer des valises de billet. Voyez
? Donc à la fin, je suis pas sûr que ce
type de mesure encore une fois, moi je
j'ai aucun problème avec la
transparence. Je déclare tout ce que
j'ai gagné pendant toutes les dernières
années. Je déclare toutes mes activités
en dehors du Parlement européen. Euh
être marié
non euh
c'est c'est mais mais voilà, il faut il
faut assumer cette cette transparence
là. Euh pas de problème. Le seul acteur
très présent à Bruxelles auquel on n'
rien demandé, c'est les ONG. Les ONG
n'ont toujours aucune règle de
transparence à suivre et pourtant au
cœur du Qatargate, il y avait une ONG.
Le l'organisation qui distribuait
littéralement les valises de billets,
c'était une ONG enregistrée auprès de
l'Union européenne qui intervenait au
Parlement européen, qui avait été créé
par un ancien député socialiste et un
ancien assistant parlementaire
socialiste et qui s'appelait, j'espère
que vous êtes bien assis, Fight
Impunity. C'est quand même très amusant.
Alors, je dis pas que toutes les ONG
sont corrompuses, bien sûr, pas du tout,
mais ce que je crois, c'est que les
véritables ingérances étrangères, celles
qui sont beaucoup plus robustes,
beaucoup plus professionnelles, beaucoup
plus efficaces que celles qu'on a vu
dans le catargate, les véritables
ingérances étrangères, elles utilisent
ce levier là. Et puisqu'on parlait
d'énergie, typiquement ma conviction
profonde, c'est que le principal vecteur
du combat contre l'Europe et contre
l'énergie de nos pays, contre la
souveraineté énergétique de nos pays, il
est passé par là. Le combat
antinucléaire. Regardez, vous parliez de
guerre froide. L'un des principaux
messenes des organisations écologistes
allemandes qui militaaient contre le
nucléaire pendant des années, c'était
Nordstream 2 qui appartient à Gazprom.
Et c'est parfaitement logique. Si vous
êtes russe, que vous voulez vendre plus
de gaz à l'Europe et que vous avez envie
de rendre l'Europe dépendante du gaz que
vous lui vendez, ben vous avez un
intérêt évident. Est-ce que l'Europe
ferme ses centrales nucléaires.
Et si je suis allemand, est-ce que j'ai
un intérêt à ce que les centrales
nucléaires françaises calanchent ? Ben
si vous êtes allemand et que vous fermez
vos centrales nucléaires, vous avez
intérêt aussi à ce que la France se
déface de l'avantage compétitif
exceptionnel que représente sa filière
nucléaire. C'est c'est absolument
manifeste. Mais mais encore une fois, je
reviens sur ce point. Les ONG, c'est
pour moi euh le symptôme de la naïveté
de l'Union européenne et même d'une
forme de dévoiement de la décision
publique. Et je dis pas ça du tout parce
que je voudrais criminaliser les ONG. ça
me pose aucun problème. Je j'aime la
démocratie, j'aime le pluralisme, je
défends le nucléaire et je me suis battu
pendant des années pour défendre le
nucléaire. Mais si vous êtes
antinucléaire, je suis tout à fait pour
que vous ayez le droit de vous exprimer.
Euh si vous êtes Greenpeace ou le WWF
dont on vient de nommer l'ancienne
dirigeante au ministère de l'écologie,
voilà, on y reviendra peut-être. Euh si
vous êtes antinucléaire, bon moi
j'aurais du mal à croire que vous êtes
vraiment écologiste parce
qu'objectivement si vous êtes
antinucléaire, c'est que vous avez envie
de faire comme les Allemands, de creuser
les mines de charbon pour faire euh
tourner des éoliennes parce que on les
deux sont intrinsèquement liés. Euh tout
ça pour dire que j'aurai un désaccord de
fond avec vous mais ça me dérange pas
que vous le disiez. En revanche, je
pense que c'est très important pour les
citoyens dans nos pays, c'est très
important pour les élus dans nos
parlements de savoir qui vous finance.
Et c'est même d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière c'est même très important pour
les militants de ces ONG parce que moi
je serais engagé chez Greenpeace ou WWF,
ce serait pas totalement indifférent
pour moi de savoir qu'il y a une partie
des fonds qui vont vivre mon
organisation qui viennent de pays
étrangers ou d'entreprises étrangères
qui ont un tel intérêt dans la
déstabilisation de l'activité économique
de pan entier de l'industrie de nos
pays. Et donc le le le vrai combat, il
est déterminant ici pour la transparence
du financement des ONG. C'est un combat
fondamental et on a enfin obtenu, ça a
été
rude et difficile et maintenant le
travail commence à peine mais on a enfin
obtenu de créer une commission d'enquête
au Parlement européen, une commission
parlementaire au sein de la commission
du contrôle budgétaire sur la
transparence des ONG. Mais c'est le
c'est le tout début et on l'a obtenu
contre les socialistes, contre les
écologistes, contre nos collègues
macronistes. Malheureusement, tout ce
petit monde manifestement préfère que
les ONG puissent continuer euh à être
des des boîtes noires. Enfin, c'est
parce que c'est le cas en fait
aujourd'hui.
Donc les ingérences étrangères pour moi
euh encore une fois, on peut on peut
parler de la corruption et c'est
évidemment un sujet, c'est un sujet de
morale publique d'abord, c'est aussi un
sujet de sécurité démocratique. Mais
mais je crois profondément que le vrai
la vraie une des une des vraies
vulnérabilités de la décision publique
européenne
aujourd'hui, c'est c'est l'utilisation
de ces vecteurs qui de manière
contournée ont un poids déterminant sur
les choix que nous faisons.
L'Union européenne aussi, elle finance
des ONG non ?
Oui.
À l'étranger.
Alors elle finance des ONG en Europe
d'abord pour commencer entre 2021 et
2023 c'est la Cour des comptes
européennes qui a publié un rapport sur
le sujet. C'est ça qui nous a permis de
créer cette commission d'enquête parce
qu'on le demandait depuis longtemps mais
on narrivait pas à avoir une majorité
pour ça. Là, c'est devenu tellement
évident qu'il a fallu avancer. Entre
2021 et 2023, la Commission européenne a
distribué 7 milliards d'euros à des ONG.
7 milliards d'euros dont d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup de mal à trouver la réalité de
la trace et c'est pas moi qui le dit,
c'est la Cour des comptes européennes.
Mais le truc le plus incroyable le truc
le plus incroyable c'est que la
Commission européenne a versé une partie
de cet argent à des ONG
environnementales
pour qu'elle fassent du lobbying au
Parlement européen. C'est pas interdit
de faire ça. Ah bah évidemment, c'est
totalement contraire, pas seulement euh
euh à quelques réglementations
particulières, mais c'est c'est
contraire au principe même de la
séparation des pouvoirs.
La Commission européenne, c'est
l'exécutif.
Mais la Commission européenne, c'est pas
nommer les choses. Il y a bien des gens
qui ont un nom, qui appuyent sur un
bouton ou qui signent un chèque. Est-ce
que Est-ce que vous avez les noms sur le
scotch ? Oui, bien sûr. Bah en
l'occurrence, c'était le vice-président
de la Commission européenne à l'époque
socialiste qui s'appelle Franz
Timmermans.
Il a été auditionné, il a dit "Bon, j'ai
perdu l'étiquet, je ne sais
Et ben c'est ce qu'on va faire
maintenant avec cette commission
d'enquête parlementaire.
On vient tout juste de la créer.
OK. Et moi, on écoute beaucoup de
commissions même en France
derrière les sanctions. C'est quoi ?
Mais le le
c'est une tape sur les doigts, c'était
pas bien. Ça tu as fait n'importe quoi.
L'autre il va plaider queil savait pas
trop et que bon c'était pour la
on a déjà parlé de la question de la
responsabilité politique. Mais je
alors la responsabilité votre pouvoir de
commission euh si vous mettez en exergue
que c'était pas très bien, il risque
quoi ?
Après la question c'est quelle est la
dimension judiciaire de tout ça ? Et là
pour le coup un parlement n'est pas un
tribunal. Séparation des pouvoirs aussi.
En revanche, nous notre travail c'est de
faire comme des parlementaires élus par
les citoyens de faire la transparence
indispensable. Fant moi je veux bien
être transparent, j'ai pas de problème
avec ça.
Je reviens sur les contrats des vaccins.
Euh les petits SMS, palais SMS,
venderle, euh Pizer, ça en est où cette
transparence là ? Et ben euh on pour le
coup, il y a deux actions en cours. Il y
a donc il y a le processus en initié par
la la médiatrice de l'Union européenne
dont on parlait tout à l'heure, puis il
y a une procédure judiciaire euh et donc
on verra euh à quel développement elle
conduira.
Elle a perdu les SMS, c'est sa vie
privée. Il faut demander à la NSA qui
nous donne les SMS. Comment ça se passe
? En tous les cas, aujourd'hui, on n'a
pas euh la possibilité de tracer la
manière dont cette négociation a été
conduite. Et ça c'est le c'est le
problème fondamental. Euh
je vais vous dire le secret des
affaires. C'est
Oui, mais là c'est un peu différent du
secret des affaires parce que c'est de
l'argent public. C'est l'argent public,
c'est l'argent des citoyens. C'est
l'argent que les citoyens nous confient.
Le secret des affaires, c'est quand deux
entreprises font un deal.
Et c'est important de parce que c'est
aussi un enjeu de souveraineté de de de
de protéger des des des acteur
économique
parce que effectivement les tentatives
de déstabilisation, elles peuvent passer
aussi par là. Mais le secret des
affaires n'a jamais empêché la
responsabilité juridique et la
responsabilité judiciaire et aucune
entreprise au monde ne serait excusé de
de de ces de ses de ses propres
potentiels par le prétexte du secret des
affaires. Et là, on parle pas du secret
des affaires, encore une fois, on parle
d'argent public. Et donc l'argent public
en principe c'est un argent que les
citoyens doivent pouvoir contrôler et
qui doit pouvoir être contrôlé par ceux
qui les représentent, c'està-dire leurs
parlementaires. Et aujourd'hui pour
nous, c'est un sujet fondamental qu'on
puisse pas effectivement rendre compte
de la manière dont cet argent a été
utilisé.
À votre avis, quel pays va sortir de
l'Union européenne en premier ?
L'Italie, l'Allemagne ou la France ?
Euh
je crois pas que ce soit fait d'avance.
Je pense que je pense que le risque de
dislocation que vous évoquez, il existe,
c'est certain. Euh je crois pas pour
autant que ce soit fait d'avance. Et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs, ce qui
est frappant, c'est que euh après le le
Brexit, euh on avait entendu beaucoup de
voix dont le Rassemblement national dire
bah maintenant Frexit, il faut sortir le
plus vite possible. Marine Le Pen avait,
ils avaient dit ça le Front National.
Ouais. Marine Le Pen avait fait une fête
le soir du Brexit au siège du
Rassemblement national en disant "La
Grande-Bretagne nous montre la voix et
nous allons suivre l'exemple."
C'était c'était le la doctrine
officielle. Euh j'observe que maintenant
il y a toujours évidemment
dans le dans le débat il a il y a
toujours des des gens qui revendiquent
le frexit mais aucune force politique de
premier plan, disons, ne ne demande le
frexit aujourd'hui parce que moi je
crois profondément que ça correspond à
une forme de maturation du débat. Je
pense que je pense que l'Europe existe
en fait il demande
Union européenne ou pas. L'Europe existe
et l'Europe c'est un combat. L'Europe
c'est une bataille. L'Europe sera ce
qu'on enfera. FD, c'est quoi l'AFD ?
L'AFD, je sais, je crois pas que l'AFD
revendique le la sortie de l'Union
européenne. Euh, regardez, vous parliez
de l'Italie, Mélonie ne demande pas la
sortie de l'Union européenne. Orban ne
veut pas sortir de l'Union Europe.
Ouais.
L'euro monnaie fantôme parce que basé
que sur de la flute de politiciens, non
pas sur de l'énergie et du vrai boulot.
Euh, les dettes s'accumulent. Euh on se
on se fâche tellement avec euh les
Russes
que bah on sanctionne tout le monde.
Désolé pour le scotch. Euh, on
sanctionne tout le monde et eux nous
sanctionnent façon euh pop-of,
c'est-à-dire en miroir euh façon miroir.
Résultat des courses, notre industrie
calanche. On se fait racheter nos boîtes
à gauche à droite. Euh, on se retrouve
nos yeux pour pleurer en short,
sans bob, sans crème solaire et en plein
cagnard. Les gens commencent à se
fâcher,
des parties extrêmes arrivent.
Le rou, on est où ? L'Europe, on est où
? L'Union européenne, on est où ?
En fait,
la meilleure prospective, on l'a fait en
regardant le réel aujourd'hui.
Et je pense que l'euro
euh
a perdu combien de de valeur là cette
année ?
Il a pas perdu tant que ça. Enfin, là
encore, c'est du comparatif, hein.
L'euro, il a pas perdu de valeur par
rapport au dollars. C'est le dollar qui
perd de la valeur parce que c'est la
politique de Trump de faire perdre de la
valeur au dollar. Et c'est d'ailleurs
une catastrophe pour l'euro parce qu'en
fait cette perte de valeur du dollar va
coûter beaucoup plus cher à l'Union
européenne que les tarifs douigners que
Trump. Tout le monde parle des tarifs
doués mais le vrai sujet c'est pas les
tarifs doués. Le les tarifs doués sont
un sujet mais ce qui va coûter le plus
cher à l'industrie européenne de très
loin c'est la politique du dollar
faible. Euh
donc je peux pas vous donner les
chiffres en valeur absolue. Je connais
pas les cours de change du jour voyez.
Mais je crois que ce qui compte c'est
comme le PIB, c'est les dynamiques et
pas et pas et pas la la l'image figée.
Si ça se passe, c'estàd
Mais mais en fait, regardons l'euro.
Pour moi, l'euro euh si je regarde la
situation de la France aujourd'hui, je
pense que l'euro est sans doute un des
facteurs qui l'explique le plus. Je je
dis pas par là que l'euro soit la cause
de tous nos malheurs, mais l'euro a été
la raison de notre anesthésie générale.
Si on avait une monnaie nationale, les
choix collectifs qu'on a fait depuis des
années nous auraient obligé à dévaluer à
de nombreuses reprises. Ou alors, ce qui
est encore plus probable, on aurait pas
fait les mêmes choix collectifs.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on va à l'assemblée
il y a quelques jours dans une sorte
d'euphorie socialiste
improbable ?
faitant la suspension de la réforme des
retraites. Mais parce qu'en fait on peut
s'offrir ce ce délire parce que c'est
vraiment du délire, on peut s'offrir ce
délire sans en payer les conséquences.
L'euro
faire l'avocat du diable,
l'Euro l'Euro a permis au responsable
politique français de vivre la
déconnexion rêvée entre les décisions
qu'il prenaient et leurs inéluctables
conséquences. Et ça a créé cette espèce
d'irresponsabilité générale dont on
parlait tout à l'heure.
Je fais l'avocat du diable.
Les retraites,
on suspend, on met en apesanteur, on
annule, bon, appelez ça comment ? Comme
vous voulez. Ça permet d'éviter des
manifestations monstres. Ça permet euh
de donner un petit susucre, de rassurer
un électorat qui va voter euh pas
extrême.
Ça permet en gros peut-être d'acheter
les élections ou de subborner les
élections.
Vous savez, Peter Sloderdick a écrit un
livre
euh assez marquant qui s'appelle
Après-nous le déluge. Le titre du livre,
c'est la reprise de cette formule
apocryphe qui était prêtée à madame
Dubari
et et Slotter Dick dit en fait la vraie
caractéristique de la période que nous
vivons c'est pas
la Comesse.
Comment
la comptesse ?
Euh oui oui. Euh
euh bah madame du Baris quoi. Il y en a
pas il y en a il y en a pas 1000
la maîtresse de Louis XV. Et Slotter Dic
vraie rupture qui caractérise l'époque
que nous vivons, c'est pas une rupture
comme on le dit souvent avec le passé
mais c'est une rupture avec l'avenir.
Ce qui caractérise les sociétés
occidentales aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on
vit pour l'immédiateté
et que
on se moque éperdument
des conséquences de long terme. Et ce
qui manque à la politique aujourd'hui,
c'est d'abord cette
dimension du long terme. C'est d'abord
ce qu'on pourrait appeler des hommes
d'état qui sont capables de se
préoccuper pas seulement du prochain
sondage mais qui sont capables de se
préoccuper de ce qu'on laissera à la
prochaine génération. Pour moi, la
suspension de la réforme des retraite,
c'est pas le sujet, c'est pas la réforme
des retraites. Tout le monde se fout de
la réforme des retraites. Enfin, je veux
dire par là que c'est pas c'est pas
c'est d'ailleurs terrifiant que la
question de la réforme des retraites
soit l'alpha et l'oméga de la vie
politique française depuis des années
maintenant. C'est c'est quand on y
pense, c'est stupéfiant. C'est vraiment
un pays qui est en train de s'endormir
sur le bord de la route en disant
"Laisez-moi mourir ici." Enfin, c'est
c'est un pays qui s'endort ou c'est des
blocs politiques qui sont très
qui reste dans le sens un bloc
électoral.
Oui, exactement. qui a l'épargne, qui a
le machin qui est ce qui est fou c'est
qu'on parle que de ça. Enfin, on vit une
période de bouleversement géopolitique
absolument majeur. Le
noyau non c'est leur noyau.
Mais mais ce que je crois frappant c'est
pas la réforme de c'est pas le problème,
c'est le symptôme du problème. C'est
qu'on est capable d'expliquer aux gens
enfin les mêmes qui font ça, si c'était
utile pour eux de vendre au français la
retraite à 50 ans, il leur dirait "Allez
hop, on y va. la retraite à 50 ans
utile pour eux. Je comprends pas bien ça
veut dire
si c'était utile pour pouvoir rester au
pouvoir pour pouvoir rester en fonction
pour pouvoir
croiser des comme ça.
Bah malheureusement c'est pas que j'en
croise des comme ça c'est que tous les
Français le voient. Enfin, la réforme
des retraites, les les macronistes l'ont
fait en expliquant que c'était, je cite
Emmanuel Macron, la mère des batailles.
C'était la mère des batailles. Euh et et
Emmanuel Macron expliquait qu'il fallait
la faire parce qu'il fallait sauver le
système de retraite par répartition et
que si on faisait pas cette réforme, le
système de retraite entier allait
s'effondrer.
C'est pas ça a pas été aussi poussé par
l'Europe ça. Ça a été aussi poussé par
l'Europe bien sûr, mais parce que les
Européens regardent la France avec un
peu de stupéfaction en se disant euh
votre déficit commercial euh tire euh
l'économie européenne vers le bas et
votre déficit budgétaire menace toute la
zone euro. Et maintenant, vous nous
expliquez que vous voulez faire la
retraite à 62 ans alors que euh,
rappelons-le quand même, les socialistes
danois viennent de voter pour la
retraite à 70 ans. Les socialistes
espagnols ont fait la retraite à 67 ans.
On est le on est le seul pays en Europe
aujourd'hui qui dans la situation
démographique que nous connaissons, un
collégien comprendrait parfaitement
pourquoi c'est totalement aberrant de
baisser l'âge de départ à la retraite
alors qu'on a déjà un système
structurellement déficitaire et un pays
dont les comptes publics font maintenant
frémir d'angoisse la Grèce et le
Portugal.
Après moi le déluge.
Après nous le déluge. Voilà. Et moi ce
qui compte c'est je fais le dernier tour
de manège. Je je veux rester là. Et donc
si j'ai besoin que les socialistes
vendent à leur électorat la dernière
démagogie en vogue, ben je je donne ça
au socialistes et je je reste dans mon
ministère. C'est c'est
ça va se terminer cette histoire. Si la
France fait défaut, si on se fait encore
redégrader notre note, comment ça va se
terminer ici ?
Mais déjà on s'est fait dégrader la note
et et c'est incroyable parce que tout le
monde s'en fout. SN
C 40 caracol quand même non Ouais, le le
CAC 40 caracol mais mais SNP a quand
même avancé de de de 5 ou 6 semaines la
date de sa notation, l'agence de
notation. Ce qui arrive très rarement,
je suis pas du tout un fan des agences
de notation. Il faut quand même se
rappeler que les agences de notation
donnaient les meilleures notes au aux
crédits
euh euh au à tous les crédits douteux de
l'immobilier américain au subprime
américain
euh en plein milieu de la crise qui
commençait. Enfin, les agences de
notation sont généralement les dernières
à réagir. La vérité, c'est que le marché
note déjà beaucoup moins bien la France
que les agences de notation. La France
aujourd'hui place sa dette comme un pays
qui serait noté triple B. Euh, on est
déjà plus A pour le marché. Mais bon, le
fait que SNP a avancé son calendrier, ce
que les agences ne font absolument pas
jamais, mais ce qu'elles font très
rarement.
Il devait partir en vacances peut-être.
Oui, peut-être. Vous avez pas envie
d'attendre ? Non mais ça n'a pas fait un
pli. Enfin, ça a pas suscité une émotion
considérable.
Pour l'instant, tout va bien. Le Titanic
se porte correctement. On a de l'eau un
peu jusqu'au cheville. Ça commence à
faire un peu froid. On voit les glaçons
qui se rapprochent mais l'orchestre joue
toujours.
Qui est-ce qui est dans l'orchestre ?
Ben
ce qui était dans l'orchestre, qui est
dans l'orchestre et qui ne sera plus
dans l'orchestre. dans l'orchestre, il y
a des des responsables politiques qui
pratiquent le déni de réalité pour faire
durer encore un peu l'illusion. Mais il
y a pas seulement des responsables
politiques. Euh il y a il y a la réalité
de notre débat médiatique qui est qui
est quand même
bien souvent assez désolant. Enfin, moi
je suis frappé de ce que et je dis pas
ça comme un reproche à des journalistes
individuellement, mais de le le un débat
médiatique normal
ne devrait pas permettre qu'on parle de
la suspension des de la réforme des
retraites comme si c'était euh un truc
gratuit qu'on pouvait s'offrir
aujourd'hui. Enfin, on devrait raconter
aux gens la vérité de la situation, la
vérité la vérité du mur démographique
qu'on a sous les yeux aujourd'hui. Le
mur démographique. Mais ça, mais qui en
parle ? Quand est-ce qu'on débat
là-dessus ? Quand est-ce qu'on parle des
vrais sujets ? Je pense que il y a
presque un théorème à tenter mais mais
vous êtes plus scientifique que moi. Moi
je suis humblement prof de philo, mais
il y aurait presque un théorème attenté.
Plus un sujet est important et moins il
suscite d'attention collective dans le
débat public, moins il suscite
d'attention médiatique générale et c'est
c'est destructeur comme situation pour
la maturité du débat politique en
France.
Vous autorisez une parenthèse ?
Ouais, je vous en prie. Bah je suis chez
vous quand même. Enfin chez toi, je sais
pas comment on dit.
On est on est sur terre. On est chez
nous.
Sarco en zonzon, le débat médiatique.
Vous avez suivi monsieur Har Arfi de
chez Média Part,
vous avez vu un petit peu comment ça
s'est goupé le dossier Sarkozy.
fascinant quand même.
Mami mamie b en cours
et on en passe et on en passe et on en
passe. Le fait que on vienne pleurer
autour de de Sarco que Darmanin le
visite que il y ait de flics qui le
protègent dans la cellule d'à côté qui
se relau
[Musique]
injusticiable comme un autre ou pas
comme un autre.
Comment ça se fait que le les médias
font les chou gras de Alors certes c'est
le premier président français en zonzon
que machin
c'est quand même pas un petit événement
et alors
mais là encore
et le fait qu'il soit en zonzon
est-ce qu'il faut lui supprimer ses
avantages d'ancien président ? Est-ce
qu'il faut lui retirer là il y en a plus
là
Ouais mais quand il va sortir il va
est-ce qu'il va les récupérer ? Est-ce
qu'il faut le lever
ses médailles déjà ? Est-ce Est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on peut C'est ça a déjà
été fait. La vraie question qu'on peut
se poser, c'est
Macron. Macron, il a il lui a enlevé sa
légion.
Oui.
Ah bon ?
Ouais.
La vraie fait quelque chose de bien pour
une fois.
Je sais pas si c'était bien.
Pourquoi vous savez pas si c'était bien
?
Vous savez pourquoi il a eu la légion
d'honneur ? Dites-moi.
Il a eu la Légion d'honneur après avoir
sorti un par un les enfants de la
maternelle de Neïi
pris en otage par un type qui voulait se
faire exploser.
Human bomb.
Il faut lui laisser. Alors
on peut moi je pense queon on aurait dû
lui laisser. On peut penser tout ce
qu'on veut de Sarkozi et en l'occurrence
je vais vous dire je suis d'autant plus
libre pour le dire qu'il a pas toujours
été tendre avec moi. Si vous regardez ce
qu'il a pu dire à mon sujet.
Il a dit quoi ? Bon, il il a parfois euh
eu des mots assez durs et libre à lui.
Euh
du genre comment
vous regarderez, je vais pas je vais
pas regarder.
Mais non, mais c'est pas il y a rien de
grave là-dedans. Mais en tous les cas,
je veux dire par là que il a pas
toujours été euh tendre à mon égard et
libre à lui. Encore une fois, chacun a
son opinion. Donc tout ça pour dire que
je me sens pas, décidément. Ça vous
dérange si je lâche ce scotch ? Parce
que
demander ça. Ouais, laissez
ou alors vous m'enfilez un autre comme
ça je
euh
c'est de ma faute parce que comme ça ça
protège les vestes.
Non mais c'est très bien, c'est très
bien. Euh le le le fait est que euh je
dis ça du coup, c'est pour préciser d'où
je parle comme on dit en sociologie. Euh
j'ai j'ai j'ai je je dis pas ça par
esprit partisan, mais quelqu'un qui a
qui a qui a sorti des des enfants d'une
prise d'otage euh avec un courage
physique que personne ne peut lui
daigner, vous pouvez en penser ce que
vous voulez. Vous pouvez être en
désaccord radical avec la politique
qu'il a mené, avec tout ce que vous
voulez. Mais à la fin, quand on a gagné
la légion d'honneur pour ça, je pense
que
ça vaut le coup de la lui laisser. Et
maintenant, la vraie question que je me
pose et je me la pose comme un citoyen
parmi d'autres,
est-ce que vraiment il était à ce point
indispensable d'appliquer l'exécution
provisoire à la condamnation de Nicolas
Sarkozy ? Vous demandiez est-ce que
c'est injusticiable comme les autres ?
Ben moi, je me pose la même question.
Est-ce que c'est injusticiable comme les
autres ? Est-ce qu'un justiciable comme
les autres aurait été en prison après sa
condamnation en première instance ? Il a
été condamné. OK. Euh je suis pas
enquêteur, je suis pas policier, je suis
pas magistrat, j'ai pas tout le fond de
dossier. Ce que j'observe c'est sur les
quatre accusations qui étaient portées
contre lui, trois ont été par le
tribunal lui-même ont été disqualifiés.
Et le document de Méiapart, vous évoquez
Fabrice Arfi, qui a été le point de
départ de toute cette histoire est
considéré par le jugement comme étant
probablement un faux. Donc
vous êtes sûr de votre source là ?
Probablement un faux. C'est le texte du
jugement. OK.
à la fin, il est condamné quand même. Il
fait appel. A priori, l'appel est
suspensif. L'appel n'est pas suspensif,
c'estàdire, il y a exécution provisoire
dans des circonstances précises que le
droit évoque. Quand vous avez un
condamné qui présente un risque de
récidive, quand vous avez un condamné
qui présente un risque de fuite, quand
vous avez un condamné qui présente un
risque de subordner des témoins ou de
dissimuler des preuves,
il est mort.
Aucune de ces trois raisons n'a été
retenue. La raison qui a été retenue,
c'est un motif d'ordre public parce que
les faits sont d'une particulière
gravité. Pardon, c'est une totologie.
C'estàd vous condamnez quelqu'un en
disant que les faits sont très graves,
il fait appel. Ça veut dire qu'il pense
que les faits sont pas graves. Il a
droit à une deuxième lecture. C'est le
droit de tout citoyen. Et on verra en
deuxième lecture si les faits sont
graves et s'il est condamné à nouveau,
si sa condamnation est confirmée. Si les
juges étaient si sûrs que ça de leur
verdict, qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient à
craindre d'attendre qu'il y ait un appel
? Et je dis ça encore une fois mais
comme un citoyen parmi d'autres. Je je
j'ai dit de la même manière, je suis pas
au Rassemblement national mais que
l'exécution provisoire imposée à la
condamnation de Marine Le Pen pour le
même motif d'ordre public et de
particulière gravité des faits. Mais
pardon, mais encore une fois je Ensuite,
elle a fait appel comme Nicolas Sarkozy,
l'appel décidera si les condamnations
sont confirmées ou pas, mais de quel
droit et pour quel motif et pour quelle
raison on va imposer cette exécution
provisoire ? Alors, vous avez par
ailleurs dans notre pays tous les jours
des gens qui sont objectivement
dangereux, des gens qui sont
objectivement violents, des gens qui
sont objectivement capable de s'enfuir
ou de se ou de se se mettre à à
subborner des témoins ou de détruire des
preuves et qui pour le coup sont
relâchés dans la nature parce qu'il y a
pas assez de place de prison ou parce
que les juges considèrent que c'est pas
la peine de les garder.
Je je je dis ça encore une fois
comme un français parmi d'autres qui
voudrait pouvoir croire absolument que
la justice est rendue de manière
impartiale dans ce pays mais qui a qui a
qui a vraiment du mal à être certain que
ce soit complètement le cas.
Quand vous voyez la la condamnation de
Sarco, vous pensez au mur des cons ou
vous pensez à Média Part ?
Bah les deux mais en l'occurrence la
condamnation elle vient pas de médiia
part. L'affaire vient de Média part mais
la condamnation elle vient de magistrat.
Pardon, mais encore une fois le le
syndicat de la magistrature qui va euh à
la fête de l'huma
qui participe à des manifestations
de gauche, on peut être magistrat et
avoir des opinions politiques.
Évidemment, il y a aucun problème avec
ça. Les magistrats sont historiens comme
les autres. mais que des syndicats de
magistrats escalités affichent des
préférences politiques.
C'est un problème. Et ce serait
d'ailleurs un problème si c'était dans
le sens inverse. Euh et d'ailleurs, on a
tout à fait euh la certitude que si
c'était dans le sens inverse et si vous
aviez un syndicat de magistrat qui euh
s'engageait dans d'autres partis
politiques,
probablement médiia part pour le coup en
ferait des tonnes de papiers. J'imagine
que vous le pensez comme moi.
Vous faites de la suputation, mon très
cher ami.
Revenons à nos dislocation
européenne de l'Union européenne.
Pourquoi vous regardez votre montre ?
Mais parce que vous m'avez dit que si ça
durait longtemps, c'est que c'était
intéressant. Donc je m'inquiète.
1h30 méfiez-vous hein.
Je rentre dans la zone rouge.
Euh j'en profite euh de dire à notre
communauté votez dans les questions pour
nous faire remonter les questions qui
vous intéressent le plus. Soutenez-nous
sur Tipi parce que c'est grâce à vous
qu'on est totalement indépendant
et qu'on vous aime fort. Et revenons à
notre dislocation de l'Europe. Qui
est-ce qui sort en premier ? Qui ne va
pas sortir en premier ? Est-ce qu'il
faut en fait se serrer les coudes et
essayer de trouver des solutions ? On n
pas d'énergie, on n pas de mine. Est-ce
qu'il faut ouvrir des mines ? Est-ce
qu'il faut forer le gaz de chiste qu'on
a dans notre sous-sol ? Si on en a,
est-ce qu'il faut arrêter
de faire Yaka faucon Agnè panier runaché
qui nous dit il faut engager 100000
personnes dans le nucléaire ?
Donc on a calculé 100000 personnes dans
le nucléaire. après que après que la
même majorité nous a expliqué qu'il
fallait fermer 14 réacteurs nucléaires
en France.
Oui, mais bon, vous avez compris, ça
fait voter les écologistes, c'est sympa,
ça permet de faire un barrage.
Non, mais il faut quand même revenir
làdessus parce que c'est déterminant
politique industrielle. Bon, on sait
rien, c'est pas grave. Vous
vous dites on a pas d'énergie mais c'est
on a pas d'énergie.
L'énergie. Non,
mais c'est ce que vous venez de dire
qu'on avait pas d'énergie.
C'est votre phrase, je vous cite, on
pourra fa checker. Mais si, on a de
l'énergie. Ouais. Le gaz de chiste,
est-ce qu'il faut le forêt ?
Non, mais déjà rien que ça, reprenons la
question du débat sur l'électricité
parce qu'on est à la veille d'un d'un
débat qui va de nouveau
Échelle française ou européenne
à l'échelle française, mais il y a aussi
un enjeu européen majeur, le débat sur
la PPE3.
Je sais que vous avez reçu récemment mon
un bourguignon,
mon grand ami Bernardy ou bien Yve
Bréchet tout récemment avec Louis
Galois. J'ai pas eu le temps de regarder
celle-là, mais j'ai j'ai vu celle avec
Bernard Accoyer qui est un combattant
exceptionnel de du nucléaire depuis
depuis longtemps.
Il est pas facile hein. Il est pas
facile.
Bah heureusement qu'il est pas facile.
Il a fallu du caractère quand même pour
mener ce combat là et on l'a mené
ensemble parce que ces dernières années
on se sentait un peu seul donc ça nous
faisait du bien de nous serrer les
coudes pour reprendre votre expression.
Mais le fait est qu'aujourd'hui le débat
il est toujours devant nous. On vient de
voir la nomination d'une ministre de
l'environnement qui est antinucléaire.
À la tête du WWF, elle a intenté une
action en justice contre l'Union
européenne quand on a gagné le combat
pour inclure le nucléaire dans la
taxonomie verte.
ce qui a été un combat extrêmement rude
au Parlement européen et qu'on a dû
mener malheureusement contre beaucoup de
forces politiques françaises
et notamment contre la majorité
présidentielle à l'époque.
Donc on on est toujours au cœur de ce
débat et la la PPE3 c'est un enjeu qui
est déterminant pour l'avenir du pays,
pour l'avenir de la possibilité même de
la réindustrialisation de la France,
pour l'avenir de notre modèle social et
de de de la vie des des des foyers
français et pour l'avenir de notre
souveraineté et de notre sécurité. Et
donc c'est c'est on peut pas minimiser
l'importance de ce sujet, c'est
impossible. C'est l'un des sujets les
plus déterminants qui va venir dans les
dans les semaines qui qui qui s'ouvrent
maintenant.
Et en fait le choix qu'on doit faire
c'est c'est le le le le but c'est
d'arriver enfin à un choix clair. On
nous explique depuis maintenant 2012 que
il faut faire baisser la part du
nucléaire dans le mix électrique
français et on nous explique qu'il y
aurait une sorte de complémentarité
entre les renouvelables et le nucléaire.
Et cette complémentarité est un mythe.
C'est un mythe. C'est un c'est c'est une
aberration industrielle et c'est une
folie euh budgétaire et une folie
énergétique et et donc le le encore une
fois le
c'est un mythe quand même, on est en
France.
Oui.
Si c'est un mythe, pourquoi on a laissé
perdurer ce mythe ?
Ben, on certains l'ont fait perdurer euh
et d'autres s'y sont opposés mais mais
qui criaient un peu dans le désert. Pas
de grève de la fin à l'Académie des
Sciences.
Euh on n pas vu euh on a sans doute
certainement pas vu une mobilisation
suffisamment forte, mais même encore
aujourd'hui la mobilisation est pas
suffisamment forte, y compris dans le
monde intellectuel et dans le monde
industriel
et et par par par peur du du
politiquement correct. Parce que être
contre les éoliennes, c'est pas bien.
Parce qu'il faut être pour les
éoliennes. Il faut il faut
discuter avec quelqu'un il y a pas
longtemps. Il
faut être pour les renouvelables.
Paraît-il que chez les républicains, on
vote pour les éoliennes parce que ça
fait plaisir aux jeunes.
Ah non, pour le coup les Républicains,
ils ont fait dans leur histoire
certainement beaucoup de de de bêtises.
C'est un grand parti politique qui a une
longue histoire et donc qui a eu
l'occasion de faire parfois des erreurs.
Mais il y a un point sur lequel on n pas
à battre notre coulpe,
ça vous êtes pas tombé dans le piège.
C'est que les Républicains, c'est le
seul parti politique en France avec le
Parti communiste français qui n'a jamais
été antinucléaire, qui a toujours
défendu le nucléaire. toujours tous les
autres partis politiques, tous ont été
ou sont encore antinucléaires.
Et ça pour moi, pour un électeur
français, ça devrait être un critère de
distinction relativement important parce
que derrière cette question là, c'est
bien sûr notre énergie, mais l'énergie
c'est tout. L'énergie c'est tout. C'est
la vie d'une société. L'énergie c'est la
sève qui coule dans l'économie.
L'énergie c'est la condition du modèle
social. L'énergie c'est la garantie de
la sécurité. Donc l'énergie c'est tout.
Et et par ailleurs des mauvais choix
énergétiques sont aussi le symptôme
d'une forme de déraison qui devrait qui
devrait être fuit avec beaucoup de
Vous appelez pas vous appelz ça déraison
on appelle ça de la subordation de vote.
Qu'est-ce que vous connaissez au
nucléaire ?
Alors pour le coup je me suis bien battu
sur le nucléaire donc j'ai eu l'occasion
de beaucoup travailler avec et pour
cette filière. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire réacteurs en France ?
Il y a combien de réacteurs en France ?
Il y a une cinquantaine de réacteurs
actifs
en totalité.
en totalité euh
je crois autour de 70
non échec.
Comment ça fonctionne un réacteur
nucléaire ?
Alors, je suis pas spécialiste de
physique nucléaire. En revanche, je peux
vous expliquer comment on se bat pour le
nucléaire au Parlement européen. Ça
c'est ça c'est mon sujet.
Est-ce que vous êtes renseigné sur la
disponibilité des ressources en uranium
?
Oui. On a combien de stocks en France,
en Europe ?
De quel point de vue ? pour recharger un
réacteur.
Oui, on a combien de temps d'avance ?
On a combien de comp
d'uranium en réserve ?
En réserve pour nos réacteurs ?
Mais le le plus important c'est
combien d'années combien d'années on est
capable de mettre les piles ? Vous
savez, vous avez vu le petit lapin avec
la pub Bernard Tapi du racel
et euh on va on va essayer de résumer ça
gentiment. les crayons de combustible,
l'uranium qu'on met qu'on met dedans,
on a combien de réserves en France ?
Le plus important question deè partie de
la question, c'est
on va dans le quel pays ? On s'en fout
de ça. On va dans quel pays pour aller
se réapprovisionner en uranium ? Et là,
je vois la terre entière vouloir faire
de des réacteurs. La Chine qui construit
un réacteur par mois,
tout le monde veut faire les Américains,
tout le monde, les Indiens, tout le
monde, même les même en Afrique, ils
construisent des des réacteurs. Est-ce
que va pas y avoir un problème de
disponibilité de la ressource ?
La question pour nous, c'est quelle est
la diversité des possibilités
d'approvisionnement ? C'est ça le le
l'enjeu clé, c'est de pas dépendre d'un
seul pays pour importer de l'uranium.
C'est ça le le le sujet majeur en terme
de en terme de sécurité et de
souveraineté.
Et donc, vous êtes renseigné là-dessus.
Aujourd'hui, il y a il y a euh
suffisamment de diversité dans la
possibilité d'approvisionnement pour
qu'on ait pas typiquement aujourd'hui,
on nous explique que le nucléaire, c'est
la nouvelle matrice au Parlement
européen, on nous explique le nucléaire
c'est mal parce que on importe de
l'uranium de Russie. Euh alors, il y a
des types de réacteurs qui ne peuvent
utiliser que des notamment en Europe
centrale parce qu'ils ont été construits
par la Russie. Donc il y a des types de
réacteurs qui effectivement ne peuvent
utiliser que du combustible qui vient de
de Russie. Mais mais pour nous en
France, c'est faux de faire croire que
le nucléaire serait l'occasion d'une
dépendance à l'égard de la Russie.
Il y a plusieurs
il peut donner de l'uranium à tout le
monde facilement. Mais pas un seul pays
mais
le Niger le Niger après tout le problème
c'est la question géopolitique, c'est la
question de la stabilité géopolitique et
ce qui s'est passé en Afrique est pas
innocent de ce point de vue je suis
désolé d'être un peu vulgaire mais on va
pas se retrouver à poil
vu que notre
vu que notre président de la République
bon sa politique extérieure et surtout
en Afrique un échec. Bon faut dire que
les Chinois et les Russes ont aidé un
petit peu l'échec.
Enfin, ils ont ils ont pas eu besoin d'y
mettre trop de moyens non plus.
Oui,
on a quand même été euh
écarté d'Afrique par du continent
africain, des pays africain par des des
opérations d'influence assez
rudimentaires euh et qu'un pays comme la
France avait a priori les moyens de
combattre s'il avait eu la lucidité
nécessaire. C'est la franchise
et et la et la volonté la volonté
politique.
Et si on avait pas aider ces opérations
d'influence en jouant en nous-même le
rôle que ceux qui nous caricaturaient
rêvaient de nous voir remplir.
Comment on va faire pour l'uranium si
les Russes ferment le robinet ?
L'Afrique nous dit "Bon, tu es gentil
mais Macron, il nous a laissé tellement
un goût amer que bon, on va on va
attendre un peu, on va donner ça à nos
copines."
Mais c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
dimension déterminante dans cette
relation géopoli. C'est quoi les
solutions ? Une relation géopolitique,
la diplomatie, ça ne se reconstruit pas
sur un coup de baguette magique.
La la confiance, ça se gagne goutte
après goutte. Et après, il y a Emmanuel
Pon qui passe et c'est une hémorragie.
Ça ça se reconstruit d'autant plus que
ça se reconstruit comment ? Mais et ça
se reconstruit d'autant plus que la
Chine et la Russie qui ont pris le
terrain euh qui ont conquis le terrain
qu'on a laissé euh sont en train de de
ne pas laisser euh que de bonnes
impressions de leur présence sur le
continent africain. À nous d'être
suffisamment malin pour exploiter ces
vulnérabilités. Je je suis pas sûr que
la code de popularité des mercenaires de
Wagner en Afrique soit aussi importante
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était quand elle
est ferme de troll de de de Poutine
faisait de Prigogine faisait des des des
des opérations d'intox sur les forces
armées françaises. Maintenant, les
choses ont peut-être un peu changé et
donc voilà, quand on aura l'occasion
d'une vraie alternance en France et ben
il faudra que le nouveau chef de l'État
reprenne avec l'humilité, la simplicité,
la franchise, la clarté qui a
certainement manqué à la diplomatie
française au cours des dernières années
reprennent le le chemin du continent
africain et rouvre un dialogue qui est
absolument nécessaire pour nous comme
pour ces pays. parce que je crois
profondément que les laisser entre les
les mains de la Chine et de la Russie,
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas leur faire un
cadeau.
Il y a il y a un documentaire très très
intéressant qui est vieux d'ailleurs de
sur les fermes à troll de
Saint-Pétersbourg par Paul Morera. C'est
c'est graviard.
À l'époque c'était c'est
le cas de le dire.
Ouais. Il à l'époque c'est 4500 m²
d'usinatrol. Maintenant ils sont à 15000
m². Et et et maintenant pour le coup
avec l'IA, on va industrialiser les
process de telle sorte que le facteur
humain sera même plus tellement
nécessaire. Donc
confier un petit truc parce que nous on
fait aussi de la diplomatie parallèle.
J'ai fait bugger le numéro 2. Ouais.
J'ai fait bugger le numéro 2 du
ministère de l'intérieur russe grâce à
Paul à Paul Morera sur les fermatrol. C
mourir de rien. Bon, passons.
Mais mais revenons peut-être sur le le
sujet du nucléaire. Ce qui a fragilisé
le nucléaire aujourd'hui, c'est pas le
manque de disponibilité de l'uranium,
hein.
Ça risque de l'être.
Oui, mais enfin en tous les cas, c'est
pas le problème aujourd'hui. Le vrai
problème aujourd'hui.
Il faut penser les problèmes de demain
aussi, mon
D'accord. Mais enfin pour pouvoir penser
les problèmes de demain, pour avoir le
luxe de se préoccuper des problèmes de
demain, faut résoudre ceux d'aujourd'hui
parce que on aura pas tellement besoin
de se préoccuper de la disponibilité en
uranium si la France est toujours euh
piégée dans cette espèce de pensée
magique qui veut qu'on ait partout des
des énergies renouvelables en parallèle
d'un parc nucléaire dont on se préoccupe
jamais de réfléchir à l'avenir parce que
c'est ça qui nous guettete en fait à
travers la PPE3. C'est ça le vrai sujet.
On se prend quelques questions internet.
Allez.
Euh alors occasion de saluer tous ceux
qui nous regardent. Ça ça va l'irer
parce que je vais toucher ingénieur du
son. Réveille-toi.
Je prends la toute première. Non, ça
c'est des questions pour monsieur Tangy.
On a reçu Jean-Philippe Tangy.
J'ai vu aussi. J'ai pu regarder en
entier.
C'est très bien débrouillé.
Première question 19h56. Que
connaissez-vous de la Russie
pointinterrogation ? Avez-vous déjà
voyagé là-bas ? Et je rajouterai que
connaissez-vous de l'Ukraine ? Avez-vous
voyagé là-bas ?
Euh, je
je j'ai eu l'occasion de voyager en
Russie. Euh
quelle année ? Combien de fois, organisé
? Comment ? C'était sur vos propres
denierers, c'était quand vous étiez
étudiant ? C'était payé par l'Union
européenne ou vous avez
Non, non, non, j'étais pas j'étais pas
encore élu. Euh c'était euh quelle année
?
Quel âge vous avez ? J'ai toujours juste
40 ans. Ça me fait bizarre de dire ça.
Bah je vieilli quoi. Euh
vous êtes pas marié ?
Non.
Et on fait comment pour la démographie ?
Vous avez des enfants ?
Bah il faut se marier.
Vous avez des Non mais obligé de se
marier pour avoir des enfants. Et vous
avez des enfants ? Non, mais j'espère en
avoir.
Et euh quand on entend Emmanuel Macron
dire réarmer la natalité euh en France,
ben ensuite, on écoute le gouvernement
qui dit "Rabotez encore euh la la
politique familiale." Voilà, c'est la
réalité. C'est c'est très beau de parler
de rarmement démographique, mais en
vérité depuis François Hollande et
Emmanuel Macron, il y a une continuité
magnifique dans la destruction
méthodique de la politique familiale qui
faisait la force de la France et qui
faisait que la France avait encore un
peu de dynamique dans sa natalité parmi
les pays européens qui étaient tous en
train de se dévitaliser. Donc il y a
comme souvent les grandes déclarations
et puis derrière il y a la réalité des
faits et des actes. Et moi quand
j'entends que le même gouvernement qui
suspend la réforme des retraites va
encore raboter les allocations
familiales, je dis que c'est
effectivement malheureusement le choix
de la génération qui s'en va plutôt que
de soutenir celle qui vient et celle qui
devrait naître.
Euh je reprends la question.
Connaissez-vous la Russie ? Je rajoute
connaissez-vous l'Ukraine ? Avez-vous
déjà voyagé là-bas ? J'ai jamais été en
Ukraine. J'ai été en Russie une fois euh
quelques jours.
Avant la guerre, l'Ukraine c'était
magnifique, hein.
Mais je je j'espère pouvoir aller en
Ukraine. Euh et
donc c'était pourquoi la Russie ?
J'ai été en Russie parce que j'ai été
invité à l'époque par euh des des
Français de Moscou pour venir faire des
conférences quand j'avais publié un
livre, mon premier livre pour le coup.
Quelle année ?
Et je pense que c'était en 2015 je
crois, de mémoire. Je suis pas
totalement sûr. Vous
l'avez un peu inquiété si
mais j'y suis allé seulement quelques
jours et pour tout dire, un monsieur
dans l'avion m'avait fait cette réponse
qui m'a frappé et il m'avait dit "Vous
vous allez en Russie ?" Et j'avais dit
"Oui". Et il m'avait dit "Vous allez où
en Russie ?" Et j'avais dit "Je vais à
Moscou." Et il m'avait répondu "Ah bah
vous allez pas en Russie alors." Donc je
peux pas prétendre connaître la Russie
parce que sans doute l'expérience que
j'en ai était beaucoup trop limitée pour
affirmer.
Vous êtes resté à Moscou même ? Oui.
Et vous êtes pas sorti de l'aéroport
quoi ?
Si si si, mais j'ai passé euh je crois
quelques peut-être une petite semaine
dans Moscou.
Vous êtes baladé euh en dehors
euh en dehors de Moscou ? justement,
j'étais resté à Moscou, je me suis
baladé dans Moscou
et mais c'est c'est c'était d'ailleurs,
je me souviens très bien, c'était la
semaine du euh ça devait être autour de
la mi-mai, c'était juste après la
célébration du 9 mai puisque la Russie
faite la victoire de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale le 9 mai et pas le 8. Euh et
c'était très marquant parce que le 9
mai, il y a le défilé militaire dont on
voit souvent les images, mais euh dans
l'après-midi euh il y a un défilé qui
réunit euh tous les gens qui veulent
venir dans la société russe et euh qui
défilent en portant les photos de leurs
grands-parents à air grands-parents qui
ont participé à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale, soit en étant soldat, soit
parce qu'ils étaient au champ, enfin les
les femmes qui travaillaient dans dans
les usines ou dans les mines pendant que
les hommes combattaient et donc
pour aller boter le cul des cheveux,
c'est ça ?
Et donc les les Russes euh défile dans
Moscou avec les photos de leur de leurs
grands-parents ou
arrière-grands-parents. Ça s'appelle le
bataillon des immortels dans mon
souvenir. Et ensuite une fois qu'ils ont
terminé cette manifestation, ils
accrochent ces photos partout dans
Moscou. Et donc dans les dans les bars,
dans les restaurants et cetera, il y
avait des des des photos euh de de tous
les anonymes russes qui euh
ça a laissé quelques séquel chez eux,
hein.
Énorme. Mais là aussi, je pense qu'on on
peut difficilement comprendre de toute
façon, on peut difficilement comprendre
la situation actuelle si on la place pas
dans l'histoire longue.
Qui fait ça encore ?
Poutine,
histoire longue.
Oui, je pense que Poutine a une vision
une vision euh
non dialectique d'ailleurs de l'histoire
de la Russie mais parce que sans doute
la Russie porte ça en elle. Je prétends
pas en être un expert mais c'est ce qui
m'a toujours fasciné dans la Russ de
faire ça.
Mais en un sens, je crois qu'il vaut
mieux avoir une vision dialectique de
l'histoire. Moi ce qui m'a frappé par
exemple en Russie, c'était de voir dans
les quelques jours que j'y ai passé,
donc je prétends encore une fois pas du
tout en être un expert, mais ce qui
m'avait frappé, je me rappelle très
bien, c'est
2015, vous étiez pas encore élu, c'est
ça ?
Non,
vous étiez juste prof de philo.
Oui.
Et comment ça se fait que vous aviez été
repéré pour aller présenter votre
bouquin à Moscou ?
J'ai publié un livre qui s'appelait Les
déshérités euh en 2014 qui a eu un écho
que j'aurais pas imaginé. C'était pour
parler de la crise de l'école et plus
largement de la crise de la transmission
et ça m'a valu d'être invité un peu
partout. J'ai fait le tour surtout du
pays hein, j'ai était partout en France.
Comment vous avez été repéré pour aller
là-bas ?
Ben je vous dis c'est des Français de
Moscou mais comme j'avais été
vous étiez déjà encarté chez les
républicains.
Non,
je pose la question parce que des fois
il y a des puissances étrangères qui
repèrent des talents montants.
Non, c'était vraiment des Français là
euh avec qui je suis resté en lien
d'ailleurs avec
chef d'entreprise
c'était des Français qui avaient des
activités. Oui. qui qui travaillait à
Moscou et qui mais encore une fois j'ai
de même que j'ai été invité à Poitier à
Clerontferrand et euh
Poitier Claironferrand c'est pas Moscou
bien sûr mais j'ai été invité un peu
partout pour parler de ce livre parce
qu'il avait suscité un un intérêt
qu'encore une fois j'avais pas du tout
prévu.
Quel regard vous portez sur François
Fillon ? et et ce qui m'avait frappé du
coup euh à Moscou sur la place rouge en
particulier, c'est de voir qu'au même
endroit, vous avez le mausolée de
Lénine, vous avez les églises que les
Russes ont reconstruit avec leur propre
denier après euh euh après la la chute
de l'Union soviétique et euh et vous
avez le le créelin bien sûr et en face
les les grands magasins qui euh qui qui
présentent tous les tous les tous les
produits de de la de la mode
internationale. Donc il y a une espèce
de mélange et il y avait un type au
milieu de la place rouge qui faisait
vous savez le le la manche en en jouant
la statue figé et en l'occurrence
c'était Staline.
Moi, je crois que c'est bien d'avoir une
vision dialectique de l'histoire et que
et que Staline était un un l'un des plus
grands criminels de l'histoire de
l'humanité et je comprends tous les pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale qui qui
veulent pas revenir
sous le sous le jou de de cette
de cette de cette violence absolue.
Quel question ? Quelle était ma question
?
La question était pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a pas une vision dialectique de
l'histoire ? Pour qu'est-ce que vous
pensez que pensez de François Fillon ?
Qu'est-ce que je pense de François
Fillon ? Ben pour moi, vous parliez tout
à l'heure de de de ces ces ces moments
qui font douter de la justice. La la
l'incroyable accélération du temps
judiciaire dans la situation de François
Fillon a fait partie de ces moments-là.
Je pense que je pense que ça ça vaut le
coup d'être appelé parce que quand on
voit les développements récents, on peut
on ne peut pas ne pas les relier.
Alors, c'était quoi François Fillon ?
C'était les costumes sa femme qui était
payé euh mais qui travaillait pas
d'après ce queon a pu lire, c'est ça ?
Euh
c'était quoi ? On l'a désingué avant la
guerre pour éviter que il aille traîné
avec ses copains.
Ben la seule chose qu'on peut observer
que entre le moment où une information
est sortie dans la presse, en
l'occurrence le canard enchaîné sur le
fait qu'il aurait potentiellement mal
usé les fonds de l'Assemblée nationale
et le moment où il a été mis en examen,
il a dû s'écouler quoi je sais plus 15
jours, 3 semaines. On avait jamais vu la
justice aussi rapide, n'est-ce pas ?
Après, il a fallu des années d'ailleurs
pour que les choses aillent au bout de
cette procédure judiciaire.
La
la la personne qui nous expliquera que
cette
accélération ou en tous les cas que
cette vitesse était normale et qu'elle
correspondait à à la vitesse ordinaire
des procédures judiciaires,
je je je l'ai jamais rencontré. Et et
par ailleurs là encore, on n' pas fait
beaucoup de bruit avec ça, mais quand
quand euh de mémoire la patronne du
parquet national financier expliqué
qu'elle qu'elle était euh exposée à des
à des pressions euh politiques pour
accélérer les choses et qu'elle a
expliqué ça dans une commission
d'enquête à l'Assemblée nationale, euh
ça aurait dû démocratie normale qui
s'inquiète de sa propre santé, ça aurait
dû susciter un débat public national,
ce qui n'a pas été le cas.
Non.
Donc l'Ukraine, vous avez pas visité
l'Ukraine ?
Non, j'ai jamais été en Ukraine mais
j'espère y aller.
C'est très joli. Du moins, c'était très
joli.
Deuxème question,
je la lis, je la découvre avec vous.
Pourquoi dénonce-til l'impunité d'école
blanc ? Mais il va rendre visite à
Sarkozi avant son incarcération. Vous
avez jamais été visité Sarkozi ? J'ai vu
Nicolas Sarkozi. Oui.
Quand ça ?
Il y a quelques jours.
Pourquoi faire ? pour lui amener des
oranges.
Non, j'ai j'ai
défendu publiquement dans les médias la
position que je défendais à l'instant
devant vous. C'est-à-dire que je je
suis vraiment profondément
préoccupé de ce que signifie
l'application de cette exécution
provisoire. Et donc il m'a il m'a il m'a
remercié de la position que j'avais
prise et m'a proposé de passer le voir.
Et donc je je suis passé le voir.
Et comment il va ?
Euh ben je je garderai pour moi
l'échange qu'on a eu, mais j'ai été
vraiment impressionné par euh j'ai été
impressionné par euh par euh
il
ne se plaint pas une seconde.
Encore heureux ?
Ben
c'est un homme.
Ouais ben ça mérite d'être souligné
quand même.
Question internet le alors je la
découvre avec vous. J'espère qu'elle est
bien formulée, qu'il y a pas de bêtises
de l'anadoxe
de Trifin dit que la monnaie de réserve
doit être en déficit commercial. L'euro
veut ce statut mais l'Allemagne impose
l'austérité et les excédents. Résultat,
pas assez d'euros en circulation. Le
Dollar reste hégémonique à 88 %. Ça doit
il doit dire 9 % en terme de
transaction. Et la Chine prépare quelque
chose en achetant de l'or en masse.
L'Allemagne préfère son modèle
exportateur à la puissance de l'euro.
Vous ne proposez rien pour y remédier.
Pourquoi ?
J'ai j'ai deux désaccords avec
la question de Trifin.
Non, Trifin, ça c'est le le le paradoxe
de Trifin. Rem, c'est la question de
Gaë. Gaë, j'ai deux désaccords avec la
question de Gaëel. D'abord, je crois pas
du tout que l'Europe veuille que l'euro
devienne une monnaie de réserve.
Je crois pas du tout qu'elle ait jamais
eu cette ambition d'ailleurs. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est sans doute un symptôme
intéressant, mais je pense pas que
l'Europe a jamais pensé l'euro dans une
logique de puissance. Jamais.
Deuxièmement, je crois pas que
l'Allemagne d'aujourd'hui corresponde à
ce que Gaë en décrit. Je crois pas que
l'Allemagne soit restée terriblement
austéritaire.
Non, là ils vont s'en taquer pour
s'armer
et c'est le moment de réaliser ce qui
est en train de se passer pour nous.
La dette française, elle va être
vachement moins sexy sur les marchés si
les Allemands ils commencent à venir
racoller pour vendre leur dettes.
Exactement. Donc si on continue de
penser que l'Allemagne est austéritaire,
on va pas du tout comprendre ce qui va
nous arriver. En 2026, la France a un
stock de dette absolument
inédit à refinancer.
Combien ?
Euh là encore, je saurais pas. Je je
j'ai su le chiffre, je l'ai plus en
tête. Mais en tous les cas, c'est un
volume qui va être très important
et ça va être extrêmement compliqué
parce que la dette italienne est devenue
plus compétitive que la nôtre et que
l'Allemagne qui a toujours été plus
compétitif que nous mais qui ne
s'endettait pas, donc sa dette était
très rare, maintenant va lever
massivement de l'argent sur les marchés
et donc et donc ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour France Trésor de réussir
à placer la dette française. Si on le
met avec un petit taux variable,
Ouais. Mais ça va nous coûter beaucoup
plus cher,
surtout si les taux augmentent.
Les taux vont augmenter. Ils ont déjà
massivement augmenté, ils vont continuer
d'augmenter et surtout ils vont d'autant
plus augmenter qu'on aura des
concurrents qui proposeront une dette
plus crédible et donc plus avantageuse
à ceux qui voudront en acheter. Donc
donc le le fait est que il faut prendre
la mesure de ce que signifie le fait que
l'Allemagne est rompue avec le modèle
austéritaire.
Et ce matin, j'étais au sommet du PPE
avec
le le Chance Limert. Euh aujourd'hui,
l'Allemagne est engagé de manière
déterminée dans une trajectoire
d'investissement industriel majeur et et
ça va être pour nous d'une certaine
manière la double peine parce que on on
est on est non seulement confronté au
retour en puissance de de la de la
dynamique allemande par le biais de
l'investissement, mais on l'est à un
moment où nous on n plus du tout les
marges de manœuvre. pour éviter le
décrochage que cette situation va créer.
L'Allemagne a peur.
L'Allemagne a peur bien sûr, mais le
modèle allemand est quand même
aujourd'hui profond profondément ébranlé
parce que le le pari de la dépendance
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure, c'était
singulièrement celui de l'Allemagne et
que et que là c'est son c'est le cœur de
son modèle qui est en difficulté. Mais
enfin, l'Allemagne va va voit ses ses
fondamentaux vacillés, mais encore une
fois, redisons-le. Euh, elle en a sous
le pied beaucoup plus que nous pour
affronter les temps difficiles, hein.
Euh, et et la vérité, c'est que c'est
que quand vous dites euh quand tu dis
euh elle en a sous le pied, c'est parce
que quoi ? Elle est endettée à combien
de pourcent ? 60
64 % de dette sur p %.
Donc, elle a la capacité de mon
de mémoire
de Alors, elle a la capacité de monter
euh
à combien ? À 100 ? Non, il ira pas à
100 parce que je pense que il reste
quand même en Allemagne rapport à la
dette qui est différent d'une autre.
Mais en tous les cas, elle va
s'endetter. Elle peut s'endetter
massivement et euh en tous les cas, elle
peut investir massivement et ce que nous
ne pouvons plus faire.
C'est combien le PIB de l'Allemagne ?
Là encore pareil, j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'ordre de grandeur.
Question internet que je découvre avec
vous, que je prends dans l'ordre.
Alors, je la lis. L'influence qu'A en
France paralyse-t-elle notre débat sur
l'immigration et l'identité pour
interrogation ? Et si oui, une sortie de
Schengen pour reprendre le contrôle de
nos frontières ne nécessite-elles pas
d'abord de nous libérer de ces
dépendances économiques étrangères ?
L'influence Qatarie, elle euh je crois
qu'elle se elle se lit dans le débat
alors sur l'immigration, je sais pas
mais en tous les cas dans le dans le
dans le débat sur euh
l'intégration au sens large ou en tous
les cas ce qui fait que que
l'assimilation soit devenue à ce point
tabou. Et et là encore, je reviens aux
publicités de la Commission européenne,
euh la liberté est dans le hijab. D'où
est-ce que tout ça vient ? Ben, ça vient
du fait que la Commission européenne
depuis des années a entretenu des
relations institutionnelles structurées
avec une organisation qui s'appelle le
FISO. Fémiso qui défend le féminisme
musulman
euh qui est en fait bien sûr la
promotion du voileur. Euh le FISO est
une organisation qui est liée euh aux
frères musulmans. Vous avez des preuves
de ça
notamment c'est c'est c'est alors
évidemment le le déni est total hein.
Ils vont ils vont évidemment le nier. Et
moi, j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire et de
l'écrire et de le publier notamment par
le le biais d'une plateforme qui
s'appelle Enar, European Network Against
Racism, le la plateforme européenne, le
réseau européen contre le racisme.
Derrière ce joli mot de réseau européen
contre le racisme, il y a une
organisation qui en fait promeut l'islam
politique
et qui a été dirigée par quelqu'un qui
se présente comme un ancien frère
musulman.
Je rencontrais récemment un
un diplomate d'un d'un pays arabe qui me
disait qu'il était stupéfait de la
naïveté avec laquelle les Européens
laissent les frères musulmans opérer sur
leur sol.
C'était quel pays arabe ? C'est
je dirais pas parce que pour le coup je
je dirais pas
cit par là quoi.
Je dirais pas du tout mais c'est
il parlait il parlait l'arabe classique,
l'arabe littéraire. Il parlait quel
arabe ? Euh en l'occurrence, on parlait
anglais. Euh mais par
arabe,
comment ?
Vous savez dire quelques mots ?
Pas du tout.
Euh
là là
j'ai été au Mais j'ai été aux Émirats.
Euh vous parliez des Émirats ?
Vous étiez où aux Émirats ?
J'ai été à Abu Dhabi et euh et à Dubaï.
Qui est-ce qui payait le voyage ?
Euh
c'est le Parlement européen. J'ai fait
un déplacement dans le cadre du
Parlement. On a on a des moyens
relativement euh euh enfin on a on a une
une enveloppe.
Vous dormiez où ? À Dubaï.
Je dormais euh
à Abu Dhabi ou à Dubaï, enfin les deux.
Euh mais à l'hôtel.
Quel hôtel ?
Euh un hôtel du groupe Accord. Je
saurais pu me rappeler lequel. Mais euh
quand vous avez passé la douane, vous
aviez un passeport diplomatique ?
J'avais euh
j'avais non, j'avais mon passeport
français.
Vous avez donné votre emprintis ?
Je peux même le dire parce que j'ai eu
une petite angoisse parce qu'il était
périmé 6 mois plus tard et je je me suis
rendu compte au dernier moment que
j'avais peut-être pas été assez prudent
sur le renouvellement de mon passeport.
Vous avez laissé votre empreinte d'Iris
?
Euh j'ai fait une enfin vous avez le le
la photo à l'aéroport
donc c'est possible. Je sais pas. Ils
vous ont donné une petite carte SIM ?
Non.
Dans le passeport ?
C en quelle année ça ?
C'était il y a 1 an.
Tout ça pour dire que aux Émirats, j'ai
rencontré euh des des
euh des Émiratis qui m'ont dit euh c'est
stupéfiant que vous laissiez faire les
islamistes sur votre sol. Euh et j'ai
visité euh ce lieu incroyable qui a été
construit à à Abou Dhabi euh où sur un
même site, ils ont construit euh trois
bâtiments de la même taille, une
mosquée, une église, une synagogue de la
même taille et ils m'ont fait visiter
ces ces ces trois lieux. Et dans la
synagogue, il me dit on est voilà, on
est on est on est on est très on est
très fier et très heureux de montrer que
que euh des des personnes de confession
juif peuvent pratiquer leur religion ici
au aux Émirats et je leur dis "Vous avez
une communauté juive importante ?" et
ils disent "Bah, on a une communauté
juive." Oui. qui qui commence à à
d'ailleurs se se développer vraiment
parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de
personnes de confession juives qui
arrivent d'Europe aujourd'hui parce
qu'elles se sent ils sont très tolérants
à Dubaï.
Du mot aux Émirats
ex elles se sentent plus en sécurité aux
Émirats qu'en Europe.
Vous êtes sorti de Dubaï ? C'est c'est
quand même quand vous voyez quelqu'un
euh qui assume euh de représenter un
pays musulman conservateur et qui vous
dit
les juifs en Europe sont trop inquiets
pour rester dans vos pays et ils
viennent chez nous parce qu'ils se
sentent plus en sécurité. Est-ce qu'on
se rend compte de l'ampleur du signal
d'alarme que ça doit représenter ?
Sorti de Dubaï ?
J'ai été dans le désert.
un truc pour touriste quoi.
J'ai été là encore, j'ai allé rencontrer
la communauté française là-bas et donc
non, j'allais rencontrer la communauté
française aux Émirats et ils m'ont dit
"Mais c'est pas c'est pas possible si
vous venez." C'était assez court, je
suis resté 3 jours. Mais donc on a on a
juste été passé 2 heures pour voir le le
désert et en l'occurrence pour voir
l'incroyable centrale solaire au milieu
du désert près de près de Dubaï.
Est-ce qu'en Europe, il faut réouvrir
des mines ? En Europe, il faut réouvrir
des mines. Oui, bien sûr.
Type pour aller chercher quoi ?
Bah, je vous donne un sujet très
concret. Je je
me bat là encore et c'est un combat qui
devrait avoir beaucoup plus de place
dans l'actualité française. Je me bat
pour réussir à sortir la
Nouvelle-Calédonie de l'impasse où elle
se trouve. Et la Nouvelle-Calédonie
aujourd'hui est clairement ciblée par
ces ingérences étrangères dont on
parlait tout à l'heure.
L'Azerbidjan.
L'Azerbaïdjan. C'est quand même
stupéfiant. Arrêtons-nous juste sur ce
point. L'Azerbaïdjan. L'Azerbaïdjan
finance, organise
le monde indépendantiste en
Nouvelle-Calédonie. L'Azerbaïdjan
organise ce qu'ils appellent le forum de
Baku pour la décolonisation. C'estàd
qu'ils invitent à leur frais des
indépendantistes. Maintenant, c'est plus
seulement la Nouvelle-Calédonie, c'est
les Antilles. Ils invitent des gens qui
veulent que le territoire français,
parce que ces territoires sont français,
soient retirés.
Territoire, c'est la France tout court.
France. Oui, c'est le territoire
français. Euh que le territoire français
soit retiré à la France, c'est une
guerre de territoire. Euh il et il
financ de manière publique. Euh
l'Aerbaïdjan organise un colloque à
Numea sur la je cite la décolonisation
des outres mères français. Et quelle est
la réponse de la France du gouvernement
français ?
Un tweet. Un tweet du CADOC. Euh comment
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on soit pris
au sérieux après ça ? Donc aujourd'hui,
on on voit la la Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui a été piégé dans ces spirales de la
violence qui encore a été aussi pensé
depuis l'étranger.
Et j'allais dire d'une certaine manière
là encore je reviens sur ce que je
disais des ONG dans le dans le dans le
débat qui est des gens qui en
Nouvelle-Calédonie militent pour
l'indépendance, c'est la démocratie.
Libre à eux de le faire. En revanche,
que ces gens soient financés par des
puissances étrangères, ça c'est
complètement différent. Et là, ça
devrait être pour le coup un enjeu de
sécurité nationale qui n'est pas traité
au bon niveau. Alors, on va on va
enlever les crêtages les crêtages de
financement d'ingérence extérieur.
Vous les comprenez les indépendantistes
?
La France,
on investit quoi là-bas ? On s'en occupe
un petit peu de nos territoires d'outre
mer.
Ben en l'occurrence, on aurait
la Martinique, la Guadeloupe, ils sont
obligés d'acheter franco-français, ils
peuvent pas les se fournir à côté.
Donc ça coûte plus cher
quand vous voyez le pack de
il se f ils se fournissent aussi à côté
comme comme nous d'ailleurs hein.
Mais le fait est qu'effectivement
l'insularité et l'éloignement
géographique créent des surcouts qui
sont en plus aggravés par l'oxroit de
mer dans dans les Antilles par exemple.
Là là on va se retrouver
et donc un malaise social immense. Oui.
On va se retrouver avec une inflation
dingue. Les économies captives de nos
territoires ou les les économies
insulaires captives,
ça va ne faire que augmenter les
tensions. Ça va être ça va être un
boulevard pour les ingérences
étrangères. Mais c'est c'est déjà mais
le boulevard, il est créé pas par les
tensions internes à ces territoires
auquels il faudrait qu'on qu'on apporte
en effet des réponses et dont on devrait
prendre soin.
J'avais j'avais pris l'engagement au
début de mon premier mandat de de
d'aller dans tous les outres maires
français.
Vous avez été à Mayotte ?
J'ai été à Mayotte plusieurs fois.
Vous étiez où ? À Mayotte.
Ah, j'ai été partout à Mayotte. J'y suis
allé à plusieurs reprises.
Vous êtes arrivé à Bamutzu ? Ben, je
suis arrivé à Petite Terre comme tout le
monde par l'aéroport.
J'ai pris un petit taxi pour prendre le
bateau.
J'ai pris la barge.
Ouais. Le la barge, vous arrivez à la
barge, à droite, il y a le marché. En
face, il y a le rond-point et et la
deuxième sortie du rond-point, vous avez
le seul hôtel deux étoiles de
le caribou. Ouais. Juste là, là avec le
le petit supermarché à côté.
Caribou, ça veut dire quoi caribou ? Ben
caribou, ça veut dire bonjour,
bienvenue.
Et donc
et le caribou, malheureusement, il a été
c'est vraiment endommagé par le par le
cyclone. Mais non, j'ai été partout à
Mayotte, j'ai été vraiment partout sur
Grande Terre.
Quelle année ? Quelle année ?
J'ai été à plusieurs reprises. J'ai été
trois fois à Mayotte.
Quelle année ? La dernière fois.
Et la dernière fois c'était en 2024.
Donc 2024 vous étiez avec la gendarmerie
qui vous accompagnait. Vous avez loué
une voiture et vous avez été vous
baladé. Euh
j'ai été accueilli par des maoris donc
j'ai monté dans la voiture de en
l'occurrence mes amis Maoré me donner
l'occasion de les saluer. Euh
nous on embrasse très fort Mayotte.
Voilà, on embrasse très fort Mayotte.
On connaît Mayotte.
Moi je suis tombé amoureux de Mayotte.
C'est vraiment
les Mayotte nous manquent. Les
Maoreilles nous manquent et euh
mais Mayotte vous savez moi ce qui me
frappe c'est vrai dans les outresemers
en général c'est vrai de Mayotte en
particulier. ce qu'on les autres c'est à
la fois très différent de la métropole
bien sûr euh parce que la réalité est
très différente pour plein de raisons
évidentes et en même temps et en même
temps
toutes les épreuves toutes les
souffrances toutes les défaillances
qu'on voit en notre mer sont
profondément les épreuves, les
souffrances et les défaillances du pays.
C'est c'est vraiment fascinant parce que
l'insularité ça condense tout et donc ça
rend tout extraordinairement lisible.
Ce qui est à grande échelle et parfois
imperceptible devient une évidence
absolue quand vous regardez la situation
à l'échelle insulaire. Et Mayotte, c'est
absolument
euh cristallin. La la la souffrance, la
détresse des Maoré, c'est la c'est la
détresse de la France. Mais c'est une
détresse qui est vécue
dans dans une dans une dans une forme de
de euh de de violence et de clarté à la
fois qui
la détresse aussi de toute la région
hein parce que au Comor c'est la
détresse aussi hein.
Bien sûr mais mais et et à gauche des
Comors, c'est aussi la détresse. Les
comores, c'est la détresse d'un pays qui
est c'est c'est malheureusement la
détresse d'un pays qui est gouverné par
un régime totalement corrompu qui
utilise la France, qui utilise la
question migratoire comme une manière de
se défaire de ses propres problèmes, de
ne pas résoudre ses problèmes. C'est
quoi le business model de l'immigration
? Et c'est vrai d'ailleurs sur une
grande partie du continent africain, le
business de l'immigration, c'est pour ne
pas résoudre les problèmes internes du
pays, pour ne pas réparer des régimes
corrompus, vous exportez du désespoir et
vous importez des devises. Vous exportez
des du désespoir, c'est des jeunes qui
se barrent, qui s'en vont parce qu'ils
ont pas d'avenir chez vous, qui vont en
Europe, en France et qui vous renvoie
des devises pour faire vivre leur
famille. Ils envoient tous les mois de
quoi soutenir ceux qui sont restés au
pays.
Alors, on fait quoi ?
Et et Mayotte, mais Mayotte, c'est c'est
tellement criant la la réalité de la
situation Maoresse, c'est la réalité
d'une crise migratoire qui a tout
déréglé, qui a tout détruit à Mayotte au
point que vous avez plus une
infrastructure qui fonctionne
correctement. Vous savez comment j'ai
connu Mayotte pour la première fois ? La
la c'est le le d'ailleurs c'est le
premier outreur où j'ai été parce que
j'avais été contacté par
Estelle
Mansour Camardine
et qui m'avait appelé pour me parler du
scandale majeur que représente le le le
mauvais emploi des fonds européens qui
était supposé être versé pour l'usine de
désalinisation qui n'a jamais
fonctionné.
Donc l'Europe a mis des des
fonds très importants pour construire
une usine de désalinisation.
Euh ça se chiffre en dizaine de millions
d'euros, je pourrais vous le vous le
retrouver. euh elle n'a jamais été euh
elle a jamais été construite. Et quand
on a euh connu d'un seul coup cette
gigantesque pénurido, les Français en
métropole ont découvert, je sais pas si
d'ailleurs ils le savent tous, mais qu'
Mayotte, ça fait des années, ça fait des
années qu'il y a des tours d'eau. C'est
vous arrivez au caribou, vous arrivez à
l'hôtel et euh la personne derrière le
comptoir qui vous accueille vous donne
un jericane de flotte parce que demain,
il y aura pas d'eau. Donc pour se laver,
il faut utiliser le jerican. C'est un
département français. Et pourquoi cette
pénurie d'eau ?
C'est un département français aussi. Il
y a la lèpre hein.
Oui, c'est un département français. J'y
était pendant l'épidémie de de la la
dernière épidémie de Choléra qui a qui a
touché Mayotte. J'y étais à ce moment-là
pour justement aller aller soutenir
aller soutenir les Maoré et voir ce
qu'on ce qu'on pouvait faire depuis
depuis Bruxelles pour les aider. Mais
mais la vérité c'est que cette épidémie
euh cette crise de l'eau euh toutes les
crises que connaît Mayotte sont liées à
une crise migratoire euh qui est celle
que le pays tout entier connaît aussi,
que la France connaît aussi aujourd'hui.
On va avoir le même problème
d'infrastructure en France,
bien sûr. Bah, on l'a déjà. Enfin euh
je vois que le ministre de l'intérieur
euh se se débattait récemment avec la
question du chiffre des des des immigrés
illégaux en France. Euh
ancien préfet de police, comment il
s'appelle déjà ? Comment est-ce qu'on
peut penser quand vous avez chaque année
euh 500000 personnes qui entrent
légalement Laurent Nugèz quand vous avez
chaque année 500000 personnes qui
entrent légalement en France depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été élu président
de la République, comment est-ce qu'on
peut penser que ça créait pas un sujet
de de d'équipement, d'infrastructure de
enfin c'est c'est logique en je veux
dire c'est euh ces personnes pourraient
unir de de d'où qu'on veut. Ça ça ajoute
euh de manière effective, c'est comme si
chaque année on construisait
l'équivalent d'une des grandes
agglomérations françaises. Ça ça ne peut
pas ne pas avoir de conséquences sur
encore une fois ça à Mayot ça se voit
d'une manière encore plus dense mais
c'est la réalité de la France.
Mayot, Mayot, tu nous manques. On va
bientôt venir te voir pour
faire un update de ce qui se passe
là-bas, histoire de ramener d'une façon
très crue votre réalité.
Question internet. Le règlement de
blocage européen existe depuis 1996 pour
protéger nos entreprises contre les
sanctions extraterritoriales
américaines. Pourtant, personne ne
l'utilise. BNP Paris paye 9 milliards.
Alstom est démantelé. Les entreprises
européennes préfèrent plier devant
Washington. L'Europe a créé un outil
qu'elle n'ose pas utiliser. Où est la
souveraineté quand nos propres lois
restent l'être morte ?
Mais je je reviens ce que je disais tout
à l'heure, je partage totalement le
constat. La vérité, c'est que
aujourd'hui l'Europe s'est placée sous
la protection des États-Unis pour sa
propre sécurité. Et donc à partir de là,
bah quand vous faites le choix de la
vassalité, vous assumez les
conséquences.
et et en particulier quand le président
des États-Unis s'appelle Donald Trump et
que et que et que tout le monde a bien à
l'esprit que d'un claquement de doigt
parce que il a un mouvement d'humeur, il
peut décider de de de quitter le temps,
de suspendre l'article 5. Pour nous,
tout ça paraît peut-être lointain, mais
pour nos pour nos amis polonais, Balt,
c'est c'est une expérience très concrète
que celle de se sentir
extraordinairement vulnérable. Et ça
explique aussi encore une fois ce deal
qui n'en est pas un signé signé cet été
par l'Union européenne.
Encore une question Gaë
Brigit, monté des populismes, guerre en
Ukraine, fracture nord-sud sur la dette,
blocage institutionnel permanent. 90 %
des Français pensent que le pays est en
déclin. Vous êtes au PPE, le parti qui
gouverne l'Europe depuis 70 ans. Le
projet actuel n'est-il pas à bout de
souffle ?
Il il est à bout de souffle. Et moi, je
suis pas rentré au PPE et je suis pas
rentré chez LR parce qu'en fait c'est la
même chose. Euh
je suis pas rentré au PPE parce que
j'étais d'accord avec tout ce que le PPE
avait fait ou tout ce que le PPE
faisait. Vous faites pas, je suis rentré
là-bas pour le changer de l'intérieur et
ainsi de suite.
Bah si,
on a peut-être un désaccord, mais dans
ce cas-là, qu'est-ce que je vais vous
répondre ? Ne me faites pas aller, on va
arriver dans le parlement pour créer
quelque chose de complètement nouveau et
qui Non, en fait, il faut aller là où ça
se passe. Moi, je me suis toujours senti
de droite. Je crois au clivage.
Ça veut dire quoi droite ?
Ça veut dire c'est assez simple en fait.
Je pense que toutes les grandes
démocraties, toutes les démocraties
occidentales ont vu émerger de manière
assez naturelle le clivage gauche-
droite qui a été structuré en France
pour la première fois pendant la
Révolution française. Le clivage gauche-
droite, il oppose deux visions du monde,
deux tempérament politiques. La gauche,
c'est une colère. La gauche, c'est une
révolte. C'est la volonté de de
transformer le monde, de changer le
monde. La gauche veut changer le monde.
C'est pour ça que la gauche veut la
révolution. Enfin, historiquement,
gauche
et la droite veut côtoyer le bourgeois.
C'est ça.
Et la gauche ? Non, la gauche c'est la
droite c'est une
de manière bien plus modeste, la droite
je dirais que c'est une forme
d'inquiétude.
La droite, je peux aller jusqu'au bout.
La droite c'est la volonté de pas de
transformer le monde mais de transmettre
ce qui dans le monde mérite d'être
préservé. La droite c'est le sens des
conditions nécessaires à la vie en
société qui sont infiniment fragiles et
qu'il faut protéger. et et que la droite
soit du côté des bourgeois. Euh le
cliché que vous venez de citer, c'est en
fait un truc qui date euh euh du
marxisme. En fait, le le marxisme a
profondément déréglé les catégories
politiques. Dire que je suis marxiste.
Non, pas du tout. Je dis qu'on est tous
héritiers de la perturbation du champ
magnétique de la vie politique
occidentale qui a été créée par le
marxisme.
Pourquoi à droite ?
Parce que le marxisme a fait que les
questions économiques sont devenues
centrales. Mais en fait la question elle
est pas fondamentalement. À droite, il y
a pas des gens qui veulent un petit peu
chambouler le truc ? euh pour dire bon
maintenant ça suffit. La droite c'est
les parties de vieux boomers qui
comprennent rien à rien qui pr qui
protègent simplement leur rente, leurs
statut leur positionnement. Ils sont pas
du coup tout connectés au réel. Pourquoi
la France insoumise récolte énormément
d'électorats jeunes ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi la droite récolte
pas trop d'électorat jeunes ?
Et ben il y a pas que la France
insoumise qui récolte un électorat
jeune.
Il y a qui ?
Bah tous les partis contestataires,
disons-le, d'une manière plus générale.
C'est quoi un parti contestataire ?
Le le premier parti chez les jeunes en
France, c'est pas la France insoumise,
hein. Faut pas laisser raconter cette
histoire, c'est le Rassemblement
national.
Donc le le le sujet mais encore une fois
le le le point commun d'ailleurs à ces
formations politiques, c'est de alors
pas LFI mais en tous les cas le RN lui
aussi conteste l'idée qu'il y a un
clivage entre la gauche et la droite.
Marine Le Pen en tous les cas conteste
ça et comme Emmanuel Macron. Emmanuel
Macron nous a dit c'est fini la gauche
et la droite c'est terminé maintenant
c'est en même temps. Maintenant le vrai
clivage c'est populisme contre
progressistme. Moi j'ai jamais cru à ça.
Je pense vraiment qu'il y a un clivage
entre la gauche et la droite. Et moi, je
me suis toujours senti d'un tempérament
de droite. Et donc euh en étant moi-même
souvent très frustré de ce que les
partis politiques en général faisaient
et le parti qui devait me représenter,
je me suis dit ben il y a deux options.
Soit je soit je me plains indéfiniment,
soit j'y rentre et j'essaie d'apporter
ce que je crois nécessaire pour
renouveler ce parti parce que le plus
important, c'est à travers lui de
renouveler le pays. Et c'est quand même
de ça qu'on parle. Les partis sont des
outils. Je je me moque éperdument. On se
moque éperdument des partis. La seule
chose qui compte, c'est la France. Et
donc, je suis rentré là pour essayer de
faire en sorte que les choses changent
dans la mesure où j'en suis capable par
mes forces et ma volonté. Et c'est aussi
pour ça que je suis au PPE au Parlement
européen. On parlait tout à l'heure
d'Ursula von Derleen. Ursula Van
Derleen, elle a été soutenu par une
grande partie du PPE. Je je j'assume une
ligne différente. J'ai aucun problème
avec ça. Je pense que ce qui compte,
c'est d'avoir
à l'intérieur de de de ce qui organise
le débat politique et le débat
démocratique, d'avoir le courage de
porter les idées qu'on croit nécessaires
pour pour l'avenir de de nos pays.
Question internet. Bonjour. Il y a eu
monsieur Tangy qui a soutenu le rapport
parlementaire sur les ingérences au
niveau français. S'en est-il inspiré ?
Euh, quel rapport parlementaire ?
C'est pas marqué sur les ingérences
étrangères.
Euh,
je l'ai pas lu.
Oui, je sais pas de quel rapport on
parle exactement.
Euh, descends un petit peu là les
questions. Tu es forte.
Est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un autre
rapport parlementaire très intéressant
sur les inérences étrangères ? Ouais.
Le rapport de madame Chikirou sur la
Chine.
Chikirou sur la Oui.
Comment ça se fait que ce truc n'ait pas
fait un scandale total ?
Pourquoi la Chine elle elle vient fort ?
Sopia Shikirou fait un rapport
parlementaire. Je sais pas quelle est la
forme du document. En tout cas, elle
produit un document de l'Assemblée
nationale puisquelle est la rapporteur.
Ouais.
Stupéfiant. Vous l'avez lu ?
Non mais regardez ça. C'est
extraordinaire. La Chine est une
démocratie. C'est un facteur de
stabilité, de paix, d'harmonie,
d'équilibre. C'est un panégérique de la
Chine. Si on veut s'intéresser aux
ingérances étrangères, j'ai l'impression
que la France insoumise adore toutes les
dictatures queles qu'elles soit. Alors,
visiblement, il y a un coup de foudre
entre madame Chikirou et le régime
chinois.
C'est gratuit.
Ben non, mais c'est stupéfiant. On parle
d'ingérence étrangère, il faut regarder
où elles sont hein et par où elles
passent. Et
est-ce qu'on s'intéresse à autre chose
que les ingérences étrangères des
dictatures ? Est-ce qu'on s'intéresse à
aux ingérences étrangères ? Je dirais
par exemple britannique,
est-ce que vous avez repéré des je fais
un petit appel du coup d' finissent par
un e et ça commence par un d.
Les ingérences britanniques en France et
en Europe, est-ce que vous êtes fait
tamponner par des par des ros beefs ?
J'ai eu l'occasion de de négociation
assez rude avec les Britanniques parce
que je
je parle pas de négociation. Est-ce que
vous avez
l'attaché culturel de l'ambassade
d'Angleterre ?
Non,
jamais.
J'ai déjà échangé avec la
Est-ce que votre assistante s'est fait
tamponner par les Anglais ?
Non.
Non. Est-ce que les Américains ont
essayé de venir vous chercher ? Ah oui,
bien sûr. Pour le coup, les Américains,
on a on a quand même Mais après,
qu'est-ce que vous appelez Non mais on
parle avec les diplomaties des pays euh
étrangers. Ça pour le coup, c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas scandaleux hein, y
compris pour se dire les choses. J'ai
été à Washington deux fois cette année
euh et notamment pour des conversations
parfois très très rudes avec les
Américains, typiquement sur le sujet de
ce texte européen sur l'industrie de
défense parce que eux il étaient eux il
y étaient extrêmement opposés.
Et ben bien sûr et j'ai été au
département d'État il y a quelques
semaines et on a eu une conversation
très franche et moi j'ai dit aux
Américains les yeux dans les yeux voilà
je pense qu'il faut se dire la vérité je
leur ai dit vous nous reprochez nous
européens d'avoir été pendant très
longtemps les passagers clandestins de
la défense américaine. Dans votre esprit
il y a le col bleu américain qui paye
parce qu'il travaille dur pour défendre
les Européens qui eux ne payent pas pour
se défendre eux-mêmes. Les Européens
avec ce pognon construisent des
sécurités sociales magnifiques pendant
que le travailleur américain doit se
payer une assurance privée qui lui
rembourse pas au moment où il a un
cancer. Et donc vous vous dites que
c'est terminé et que maintenant chacun
se débrouille et que les Européens
doivent mettre 5 % de leur PIB dans leur
défense et que ça suffit comme ça de de
de jouer
les profiteurs. OK, vous avez le point,
c'est vrai. Enfin, objectivement, qui
peut leur donner tort ? Mais maintenant,
si vous considérez qu'on doit être plus
autonome, bah on va être plus autonome.
Et si vous voulez qu'on mette 5 % de
notre pipe dans la défense, ben on va le
mettre dans notre industrie de défense.
Et c'est comme ça que ça doit se passer.
Vous pouvez pas à la fois nous demander
d'être indépendant et d'être dépendant.
C'est pas possible. Mais si je dis ça au
département d'État, j'imagine que vous y
verrez pas malice. Il faut aussi parler
avec les gens avec qui on n pas
d'accord. C'est à ça que ça sert la
diplomatie.
Surtout parler avec les gens avec
lesquels on n pas d'accord. Surtout.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Sinon, ça sert à quoi de parler ? Non,
c'est quand les gens se parlent, ils
évitent de se taper dessus.
Ouais.
Quand vous allez aux États-Unis, vous
prenez un téléphone neuf.
Non,
vous allez dire que je suis naïf.
Ouais, mais ça tout le monde l'a vu,
hein. Question question internet.
Euh, faites monter les meilleures
questions, s'il vous plaît.
Pourquoi l'Europe serait-elle un combat
si c'est si bien ?
J'ai pas dit que c'était bien,
j'ai dit que c'était un combat.
Il y a plein de trucs qui vont pas bien
du tout en Europe et je passe mon temps
à j'ai plutôt l'impression de de passer
mon temps à combattre tous les délires
qui se sont accumulés en particulier au
cours des dernières années plutôt que de
de de consentir béatement à tout tout ce
qui se décide dans les institutions
européennes. Non, l'Europe c'est un
combat. Mais tout à l'heure vous disiez
sur les questions est-ce qu'il faut
quelqu'un posé la question ? On n'a pas
répondu et d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion
de présenter nos excuses à cet
internaute. Est-ce qu'il faut sortir de
l'espace Schengen pour Oui, je fais de
la politique pardon. Est-ce qu'il faut
sortir de l'espace Schengen pour
reprendre le contrôle sur l'immigration
? Schengen ou pas Schengen,
l'Europe est une réalité. C'est une
réalité physique, c'est une réalité
économique, c'est une réalité
historique, culturelle. Et cette
réalité-là, on pourra pas y échapper.
C'est-à-dire que vous pouvez euh annuler
Bruxelles, vous pouvez oublier Schengen,
vous pouvez faire tomber toutes les
commissions que vous voulez. Euh et
c'est pas l'envie qui manque parfois,
mais à la fin euh si demain la Grèce ou
l'Italie ou l'Espagne sont submergés par
des flux migratoires
euh qui sont qui sont qui sont pas
gérés,
c'est déjà le cas, hein.
C'est déjà le cas. ça a des conséquences
sur nous quoi qu'il arrive avec ou sans
l'Europe. Donc le sujet c'est euh
comment on fait en sorte euh de relever
ensemble des défis qui nous sont
communs. Et de ce point de v-à, l'Europe
n'est ni bien ni pas bien. C'est
comment on fait pour éviter que la
Méditerranée soit un cimetière ?
Bah c'est très simple, on on retrouve
des frontières.
Je suis rapporteur au Parlement
européen. C'est le prochain combat qui
qui s'engage sur le règlement retour. Le
règlement retour, c'est le texte qui va
euh remplacer la directive retour qui
existe aujourd'hui depuis 2008. C'est le
textes européens qui concerne les
expulsions.
En Europe, il y a une statistique facile
à vérifier. Euh si vous avez été
identifié comme
résident illégalement sur le sol
européen, en France par exemple, si vous
avez reçu un OQTF, vous avez en Europe
en moyenne 23 % de chance d'être
reconduit dans votre pays, c'est-à-dire
rien. Imaginez le code de la route s'il
y avait 80 % des gens qui 77 % des gens
qui qui passaient au rouge, ça tiendrait
plus du tout. Donc le le fait est que
c'est la grande,
j'ouvre une parenthèse. Euh les immigrés
irréguliers en France, même si c'est
irrégulier, ils foutent pas tous le
bordel.
J'ai pas dit ça.
D'accord.
Ils sont juste illégalement là. Donc ça
veut dire que vous avez constamment
notre droit est constamment violé et pas
seulement notre droit mais des décisions
de justice.
Ceux qui foutent le bordel c'est
pourquoi ils sont pas expulsés
directement ?
Mais parce qu'en fait personne n'est
expulsé. Et pourquoi personne n'est
expulsé ? à cause du droit européen.
Parce que la directive retour, c'est une
des raisons, mais c'est la raison la
plus marquante. La directive retour et
toutes les jurisprudences construites
autour de la directive retour par toutes
les cours nationales et européennes.
Toutes ces jurisprudences ont désarmé
nos états et font que effectivement, et
c'est ce que les Français ne peuvent
plus supporter et moi non plus et je les
comprends, effectivement quelqu'un à qui
on a délivré un un OQTF a très peu de
chance d'être reconduit. Il a été
débouté du droit d'asile. Ça ça son
refus a été confirmé une fois, deux
fois, trois fois après autant de recours
et pourtant ben il restera là. Et
comment est-ce qu'on évite que la
Méditerranée devienne un cimetière en
mettant fin à ça ? Aujourd'hui, il est
parfaitement clair pour le monde entier
que si vous arrivez à poser le pied,
même illégalement sur le sol européen,
vous y resterez pour toujours. Et c'est
pour ça que des gens risquent leur vie
en Méditerranée.
Si la gauche était sincère et qu'elle
voulait vraiment mettre fin à tout ce
business immonde des passeurs, qu'elle
voulait mettre fin à ce trafic d'êtres
humains qui a lieu sous nos yeux
aujourd'hui à nos frontières, mais elle
devrait se battre pour qu'on expulse les
illégaux. Parce que le jour où il sera
parfaitement clair dans le monde entier
que si vous mettez le pied illégalement
sur le sol européen, vous n'avez aucune
chance d'y rester, ce jour-là, plus
personne ne passe la frontière, plus
personne n'essaie de rentrer, plus
personne ne risque sa vie en traversant
la Méditerranée. Regardez ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis pour le coup. Ça,
c'est la démonstration que Trump a fait
sous nos yeux. Il y avait chaque année
300000 passages de migrants irréguliers
entre le Mexique et les États-Unis.
Cette année zéro. Pourquoi ? Parce que
Trump a mis en scène le fait que
maintenant ceux qui étaient illégalement
aux États-Unis étaient renvoyés chez eux
sans ménagement. Et ben évidemment du
coup ça vous dissuade un peu de tenter
votre aventure.
Le Mexique il les accepte.
Bah il a pas le choix.
C'est-à-dire
bah c'est-à-dire que en l'occurrence il
faut effectivement mettre en œuvre une
politique de la force. Et et c'est très
simple. Et l'Europe en a les moyens.
Ah bon ?
Bah oui.
Ah oui.
Il faut faire la même chose que les
États-Unis. Par exemple conditionnalité
sur les visas. Si vous ne coopérez pas
sur le plan sur le plan migratoire, vous
n'aurez plus un seul visa d'un seul pays
européen. Bah, je peux vous dire que ce
jour-là, un pays réfléchit à deux fois.
Comment on fait pas ça avec l'Algérie ?
Ben, c'est la question que je me pose.
C'est la question qu'a posé Bruno
Rotaillot pendant des mois au ministère
de l'intérieur.
On fait peut-être son gaz.
Non, même pas seulement. Je pense que ça
dépasse ça. La France est pas la plus
intéressée au gaz algérien. L'Italie
oui.
Ils ont peut-être pas tant que c'est
rien. En plus,
l'Italie est très intéressée par le gaz
algérien et ça mais nous c'est pas on a
un autre modèle. Je je crois pas qu'il y
ait quelque raison que ce soit de
dépendance. Il y a juste une faiblesse
organisée. Enfin une faiblesse
intrinsèque, intériorisée, une faiblesse
qui est devenue un crédau de la part de
nos de nos dirigeants.
Question internet. Le marché européen de
l'énergie avec ses mécanismes de
fixation des prix alignés sur le gaz a
contribué à l'explosion des factures des
français.
Vrai
facture d'électricité et facture
d'énergie des français. Faut-il en
sortir pour retourner pour retrouver
notre souveraineté énergétique et
protéger notre modèle nucléaire ? Où
peut-on le réformer de l'intérieur ?
Et ben, on a déjà travaillé à le
réformer et c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons qui fait que les factures
d'électricité ont baissé ces derniers
mois.
euh pour la première fois depuis
longtemps. Euh et typiquement, c'est un
exemple intéressant, la même chose que
Shengen. En fait, j'ai entendu beaucoup
de gens dire il faut sortir du marché
européen de l'électricité. En fait, il y
a un marché européen de l'électricité,
enfin, il y a un marché mondial de
l'énergie et il y aura toujours un
marché européen de l'électricité parce
qu'en fait, on va continuer de vendre et
d'acheter de l'énergie à nos voisins, de
vendre et d'acheter de l'électricité à
nos voisins parce qu'on est une plaque
géographique, on est une plaque
électrique et et d'ailleurs la France a
beaucoup gagné au marché européen de
l'électricité parce que on est pour le
coup, c'est un des derniers trucs qu'on
sait vendre, on vend de l'électricité à
nos voisins. Donc on a une activité
excédentaire sur le plan commercial en
matière d'électricité. Merci le général.
Merci le général. Alors aujourd'hui, bon
c'est un peu catastrophique parce qu'on
subventionne des éoliennes qu'on finance
à grand prix et avec ces éolienne en
fait on subventionne maintenant la
consommation de nos voisins, ce qui est
absolument stupéfiant. On détruit nos
paysages, on abîme la biodiversité, on
construit des infrastructures avec des
turbines chinoises qui vont fonctionner
30 ans et qu'on sera pas recyclé. Tout
ça pour payer que le contribuable
français paye pour l'électricité que les
Allemands utilisent.
tout faux sur toute la ligne mais ça
change rien au fait que malgré tout on a
tiré avantage de ce marché de
l'électricité et que en fait vous avez
beau abolir l'Europe et abolir
Bruxelles, il y aura toujours un marché
européen électricité. En fait c'est
c'est une réalité économique basique. La
France va pas devenir la Grande-Bretagne
et même d'ailleurs la Grande-Bretagne
est interconnectée mais enfin en tous
les cas on va pas se détacher du
continent pour vivre en autarsie. Donc
le le le vrai sujet, c'est comment on
fait en sorte que les règles du jeu
soient les bonnes. Et c'est là-dessus
qu'on s'est battu et on a obtenu, on
s'est on s'est bataillé sur le sujet
aussi avec des parlementaires nationaux
d'ailleurs et c'est l'occasion de dire à
quel point on continue de penser à
Olivier Marlex qui a été l'un des l'un
des grands artisans de ce combat.
Paix à son âme.
Paix à son âme et on continuera son
combat. Mais on on s'est battu
précisément pour changer les règles du
jeu du marché européen l'électricité. le
marché de l'électricité, il avait des
facto, c'était pas un principe de droit,
mais dans les faits, à cause du principe
de la dernière centrale appelée, il
avait corrélé le prix de l'électricité
au prix du gaz. Et c'est pour ça qu'en
effet, comme le dit très bien votre
internaute, au moment où le prix du gaz
a explosé, alors que les coûts de
production de l'électricité n'avaient
eux pour le coup pas bougé, on a vu
exploser les factures d'électricité des
Français et ça a mis en danger bien sûr
non seulement les les ménages et les
foyers, mais ça a mis en danger aussi
beaucoup d'entreprises et notamment
beaucoup de PME, de TPE, je pens les
boulangers et cera on s'est battu à leur
côté pour réformer cette règle du jeu et
notamment pour réautoriser ce que
l'Union européenne avait jusque là
interdit, c'est le principe même du long
terme pour faire en sorte que on sorte
d'un prix de fixation de l'électricité
qui était essentiellement calé sur le
sur le sur le spot et qu'on redonne aux
acteurs économiques la possibilité de
souscrire des contrats à long terme. Et
c'est ça qui fait que EDF connaissance
et coûts de production d'électricité,
les industriels en particulier et les
les acteurs économiques sachant ce coût
de production, on peut rapprocher le
prix d'achat de l'électricité de son
prix de production. Et c'est c'était le
le combat essentiel et on l'a fait dans
la dernière année du dernier mandat et
aujourd'hui cette réforme, elle est déjà
en train de porter une partie de ces
fruits. C'est pas terminé parce que le
plus important c'est bien sûr de
réformer le marché. On a encore du
travail à faire là-dessus mais le plus
important c'est d'abord de travailler
sur la production parce que vous pouvez
réformer un marché mais vous pouvez pas
réformer le principe de l'économie
fondamentale qui est que tout ce qui est
rare est cher et si l'énergie est rare
bah elle est forcément chère et donc il
faut travailler à la production et ça
c'est le sujet de la PPE et ça c'est un
sujet national. Si je vous dis bel ami à
l'échafaud.
Bon, ça m'a fait doucement sourire.
C'était le slogan de de quelques
manifestants croisé devant la gare du
Nord il y a quelques semaines. C'était
assez étonnant. J'arrive Gard du Nord
pour prendre mon train pour aller à
Bruxelles. Je tombe sur c'était le jour
d'une manifour des miracles. Toujours la
guerre du Nord.
La guerre du Nord, c'est l'angoisse
hein. L'image pour la France.
nos collègues au Parlement européen qui
vont à Paris qui arrivent gard du nord,
ils reviennent en disant "Mais qu'est-ce
qui vous arrive ?" C'est c'est le truc
le plus douloureux que je vis au
Parlement européen,
c'est passé par Guerre du Nord,
c'est pas c'est pas l'hostilité de nos
voisins. Parce que parfois on se dit
nous français, "Ouais, tout le monde
nous en veut, les Allemands nous font la
guerre.
Et les Allemands nous font la guerre.
Mais le truc le plus difficile à vivre,
c'est pas le fait que on ait des parties
difficiles à jouer. Je suis d'accord
avec vous. Ce qu'il y a de magnifique
quand on se parle, c'est qu'on évite de
se taper dessus. Et aujourd'hui,
effectivement, l'Europe, c'est un combat
de tous les jours, mais c'est un combat
qui passe par des négociations très
rudes et très exigeante euh mais mais
qui nous évite au moins de régler nos
différents par des des des tranchées et
des bayonnettes. Le fait est que le plus
dur, c'est pas ces combats-là. Le plus
dur, je trouve, le plus éprouvant à
vivre, c'est le regard de compassion,
une forme de de
commisération, je dirais, euh que les
les les Européens portent sur nous. Mais
mais qu'est-ce qui vous arrive ? Mais
mais de gens qui disent et je l'entends
partout quand je voyage, de gens qui
disent "Mais on aime la France, on tient
à la France." le braquage du Louvre.
Mais c'est une raison de plus pour
beaucoup de pays de se dire "Mais le
Louvre, le plus grand musée du monde,
c'est au Louvre que le concept de musée
a été inventé. C'est le premier musée de
l'histoire. C'est là qu'on a inventé
l'idée de mettre des tableaux sur les
murs pour que les gens puissent venir
les voir et pas pour décorer des palais.
Euh et ben aujourd'hui euh on se fait
voler par des c'est pas c'est une
lumain, c'est des types en camionnettes
électriques avec des des avec des
scooters Tmax. C'est c'est l'incendie de
Notre Dame ça. Ça a touché l'Europe
entière et les images de la France les
l'accident de Notredame jusqu'à la
jusqu'à preuve du contraire, c'est un
accident, du moins c'est
un accident mal géré.
Elle l'ouvre chez les hackeurs, il y a
des pen test, des tests d'intrusion que
ce soit sur votre PC mais sur les
infrastructures physiques.
Donc je vous donne un exemple concret
là. Très récemment, on a reçu chez nous
quelques copains. Ils avaient un peu de
matos qui coûtaient excessivement cher
dans leur valise. Ils avaient de quoi
crocheter des serrures, dupliquer des
cartes.
Vous avez des amis étonnants ?
Oui. Oui. Et surtout des des serviteurs
de la France et des boîtes. C'est c'est
des white hats. C'est des des corsaires
qui défendent les boîtes, qui défendent
l'État. Ils ont une une éthique
irréprochable. Euh euh ils veulent
durcir notre business pour éviter qu'on
se fasse euh enfoncer par les Chinois,
les Russes, les Américains, les
Britanniques, les Qataris. Ils ont la
France cheville au corps et euh ils font
des tests d'intrusion pour des boîtes et
sont très très bons.
Le Louvre, il y a pas des pen test, des
tests d'inttrusion. On nous dit que
c'est des nouvelles formes de
cambriolage.
Bon, à une échelle est relativement
rudimentaire, on est d'accord. C'est du
foutage de gueule ça.
Bien sûr.
Donc revenons à la Guerre du Nord.
Et donc la garde du Nord, c'est c'est
une expérience de de ce décrochage
français à soi seul. Mais tout ça pour
dire que non, je suis arrivé gard du
nord, j'allais prendre mon train pour
aller à Bruxelles
et et je tombe sur ce groupe de
manifestants qui qui étaient supposés
défendre les droits sociaux mais qui
avaient surtout des drapeaux
palestiniens. Et donc ils m'ont reconnu
et le le réflexe un peu spontané a été
de commencer à scander Bami à
l'échafaud. C'est c'est ce qui est ce
qui est en tant que tel intéressant
parce que c'est pas un slogan si
habituel que ça. Enfin, ils ont le droit
de pas m'apprécier mais mais c'est
amusant ce retour de la guillotine dans
les manifes de LFI. C'était des
cela étant dit manifestement pour Rima
Hassan, même les Palestiniens qui ont eu
le tort de résister au Hamas sont sont
susceptibles d'être exécutés sans
jugement. Donc après tout, ça a l'air
d'être une forme de légitimation assez
courante, y compris à l'étranger, y
compris envers les Palestiniens de la
violence politique.
Alors, tu as bougé, excuse-moi, tu as
bougé. Reviens à la question que j'avais
sélectionné concernant la défiance. Tuen
bouges pas, redescends. Excusez-moi.
Non, non, je vous en prie. Euh voilà, je
vous pose la question sur Bamierchau
parce que la la question que je vais
lire de Bousil Bonjour son avis sur la
dérive démocratique en France et
l'exaspération du peuple face aux
tambouilles politiciennes et la haine
contre son patron Macron.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu comprends que
les les Français commencent à en avoir
la casquette ? qui se font déboîter en
taxe. On a des infrastructures pour
aller à l'ostau, pour trouver un
dermato, un oftalmo ou quoi que ce soit,
ça devient compliqué. Ils se font
déboîter en taxe. On se tape une
inflation enri
note qui vient d'être dégradée. On nous
regarde d'une façon
bon à la guerre du Nord, vous êtes
déclassé, l'ouvre, vous passez encore
pour des crétins. Et en plus, est-ce que
l'exaspération des Français quand elle
va se matérialiser ?
à l'ancienne façon traditionnelle
parce que nous on aime bien les
régicides, c'est historique.
Tu as peur pour toi ?
Non, moi j'ai j'ai peur pour la
démocratie parce que je pense que la
démocratie c'est effectivement un
miracle assez fragile et qu'aujourd'hui
elle est en train d'être très
profondément abîmée.
Tuas pas l'impression que la démocratie
s'est basée sur de l'énergie bon marché
? Quand tu as plus de de d'énergie bon
marché, bah ta démocratie avec c'est
c'est la démocratie, elle peut traverser
y compris des crises assez rudes. Mais
le problème c'est que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui, c'est une forme de dénit de
démocratie.
C'est ça qu'on a vécu dans les dernières
semaines. Là, c'est un c'est un chaos
pas possible et plus personne y comprend
rien. Mais ce qu'on a vécu, et je le dis
là en parlant de ce qu'on a vécu aussi
chez LR, ce qu'on a vécu avec Bruno
Retaillot, c'est en fait un de
démocratie.
Quand
la dissolution a eu lieu, Emmanuel
Macron a perdu les élections. Il a
déclenché une dissolution, il a perdu
les élections. C'était la deuxième fois.
2022 déjà il avait perdu les élections.
En 2024 il demande aux Français de
voter. Les Français votent, il perdent.
Personne ne gagne. Situation difficile.
À ce moment-là, Emmanuel Macron a choisi
un Premier ministre qui ne venait pas de
son camp. il a choisi un premier
ministre qui était euh dans le camp de
ses opposants. Michel Barnier, il
appartenait pas au macronisme. Euh il
avait jamais été il avait jamais été
macroniste. Et donc on nous a dit bah
voilà, maintenant il faut il faut
rentrer au gouvernement pour réussir à
stabiliser le pays dans un contexte où
il y a pas de majorité. et on s'est dit
ben on va s'efforcer de faire au mieux
pour être utile au pays. Bien sûr, on n
pas non plus gagné les élections, donc
on prétend pas qu'on doivent gouverner
tout seul mais on attendra l'alternance
pour faire vraiment tout ce qu'on pense
être utile au pays si les Français nous
font confiance. Mais en attendant, on va
faire tout ce qu'on
pense devoir faire pour être utile au
pays. Le problème, c'est que quand
Emmanuel Macron a nommé Sébastien
Lecornu, François Bairou s'était imposé
à lui. Quand Emmanuel Macron a nommé
Sébastien Lecnu, c'était plus du tout le
même esprit. Il a nommé quelqu'un qui
est au cœur de son camp. Et le sujet est
pas personnel, c'est pas Sébastien
Lecornu, c'est pas une question de
personne, mais c'est une question
politique profondément. Camp ou à sa
botte ? B en tous les cas quelqu'un qui
a été l'un de ses principaux soutiens,
l'un de ses principaux alliés et qui par
conséquent prend ses ordres à l'Élysée.
Et ce que les Français ont découvert
quand Sébastien Lecnu a publié son
premier gouvernement, c'est que la liste
de ce gouvernement, elle avait été faite
pas à Matignon, elle avait été faite
dans le bureau du président. Et c'est ça
le problème majeur. Emmanuel Macron a
perdu les élections. Alors on peut
spéculer indéfiniment sur la question de
savoir s'il faut qu'il démissionne ou
pas.
Peut-être le général de Gaulle avait
tiré en 69 la conséquence que il devait
s'en aller puisqu'il avait été désavoué
par les Français, pensait-il, à cause
d'un référendum manqué sur la
régionalisation. Bon, il était parti.
Il y avait pas des intérêts derrière qui
ont stimulé un peu tout ça ?
Oh non, je crois que c'était je crois
pas que le général de Gaul était connu
pour obéir à beaucoup d'intérêts
extérieurs.
Non non, c'est mes 68 derrière c'était
tout clair cette histoire. Il y avait
pas des intérêts étrangers pour exciter
un peu tout le monde
peut-être. Mais c'est encore une autre
histoire. Charles Legaul a décidé que
quand il avait été désavoué par les
Français parce qu'il leur avait proposé
un référendum et qu'il avait perdu, il
est parti. Peut-être que Emmanuel Macron
pourrait en tirer la même conséquence,
mais c'est même pas nécessaire en fait.
Euh je veux dire par là que François
Mitteran, Jacques Chirac ont été
président de la République. Ils ont
aussi perdu les législatives et donc ils
ont accepté que ils étaient à l'Élysée,
qui qui représentaient la France à
l'étranger mais que pour le reste c'est
le gouvernement qui était indépendant
d'eux. Et je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut retrouver, qu'il faudrait retrouver
aujourd'hui parce que qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'ils se disent les Français
? Et ils ont parfaitement raison. Ils se
disent "On a voté une fois en 2022 pour
dire qu'on voulait pas donner une
majorité à Emmanuel Macron. Il nous
redemande notre avis en 24. On lui redit
la même chose et il continue de
gouverner comme si rien ne s'était
passé. Il continue de tout diriger
depuis l'Élysée comme si on avait jamais
voté." Mais c'est ça le démocratie.
C'est pour ça qu'on a quitté le
gouvernement. parce qu'on s'est dit nous
on voulait être utile au pays, on
voulait pas être la caution d'une forme
de d'acharnement. C'est le mot de
Gabriel Atal lui-même, d'avoir
qui va miner de l'intérieur la confiance
dans la vie démocratique.
Il y a pas une dérive autoritaire un peu
de l'Europe en ce moment entre chat
contrôle ? C'est quoi chat contrôle ?
Chat contrôle, c'est euh c'est un débat
que je suis avec beaucoup d'attention,
mais c'est pas la la décision est pas
prise. C'est la présidence actuelle du
Conseil européen qui est assurée par le
Danemark qui a proposé cette option,
mais elle a pas été retenue. Je le dis
parce qu'on reçoit plein de mails sur le
sujet et je comprends très bien
l'inquiétude des gens qui s'expriment.
Mais aujourd'hui, ça ça cette
proposition n'a pas été adoptée.
Vous connaissez Munique ?
Munique ?
Oui. La ville ou les accords de Munique
ou ?
Oui.
Vous connaissez J Evans ?
Ouais. Ah oui, le discours Dominique.
Ouais, oui, j'ai écouté le discours
Dominique. Moi, j'ai j'ai beaucoup
d'intérêt pour JD Vans. J'ai lu Il y qui
est vraiment un livre exceptionnel euh
vraiment euh et en plus euh très drôle,
ce qui ne gâche rien mais surtout une
plongée magnifique dans l'Amérique dont
il est issu.
Mais sur le discours de qui vient nous
faire je DVens qui vient de nous faire
la leçon sur la liberté d'expression
sur le discours de Munique, je me
permets d'avoir quand même
un un petit désaccord quand même d'abord
parce que je crois qu'il faut qu'on
affronte nos problèmes.
Désaccord parce que vous êtes petit
bras.
Non non, je je disais ça de manière
euphémistique parce que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on affronte nous-même nos
problèmes et que j'aime jamais recevoir
des leçons des autres pour commencer et
puis deuxièmement parce que ce serait
bien que les États-Unis règlent leurs
propres problèmes avec la liberté
d'expression. Non mais OK
quand il vient nous faire la leçon
en fait il vient défendre les intérêts
des gafas on va pas se mentir il vient
défendre les intérêts des grandes
plateformes américaine quand il y a
quand il y a le camp Biden qui nous fait
euh les Twitter files. Vous connaissez
les Twitter files
ou
bah les Twitter files ça concernait
aussi assez directement la France he
les les Facebook files et j'en passé des
meilleurs
et qu'ensuite les Américains viennent
nous faire des leçons sur la liberté
d'expression. C'est pour ça que je
disais qu'il faudrait peut-être qu'il
résolve leur propre problème américain.
C'est pas le camp démocrate.
Bien sûr. Enfin, je suis pas totalement
sûr plus que le camp républicain soit
totalement au clair avec le sujet.
Le DSA, c'est quoi le DSA ?
Le DSA, c'est la la régulation
européenne qui doit s'appliquer au
secteur du digital, au secteur du
numérique.
Vous avez suivi l'audition de du
monsieur qui travaille chez YouTube
France ?
Non.
De Facebook France et de Twitter France.
Vous avez suivi ça ?
Non. Ils ont été auditionnés où ? Euh si
mes souvenirs sont bons, je demande à me
faire fa checker, je crois, à
l'assemblée par l'assemblée
quand il y a le monsieur de chez YouTube
France et on diffuse en ce moment aussi
sur YouTube qui dit "Bon, quand il y a
des contenus, je résume trivialement,
quand il y a des contenus qui sont
illégaux, bah on les dégage quand ça
viole notre nos conditions
d'utilisation, on les dégage aussi, ce
qui est normal, mais bon, quand il y a
des contenus qu'on aime pas trop voir
mais qui sont pas illégaux,
et qui ne viole pas nos conditions
d'utilisation. Bah, on se débrouille
pour
les rendre un peu invisibles.
Il dit ça littéralement,
pas littéralement, je aller voir ce
qu'il raconte, mais ça y ressemble à 100
%. Et euh la question que je me pose,
c'est est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse un
syndicat de youtubeur, qu'on les traîne
à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme parce que il se il s'essu un
petit peu avec la liberté d'expression
et que ça devient compliqué parce que
s'ils reçoivent le le coup de fil d'un
ministre
ou si Facebook reçoit le coup de fil
d'un ministre ou quelqu'un qui travaille
dans un ministère pour lui dire bon
celui-là il nous embête un peu. Tu vas
un petit peu me le me le shadow banner,
me l'anonymiser, me le mettre dans
l'ombre pour plus qu'il soit référencé
correctement. Puis bon, ils sont obligés
normalement de prévenir les gens, mais
on s'est un peu rendu compte dans le
passé que des fois ils sont pas si
transparents que ça et que ils
s'arrangent un petit peu de temps en
temps avec les lois.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce que
l'Europe doit défendre ? Est-ce que
l'Europe est contente ? Peut-être
non, l'Europe doit défendre la liberté
d'expression. Évidemment, c'est
absolument fondamental et le et le grand
risque qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui,
c'est
audition au Sénat, pardon.
Audition au Sénat. Merci beaucoup.
Non, j'ai pas vu cette audition mais je
je regarderai.
C'est cavi
ou je regarderai. Euh le le grand risque
aujourd'hui, c'est que ces plateformes
deviennent plus puissantes que nos
États. Euh qu'elles sont peut-être déjà
Le problème, c'est que quand ces
plateformes sont un peu cul et chemises
avec des gouvernements un peu durs,
Biden,
les Twitter files, les Facebook files,
non mais il faut pas croire que ça ait
échangé. Enfin, je veux dire par là que
les Américains ont des intérêts et ils
défendent leurs intérêts et ils
continueront de les défendre et on peut
avoir plus ou moins de sympathie pour la
ligne politique d'un gouvernement
américain ou d'un autre. Et ça change
rien au fait qu'on doit pas dépendre de
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis,
ne serait-ce que parce qu'on n'a pas
encore le droit de vote en dans le
Minesota. Donc on peut pas décider de
qui sera le prochain président
américain. Donc on doit pas subir ce que
la démocratie américaine devient. En
aucun cas dans un sens comme dans un
autre.
Et c'est clair que pour nous mais le
défi, il est global. Il y a il y a un
enjeu de de effectivement de régulation,
mais je crois que l'Europe a commis
l'immense erreur de se définir elle-même
comme c'était le grand rêve de la
puissance normative. On va être puissant
parce qu'on fait des normes. En fait, il
y a une sorte de répartition mondiale du
travail. C'estàd les États-Unis invent,
la Chine produit et l'Europe réglemente.
Mais ça ça marche pas. Vous pouvez pas
réglementer si vous savez plus inventer
et vous pouvez pas réglementer si vous
savez plus produire. Et donc il faut
aussi que c'est pas seulement la
question de la réglementation, c'est
aussi quelle est la stratégie qu'on se
donne pour avoir enfin un écosystème
digital qui qui gagne son son autonomie.
Question internet. Monsieur Benami, quel
est votre ou vos formations en
diplomatie, en géopolitique, vos mentors
?
Euh et bien je dois dire que mais je
crois que c'est c'est le sens de la
politique. La politique c'est pas un
métier, c'est pas une carrière. Et
d'ailleurs, je je
j'ai eu la chance d'aimer passionnément
mon métier et je serais très heureux d'y
retourner. Je m'engage dans la vie
politique pour un temps de ma vie. Donc
j'ai pas de formation spécifique en
géopolitique.
Vos mentors ?
Euh mon principal mentor sur le sujet
d'affaires des affaires étrangères. J'ai
eu la chance d'apprendre beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens mais si je devais
considérer quelqu'un comme mon mentor,
je dirais que celui qui m'a le plus
appris, c'est Arnaud d'Anjan.
Arnaud Donj avec qui j'ai été élu
pendant 5 ans qui a fait une grande
partie de sa carrière dans
euh à la DGSE et qui ensuite a été élu
au Parlement européen pendant trois
mandats et qui est vraiment pour moi
l'un des
celui qui a le regard le plus juste, le
plus complet, le plus lucide sur les
affaires internationales et qui m'a
beaucoup appris.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'un ancien
des services de renseignement soit élu ?
Ben c'est très précieux.
C'est-à-dire que Poutine, ancien des
services de renseignement très élu,
c'est très précieux.
Mais après le c'est pas parce que vous
avez une compétence que vous l'utilisez
bien, mais le fait est que on a quand
même besoin d'avoir aussi des gens qui
ont cette compéten là dans les
institutions publiques.
Quand on a été dans les
Moi, je crois que c'est très précieux
que en politique, il y ait pas des
professionnels de la politique.
D'accord. Et quand on a Non, mais les
services de renseignement, c'est très
spécial.
Oui, mais il faut des gens qui il faut
pas que des gens qui ont fait des
renseignements, il faut des gens qui
viennent de partout. Il faudrait qu'il
ait plus de gens en politique qui ont
fait autre chose que de la politique du
renseignement.
Le fait de se retrouver élu, c'est
problématique ou pas problématique ?
Je crois pas. Faudra demander à Arnaud.
Question internet et on va revenir sur
les mentors. Vous avez lu CL voit
quelqu'un qui a fait du renseignement,
c'est quelqu'un qui a servi la France.
OK.
Non, mais je suis d'accord mais qui se
retrouve à des à des à des postes élus.
Imaginez-vous le directeur des services
de renseignement français intérieur ou
extérieur ou s'il a fait les deux, il se
retrouve président de la République.
Ça vous pose un problème ou ça vous pose
pas de problème ?
Mais si le type est très bon, je vois
pas pourquoi ce serait un problème.
C'est
compliqué non ? Il y a peut-être des
dossiers sur tout le monde.
Pas forcément plus que que enfin
pas forcément plus que les autres partis
politiques. C'est ça.
J'en sais rien. Mais c'est c'est pas il
y a il y a pas que dans les
renseignements que que
enfin je sais pas je je vois pas
pourquoi ça poserait un problème
singulier. La seule question qui compte
c'est est-ce que la personne que vous
éisez a a la droiture la la consistance
le courage nécessaire. C'est c'est
Vous avez lu Raymond Aaron ?
J'ai lu Raymond Aaron. Oui,
Carl von Klauswitz.
J'ai lu Klausovitz.
Euh, qui d'autre ? Qui d'autre ?
Qui d'autre ? J'ai lu.
Oui.
Dans ce secteur là.
Ah euh mais en fait en matière
d'affaires internationale, vous savez
les les affaires HBS disaient que le
l'état de nature s'observe le mieux dans
les relations entre les États parce que
les relations entre les États dans
l'état social sont les relations des
individus dans l'état de nature. Donc
finalement,
et en latin, ça se dit comment ? Euh ben
non, la seule la seule devise latine
qu'on peut lire de qu'on peut retenir de
HS, c'est celle qui l'emprunte à l'autre
qui est homo omini loupous. Et ça pour
le coup, c'est la meilleure clé
d'explication des affaires
internationales. Est
au miniloup, vous avez même pas besoin
de mettre le verbe en temps, ça
fonctionne comme ça parfois.
Euh, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Il y a encore
question mais on va plus avoir le temps
de les passer. Euh quelles sont les
richesses matérielles de la France ? Le
pinard.
Et même ça et même ça est en danger.
L'agriculture, on n pas parlé
d'agriculture, il faut absolument
parler.
On parle d'agriculture. Le mercour, ça
se passe bien.
Bah le mercour, non, ça va être un
combat, un combat de plus,
mais ça peut bien se terminer.
Le problème du mercour, c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas l'accord commercial parce
que les accords commerciaux sont pas
forcément bons. Le problème du mercour,
c'est que l'agriculture est la variable
d'ajustement de cet accord commercial.
Or, l'agriculture c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté majeur.
Ben non, mais le problème c'est qu'il y
a beaucoup de gens en Europe qui savent
pas ça. Bon
ben bien sûr, je rencontre des
dirigeants européens qui me disent
"Écoutez, si les éleveurs beauvins sont
pas capables de faire la compétition
avec les aides de la Pâque, avec les
éleveurs argentins, écoutez, le mieux
c'est peut-être d'arrêter en fait." Bah
en fait non, parce que on a pensé la
même chose avec la pharmacie et
maintenant on a fait partir toute la
production de de de
toute la production de principes actif
de nos médicaments à l'extérieur de
l'Europe et on a découvert la réalité de
notre vulnérabilité au moment de la
crise du Covid parce que on a laissé la
Russie produire pour nous l'énergie pas
cher qui faisait tourner les usines
allemandes dès qu'on a découvert ce que
ça voulait dire au moment de la guerre
en Ukraine
et parce que demain il y aura peut-être
une crise alimentaire mondiale et que là
si on a plus d'éleveur Bovin, on se dira
qu'on était quand même très con de
signer signer le mercour
et et nos engrais aussi. C'est compliqué
les engrais non ? Bien sûr, mais pareil
les anglais qui compte aussi c'est après
vous réindustrialiser la France, ça veut
pas se remettre à tout produire
mais ça veut dire être capable
d'identifier les secteurs stratégiques
sur lesquels il faut investir et pour le
reste être capable d'identifier les
partenaires commerciaux diversifiés qui
permettent de de de
d'assurer la résilience de votre de
votre société même en cas de crise
majeure. Mais en revanche, le secteur
stratégique, eux pour le coup, ils
doivent être absolument préservés. Et la
question agricole de ce point de vue-là,
on en parle souvent comme d'un truc
assez folklorique comme la pêche. On
parle jamais de la pêche, mais la pêche
c'est fondamental aussi. Euh
l'agriculture et la pêche, c'est pas du
tout pour préserver nos paysages ou nos
savoir-faires traditionnels. Bien sûr
que ça compte et qu'on aime ce que font
les agriculteurs, mais ce qui compte
d'abord, c'est la sécurité du pays et la
sécurité alimentaire et une dimension
intégrante d'une stratégie de
souveraineté.
Sinon, on sera encore condamné à manger
de la brioche. C'est ça.
Et en plus importé.
Dernière question internet et après on
reprend. En tant que professeur de
philosophie, que pensent-il de Spinoza ?
Doit-on passer par la guerre pour
unifier l'Europe ou la dissoudre ? Point
interrogation, une solution politique
existe encore. Point interrogation, y
croit-il interrogation.
Je peux vous faire une confession ?
J'aime pas du tout Spinoza. J'avais un
j'avais un prof de philo qui était un
spinosiste absolu. S'il m'écoute, il va
il va il va être absolument furieux.
Mais c'est le moment de de le confesser.
Euh,
je mets ma robe.
Non, Spinoza. Oui, Spinoza, c'est
vraiment une pensée systématique. C'est
vraiment le système à l'état pur. Et
Nietzs a écrit dans dans
je sais plus quel est le livre où se
trouve cet aaphorisme, mais Nietzs a
écrit "Je haie les gens à l'esprit de
système et je les évite. La volonté du
système est toujours un manque de
probité.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours été
très hermétique à Spinoza. Je reconnais
un sujet qu'on a pas abordé rapide.
Ah il y en a tellement mais
alors trois livres
faut savoir conclure.
Trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Trois livres à conseiller.
Alors le dernier livre de Bruno Lemè
bien entendu.
Ah bah ça c'est une évidence. On en
parle même pas bien sûr.
Euh
non, trois livres, je suis en train de
terminer euh
un livre
magnifique qui s'appelle Falcon qui est
une biographie.
Alors juste je vous reprends, je me
méfie de tous les gens à système et je
les évite. La volonté du système est un
manque de loyauté.
Mais en fait, ça dépend de la
traduction, c'est
le crépuscule des idoles 188. crépuscule
des idoles. Magnifique.
Merci d'avoir
Revenons, revenons revenons à nos
bouquins.
Euh je suis en train de terminer un
livre magnifique qui s'appelle Falcon
euh qui est la biographie de Giovanni
Falcon et par Roberto Saviano. Saviano,
c'est celui qui a écrit Gomora, c'est un
c'est un bah vous connaissez. Voilà.
Mais c'est vraiment un très beau livre.
C'est un très beau livre sur euh euh le
courage d'un magistrat mafia et et c'est
un livre qui est pas du tout simpliste,
c'est pas blanc et noir, les gentils et
les méchants. C'est vraiment un livre
sur euh le courage et sur la peur et sur
euh le découragement et sur ce que ça
veut dire de se sentir presque
impuissant face à des à des des
tendances profondes à l'œuvre dans une
société. euh que que qu'on ne peut pas
se résigner à à accepter. Pourtant,
c'est vraiment un très beau livre.
J'aime beaucoup Saviano. Du coup, ça me
fait penser à un deuxième livre qu'il
faut absolument lire. Mais bon, ça c'est
une référence très classique. Euh parce
que je pense que c'est la meilleure Vous
aimez la prospective, c'était la
meilleure tentative de prospective sur
le déclin de l'Occident. C'est le déclin
du courage. Le discours de Sol Genin à
Harvard, c'est un tout petit livre,
c'est une conférence et Sol Genicine va
à Harvard après avoir
réussi à passer à l'Ouest. on pourrait
refaire des blagues soviétiques parce
qu'il y en a plein sur le sujet et tout
le monde s'attend à ce qu'il fasse le
grand éloge du modèle démocratique et
libéral et Sul Genitin regarde ses
interlocuteurs et il leur dit "Je je
viens de de du monde soviétique dont
j'ai dénoncé
euh dont j'ai dénoncé le le
l'effondrement moral." Mais en fait vous
êtes tout aussi menacé à cause du déclin
du courage. Et je pense que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui, c'est d'abord ça. C'est la
distance stupéfiante entre ce que les
dirigeants savent qu'il faudrait faire
et ce qu'ils font à la fin. Ils savent
pas.
Si si ils savent pas.
Si la vérité c'est que vous avez
savent pas. Ils ont pas vu venir la
guerre avec les Russes. Ils ont pas vu
l'augmentation des tensions. Ils font
aucune prospective sur l'énergie. Il y
en a pas il y en a pas un qui va voir
Totel ou Uramine ou pardon un producteur
d'uranium
pour aller faire de l'interception de
renseignement correctement. pas la peine
d'aller si loin. Je reviens sur le le la
suspension de la réforme des retraites.
C'est c'est ceux qui vous expliquaient
qu'elle était nécessaire qui la font
aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire que il y a une
différence majeure entre ce qu'on ce
qu'on pense devoir faire et ce que entre
et je pense que il faut regarder les
choses lucidement. C'est pas seulement
le problème de la classe politique,
c'est le problème de la société parce
qu'on parce qu'on choisit l'immédiateté
de la la préservation d'une forme de de
de
statut quo plutôt que d'affronter les
choix courageux qu'il faudra faire et et
et même des parties qui se disent
antisystème prospèrent sur une forme de
démagogie qui est aussi le symptôme du
déclin du courage.
Euh voilà. Le troisème livre, je dirais
ça fait un peu conseil de de profitique
c'est qui est évidemment là aussi un
classique absolu c'est le métier et la
vocation de politique de Weber political
berouf
de Max
Max Weber.
Vous avez enseigné un petit peu combien
de temps ?
La politique est un effort énergique et
tenace pour taroder des planches de bois
dures. C'est la dernière page du livre.
Il est parfaitement exact de dire, et
toute l'expérience historique le
confirme, que jamais dans le monde on
aurait pu atteindre le possible si l'on
s'était sans cesse et toujours attaqué à
l'impossible.
Et l'homme qui est capable de faire cela
doit être un chef dans le sens le plus
simple de ce terme. Celui-là seul qui
convaincu que le monde jugé de son
propre point de vue sera peut-être trop
petit ou trop mesquin pour recevoir ce
qu'il prétend avoir à lui offrir et qui
reste néanmoins capable de dire quand
même celui-là seul à la vocation de la
politique.
Vous avez vu notre interview de Sarah
Knafou ?
Vous allez Non, j'ai pas regardé. Elle
était très longue, il faut dire.
Bah la vote est très longue aussi. 3h 4
minutes et
déjà euh
vous allez peut-être fa checker.
J'espère que j'ai pas oublié les mots
mais
mais c'est c'est c'est vraiment un très
beau livre.
Vous avez enseigné combien de temps ?
J'ai enseigné 11 ans.
Où ça ?
J'ai enseigné comme beaucoup de jeunes
profs du public. D'abord j'étais TZR
donc chaque année, j'étais dans un
établissement différent. J'ai enseigné
en zone urbaines sensibles, j'ai
enseigné dans des coins ruraux, j'ai
enseigné dans un lycée hôtelier, j'ai
enseigné en STI, génie mécanique et
génie électronique. Enfin, c'était
c'était l'occasion de découvrir plein de
réalités pédagogiques différentes et
puis ensuite j'ai continué en prépa
littéraire pendant quelques années.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
Vous voulez dire
en général,
je sais pas, un seul conseil.
Moi, je pense qu'on vit dans un monde où
l'appauvrissement intérieur est la plus
grande de toutes les menaces. Et donc si
j'avais un conseil à donner, il est très
simple, il faut apprendre par cœur parce
que c'est la meilleure manière de lutter
contre cette espèce de desséchement qui
nous est imposé par ce monde de
l'immédiateté, par le monde des écrans
dans lequel je vis moi aussi bien sûr,
mais qui nous nous prive de la densité
intérieure que seul permet la
fréquentation euh des livres, de la
lecture qui sont la source de liberté à
laquelle la civilisation dont nous
sommes les héritiers a toujours été
puisé. Et donc, il faut lire et il faut
apprendre. et apprendre par cœur. La
mémoire, c'est comme un muscle. Quand on
apprend plus rien, on a plus de mémoire.
Il faut s'y remettre. Il faut qu'on s'y
remette tous.
Vous avez un avis sur l'intelligence
artificielle ?
Oui,
je je pense que ça devrait pas s'appeler
intelligence artificielle.
Je pense c'est un piège conceptuel.
Euh parce qu'en fait,
je pense que c'est une puissance de
calcul absolument phénoménale qui va
défier beaucoup de règles de nos
sociétés contemporaines et qui va
profondément bouleverser
le rapport de de de l'homme au monde et
à la condition humaine. Mais je crois
pas que ce soit de l'intelligence.
Et je pense que c'est
en fait derrière cette erreur de
dénomination, il y a beaucoup de risques
potentiels pour notre rapport à cette
technologie qui est en train de de se
déployer sous nos yeux. On pourrait en
parler longtemps.
François Xavier Bami. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]